OKAY AFTERNOON. AND WELCOME TO
OUR MAY REVISION HEARING. OUR
PANELISTS ARE PARA MULTI AND IN
PERSON TODAY. PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE TAKEN AT THE END THEY
CARRYING ON ALL TOPICS FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE'LL BEGIN WITH
THOSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
FOLLOWED BY PHONE TESTIMONY EACH
PERSON WILL HAVE UP TO ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK. THE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE STREAMING
THIS HEARING. THE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957. THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT US
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM WILL BEGIN WITH THE ROLL
CALL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL GARCIA
PRESIDENT JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
STONE WALDRON. THANK YOU. OKAY.
FOR ME PROCEED I WANTED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THE
TIRELESS WORK ON PUTTING
TOGETHER THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US
I WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WERE IN THEIR
INSIGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS INTO OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT STAFF FOR MAKING A
RITUAL HEARING POSSIBLE I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE PUBLIC FOR
PARTICIPATING- AND INFORMING.
OUR DELIBERATIONS. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY EVERY BEING TWO
HUNDRED BUDGET CHANGES. TURNED A
BUDGET CHANGE RIPPLES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE AND STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS. AT THE SCEPTER OVER
ISSUE THE PUBLIC SAFETY WHILE
OUR PRIORITIES ARE MANY LA TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW THAT I BELIEVE
WILL ENHANCE COMMUNITY SAFETY
FOR ALL. WE STARTED THE YEAR OFF
WITH THE HEARING ON SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS FOR SURVIVORS OF CRIME.
I PART IN TO SEE THAT THE MAYBE
VICE INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION.
FOR PROGRAMS LIKE THE TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS THAT PROVIDE A
- RATES FOR SURVIVORS OF CRIME
TEXAS CRITICAL SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS AND ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT MOMENTS OF THEIR LIFE
. I ALSO HOPE TO SEE THE STATE
FINALLY IF THAT WAS A
COMPREHENSIVE STATE AGENCY. THAT
CAN BETTER SERVE THE COMPLEX
NEEDS OF SURVIVORS OF CRIME
WITHOUT SUBJECTING THEM TO
UNNECESSARY BUREAUCRACY. ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WE MUST DISRUPT THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE AND
THE REVOLVING DOOR FOR
CONSERVATION CALIFORNIA HAS
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS AND
SUCCESSFUL MODELS LIKE PROJECT
REBOUND. THAT INVEST IN THE
POTENTIAL OF PEOPLE TO TRANSFORM
THEIR LIVES. THESE ARE THE TYPE
OF PROGRAMS THAT WILL LIFT
PEOPLE OUT OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
FOR GOOD. FINALLY WHAT WE SPEND. AS HE SPENT TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ON SETH. JERRY ASKED WE SPENT
HOW WE SPENT OUR FOR DOLLARS IS
JUST AS IMPORTANT AS WHAT WE
CHOOSE NOT TO SPEND MONEY ON
PROPOSALS THAT INCLUDE
ACCOUNTABILITY BASED ON RESEARCH
IMPACT PRACTICES THAT ARE
OPERATIONALLY FEASIBLE AND THE
RESPONSE ARE CRITICAL NEED
IDENTIFIED BY CALIFORNIA OR WHAT
WE SHOULD BE INVESTING. IN WHEN
WE DO NOT HAVE A PROPER CONTROLS
IN PLACE TO REDUCE AND ELIMINATE
THE WASTING OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS
WE ARE DOING A DISSERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIND A
MANY CRITICAL NEEDS. I HOPE THIS
THE CEMENT GUIDES OUR
CONVERSATION STORAGE REACHING
THE FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE. I
BEFORE I MOVE ON I WANT TO SEE
IF ANY OF MY STUFF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WANT TO SPEAK ON
PRIORITIES AS WELL. OKAY. OKAY
THEN. YES OKAY. THANK YOU AND
OVER TO MISS WALDRON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AS A NEW MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE- THAT'S THE HI I
JUST WANTED TO TOUCH BASE ON A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME AS A
MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY- AND THAT
WE COULD INVEST MORE TIME
DISCUSSING WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
AND THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SPACE A MENTAL HEALTH SPACE.
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ALSO
REGARDING HOMELESSNESS WHICH
THEN LEADS A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
GET INTO THE CYCLE OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM- FOR
MANY YEARS I'VE BEEN PASSIONATE
ABOUT MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT THAT HAS PROVEN
EFFECTIVE WHICH IS SAVING LIVES
REDUCING RECIDIVISM RATES AND
REDUCING COSTS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ESTIMATED APPROXIMATELY 80% OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS HAD
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER. S. C.
D. AND OF THESE APPROXIMATELY
26% HAVE STDS RELATED TO OPIOID
DRUGS. INDIVIDUAL STRUGGLING
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS ARE
AT HIGH RISK OF FATAL DRUG
OVERDOSE ESPECIALLY IN THE
PERIOD AFTER RELEASED FROM
CUSTODY THREE TWO EIGHT. FOLD
INCREASE OF DRUG RELATED DEATHS
WITHIN THE FIRST TWO WEEKS OF
RELEASE FROM PRISON. SO I HAVE A
BUDGET REQUEST TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A BILL THAT I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR SB SIX FIVE
THREE SIGNED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
CREATED A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
COUNTIES FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT RELATED
PROGRAMS IN. COUNTY JAILS AND
FOR THOSE ON COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION FROM PRISON UNDER
COUNTY JURISDICTION. AND LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
V. SIX FIVE THREE CREATING THIS
FRAMEWORK WOULD JUST NEEDS THE
FUNDING. WITH REALIGNMENT-
COUNTY SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRAMS FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER FUNDING.
AND THIS PROGRAM WILL HELP
ESTABLISH THAT. I'M ALSO EAGER
TO HEAR OR HEAR MORE ABOUT THE
CARE COURT PROPOSAL ADDITIONS
FROM THE MAY REVISED REGARDING
MENTAL HEALTH AS CD AND
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WELCOME MISTER JOHN THIRTY
HAVE ANY COMMENTS YOU WANNA ADD
ON BEFORE WE CONTINUE WITH THE
AGENDA WE'RE JUST. WAITING ON
OPINIONS ON THE MAY REVISE. OKAY
GREAT. OKAY THEN WE ARE GOING TO
. GIVE ME ONE SECOND. YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GO THROUGH THE VOTE
ONLY AGENDA WE HAVE EIGHTEEN
VOTES THAT WILL BE TAKING. I
KNOW THAT THIS IS OVER A HUNDRED
ITEMS TOGETHER- AND THEY'VE
ENCOURAGED ALONG THE WAY SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ISSUE ONE THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT. MOVED BY MR
SOUND. SECOND SECOND MY MISTER
JONES SAWYER.
WELL. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI
YES THE ACTION IS TO PREVENT
BUDGET. GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER
BUT LACKEY HI STONE WALDRON. K.
ISSUE TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE. AND
THE ACTION IS TO APPROVE US
BUDGET WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER STONE. AND THE SECOND BY
MR JONES SAWYER GARCIA. I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY NOPE STONE WALDRON. THANK YOU. OKAY ISSUE ONE AND
TWO ARE OUT. ISSUE THREE SUPPORT
GENERAL WORK LOAD FOR THE OFFICE
OF STATE PUBLIC DEFENDERS THE
ACTION IS TO APPROVE US BUDGET
DO WE HAVE AN ACTION EMOTION.
MOVED BY MR STONE SECOND AYE MR
JONES SAWYER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL GARCIA I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY OF STAYING. STONE-
WALDRON. ISSUE DAIS OUT ISSUE
FOR VARIOUS PROPOSALS UNDER THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH THE JUDGE'S
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND THE TRIAL
COURT SECURITY THE ACTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR ITEM ONE ENTITY THE DROPPED
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
FOR ITEM TWO AND FOR THE
REMAINING PROPOSAL'S ADOPT AT
BUDGET DO WE HAVE A MOTION SO
MOVED. MOVED BY MR LACKEY AND
SECOND BY MR STONE GARCIA I
JONES SAWYER. NIKE HI STONE.
WALDRON THANK YOU THAT ISSUE AS
OUT. ISSUE NUMBER FIVE VARIOUS
BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES THE ACTION
IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. SO I GET MOVED
BY MR STONE AND SECOND MY MR
LACKEY GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER
LACKEY HI STONE. WALDRON ISSUE
FIVE IS OUT ISSUE SIX AREAS
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD THE ACTION IS APPROVED AS
BUDGETED DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED BY MR SELLING SECOND MY
MISTER JONES SAWYER GARCIA HI
JONES SAWYER LACKEY HI STONE
WALDRON. SHE SIX IS OUT ISSUE
SEVEN WE APPROPRIATE
REAPPROPRIATION FOR COMMISSION
ON JUDICIAL PERFORMANCE THE
ACTION IS TO APPROVE US BUDGETED
. SECOND MOVE BY MR STONE SECOND
MISTER LUCKY GARCIA HI JONES
SAWYER LACKEY HI STONE WALDRON.
THANK YOU ISSUE SEVEN IS OUT.
ISSUE EIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE VARIOUS BUDGET PROPOSALS
PART ONE THE ACTION IS TO
PREVENT BUDGET THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION SALUTE. MOVER MISTER
LUCKY SECOND WHAT MR STONE
GARCIA I JONES SAWYER LACKEY I
STONE WALDRON. THANK YOU ISSUE
AREAS OUT ISSUE NINE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE VARIOUS BUDGET
PROPOSALS PART TO. ACCIDENTS ARE
PROFESSED BUDGET THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION. THAT MOVE BY MR STELLEN
SECOND BY MR JONES SAWYER GARCIA
I JONES SAWYER LACKEY I'M
STAYING. STONE WALDRON. CAME
ISSUE NINE S. OUT ISSUE TEN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S VARIOUS
BUDGET PROPOSALS PART THREE. THE
ACTION IS APPROVED AS BUDGET DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. THE MOVER
MISTER STONE SECOND BY MR JONES
SAWYER GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER
LACKEY NOPE STONE. WALDRON NO.
CAN ISSUE TENNIS OUT ISSUE
ELEVEN. CRIMINAL LAW SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN THE ACTION IS TO APPROVE
THIS BUDGET THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION. BUT THE MOVE BY MR
STELLEN SECOND BY MR JONES
SAWYER GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HI. STONE WALDRON NO.
ISSUE ELEVEN S. OUT. ISSUE
TWELVE. SENTENCING SB FOUR
EIGHTY THREE THE ACTION IS TO
APPROVE USBUDGET THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION. MOVED BY MR STONE SECOND
MINISTER JONES SAWYER GARCIA HI
JONES SAWYER LACKEY NO STONE.
WALDRON HEY. QUESTION NUMBER
TWELVE IS OUT. OKAY. ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTEEN PEACE OFFICER
SERVES CERTIFICATION FOR POST
THE ACTION IS TO PREVENT BUDGET
. WE HAVE MOTION. THE MOVE BY MR
STONE SECOND AYE MR JONES SAWYER
GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER LACKEY
NOPE STONE. WALDRON ISSUE
THIRTEEN S. OUT. ISSUE FOURTEEN
DISTANCE LEARNING EVERY
APPROPRIATIONS FOR A POST. THE
ACTION THANK YOU THE ACTION AS
APPROVED AS BUDGET WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER JONES SAWYER
AND A SECOND BY MISTER LUCKY
GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER LACKEY HI
STONE. WALDRON. ISSUE FORTY MESS
OUT ISSUE FIFTEEN OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL OVERSIGHT SEE
ROB AN INTAKE UNIT. THE ACTION A
SURPLUS BUDGET MOVE BY MR JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU AYE MR STONE.
GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER LACKEY HI
STONE WALDRON. ISSUE FIFTEEN AS
OUT. IS SHE SIXTEEN FOR THE
STATE INCOME COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS BRING BUDGET
PROPOSAL THE ACTION IS TO ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL TO
APPROVE THE ALLOCATION FORMULA
CHANGE FOR ONE YEAR ONLY DO I
HAVE A MOTION SO MOVED. MOVED BY
MR LACKEY. SECOND I MISTER JONES
SAWYER GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER
LACKEY I STONE WALDRON. THANK
YOU SEE SIXTEEN S. OUT ISSUE
SEVENTEEN FRIENDS LOCATION THE
pPROJECT THE ACTIVISTS ARE
PROFESSED BUDGET THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION SOME OF. MOVED BY MR
LACKEY SECOND BY MR JONES SAWYER
. GARCIA I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
HI STONE WALDRON. THANK YOU THAT
THE ISSUE IS OUT ISSUE SEVENTEEN
ISSUE EIGHTEEN CDCR IS VARIOUS
BUDGET PROPOSALS THE ACTION IS
TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
. THE MOVE FOR MR STONE AND
SECOND BY MR JONES SAWYER GARCIA
HI JONES SAWYER LACKEY HI STONE
WALDRON. HEY ISSUE EIGHTEEN IS
ALSO OUT THANK YOU MEMBERS THAT
WITH THE- FULLER GENDER FOR VOTE
ONLY. WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE MAY REVISION DISCUSSION
OF OUR CHEN THE AGENDA IS A
COMPANY BY VARIOUS AT
ATTACHMENTS THAT INCLUDE THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS. WILL BE
GOING TO DISCUSSION ON TERRIBLE
PULLS FROM EACH DEPARTMENT. I
WILL POSITIVE QUESTIONS
REMEMBERS AFTER EACH BUDGET
PROPOSAL. MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC
ARE WELCOME TO MAKE COMMENTS ON
ANY OF THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE AT THE VERY END OF ALL OF THE
PRESENTATIONS. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THEIR FIRST ITEM
WHICH IS THE VICTIM'S
COMPENSATION BOARD. AND IT'S
ITEM ONE IN THEIR MEDIA OUT
REACH. EVEN. YOU SHOULD. CLICK
ORTEGA'S BIG. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LINDA GLEDHILL AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD AND I'M PRESENTING ON CHIU
ITEMS FOR THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION THE FIRST IS A THREE
MILLION ALLOCATION FROM THE
STATE RISK RESTITUTION FUND FOR
MEDIA OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS TO
CONNECT CRIME VICTIMS TO HARD TO
REACH AND UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS WITH PROBABLY CV
SERVICE. AS YOU KNOW BE
REIMBURSES ELIGIBLE CRIME
VICTIMS FOR CRIME RELATED COSTS
SUCH AS FUNERAL EXPENSES MEDICAL
BILLS MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
RELOCATION COSTS AND LOST INCOME
WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING SUCH AS
INSURANCE WELL OUR APPLICATION
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO GROW DATA
SHOWED THAT THE NUMBER OF
VIOLENT CRIMES ARE RISING EVEN
FASTER THE MOST CURRENT YEAR THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATION REGION
RECEIVE STATEWIDE IS ONLY TWENTY
THREE POINT 4% OF THE NUMBER OF
VIOLENT CRIMES REPORTED. THESE
DECLINING NUMBERS CAUSED CONCERN
THAT THE CURRENT MODEL OUTRAGE
WHICH IS MAINLY FOCUSED ON
ENGAGEMENT WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND COUNTY SERVICES AND IS NOT
REACHING ALL CRIME VICTIMS IN
ADDITION THE GROUP IN AND THEN
WHICH ISN'T HADN'T ISOLATING
EFFECT ON MANY PEOPLE INCLUDING
VICTIMS OF CRIME MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO REACH THEM PROBABLY
CBO USES APPROPRIATION FOR
STRATEGIC THREE YEAR MEDIAN
AVERAGE CAMPAIGN WHICH
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS AND HELP
BOOST AWARENESS OF PROBABLY C.
B. THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE WITH
THE COMPENSATION. AND SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED. THE SECOND
REVISION ITEM IS A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION FOR THE GENERAL
FUND IS TO BE SPENT OVER THREE
YEARS TO ESTABLISH AN INNOVATIVE
PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE VICTIM
SERVICES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WCBS
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
VICTIMS AFTER THEY ACCESS
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS NEEDING
SERVICES ARE LARGE INEQUITIES IN
WHAT IS A VERY VALUABLE IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE STATE.
FOR INSTANCE FIFTY OF
CALIFORNIANS COUNTIES DO NOT
HAVE A TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER
WHERE ANY CRIME VICTIM TO GET
IMMEDIATELY COUNSEL AND
ASSISTANCE. ROAD AREAS IN
PARTICULAR HAVE LIMITED ACCESS
TO VICTIM SERVICES AND MANY
VICTIMS DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO TRAVEL TO WHERE THE SERVICES
ARE. THIS COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH FUNDS. LOCAL
ENTITIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
TO FILL THAT VOID WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO IT IN A WAY
THAT IS MOST PRACTICAL AND
EFFECTIVE IN THEIR AREAS. IT
WOULD REQUIRE A 20% MATCH. ANY
TO DO THAT DESIRES TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF CRIME
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE INCLUDING
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. HEALTH CARE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND AGENCIES.
CATEGORY OF FOR CONSIDER FOR
AWARDS INCLUDES IS. SUCH AS
IMMEDIATE NEED FOR COUNSELING OR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OR BASIC
NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD AND SHELTER.
IT ALSO DIDN'T CUTE INCLUDE
COMMUNITY AWARENESS INCLUDING
OUTREAC COALITION BUILDING AND
EXPANDING THE REACH OF THE TIME
SERVICES. HOW MANY TV IS
EXPERIENCED PROVIDING GRANTS AND
ENSURING THEY'RE PROPERLY USED
THROUGH THE TRAUMA RECOVERY
CENTER PROGRAM. WITH THESE. NEW
GRANTS TELL THESE TO BE WILL
PRIORITIZE PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
VICTIM SERVICES. IN AREAS THAT
DO NOT HAVE THEM SERVICES THAT
WILL HAVE THE BIGGEST IMPACT IN
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES. TO
SOLVING COMMON PROBLEMS FACED BY
VICTIMS. OUTCOMES WILL BE
CLOSELY TRACKED AND ALL GRANTEES
WILL BE REQUIRED REPORT
REGULARLY ON HOW THEY USE IN THE
GRANT MONEY. HOW MANY VICTIMS
ARE BEING SERVED AND IN WHAT
WAYS AND THE RESULTS. THE PILOT
PROGRAM WILL ALLOW COUNTY C. B.
AND THE STATE TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF CRIME VICTIMS GETTING
HELP. ENCOURAGE NEW AND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO SERVE SUPPORT. AND REACH THEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU- IF YOU COULD
TALK ON BOTH THE MEDIA OUT REACH
AND THE INNOVATIVE CREDIT
PROGRAM FOR VICTIM SERVICES.
JUST COMPUTER THOUGHT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS TO
RAISE WITH THE MEDIA OUTREACH
PROPOSAL- A REGARDING THE
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM FOR VICTIM
SERVICES- WHILE PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE. TO
VICTIMS- CAN HAVE THE MERITS
OTHERS CURRENTLY FEW DETAILS
AVAILABLE ON THIS PROPOSAL AND
SO ACCORDINGLY THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO. DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THE GOALS OF THE
PILOT- WHAT TYPES OF SERVICES
THE FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT. HOW
THE FUNDING WOULD BE PRIORITIZED
ON BETWEEN DIFFERENT TYPES OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS UNDER THE
PROPOSAL- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS AND A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT- ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES COULD COMPETE FOR THESE
FINDS. AN ANSWER HOW WOULD THOSE
BE PRIORITIZED- AND HOW
PROVIDERS WOULD DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY FOR VICTIMES ARM AND
HOW THAT FITS IN WITH THE OTHER
PROGRAM THAT CAL THE CITY RUNS
THE VICTIM COMPENSATION PROGRAM.
THAT HAS- SOMEWHAT STRICT
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS SET AND
FEDERAL LAW. I'M AND ALSO ON THE
LEGISLATURE ONE UNDERSTAND HOW
THE OUTCOMES OF THIS PILOT WOULD
BE MEASURED THERE'S NO-
EVALUATION REPORT- OR ANYTHING
INCLUDED IN THIS PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE- TO INFORM YOU FOR
FUTURE DECISIONS IF THIS WERE
SOMETHING. ON THE LEGISLATURE
WANTED TO DO I WANTED TO
CONSIDER ON ON GOING BASIS. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD FIT INTO THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO
HAVE THIS INFORMATION WE THINK
I'M TO HELP YOU MAKE YOUR
DECISION. AND HAPPY TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. HI THANK YOU I DO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- FOR THE INNOVATIVE
PILOT PROGRAM SERVICES THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS YOU HAVE
HERE. WILL ANY OF THE SPENDING
ME USED TO AND HAS A CAPACITY OF
X. SIXTEEN TRC'S ARE YOU
ESTABLISHING YOU ONCE. THIS
PROGRAM WILL NOT BE USED FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR C. PROGRAM THAT IS
ESTABLISHED IN STATUTE WHICH
DEFINES FUNDING AND SO THIS
WOULD BE FOR NEW INNOVATIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS. SO HOW WOULD
THIS DIFFER FROM THE EXISTING.
THE CURRENT YEAR CITIES ARE SET
IN STATUTE WITH VERY STRICT
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
SET UP AND WHAT SORT OF SERVICE
THAT THEY HAVE TO OFFER THIS
WOULD NOT HAVE THOSE STRICT
REQUIREMENTS SO WE CAN BE MORE
FLEXIBLE IN BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO ENTITIES THAT
PERHAPS COULDN'T MEET THE STRICT
REQUIREMENTS OF IT HERE SEE BUT
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
VETERANS. AND SO ARE YOU GONNA
THE- TRACK OR- ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS ACTUALLY ENHANCING
THE SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS. WE
WILL BUILD REQUIREMENTS OF
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS INTO THE
GRANT PROCESS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
MANY VICTIMS WERE BEING SERVED
AND HOW THE MONEY IS BEING SPENT
. DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT THAT
MIGHT ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE. ALL OF
OUR GRANT- CURRENT YEAR STATE
RUN PROGRAMS DO YOU HAVE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
REPORT BACK TO US AND SO WE ARE
COMFORTABLE THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND AGAIN BASED ON
THE SIZE OF THE GRANT- AND WHAT
KIND OF SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
OFFERED THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
MEASURE HOW MANY VICTIMS WERE
BEING. HELPED BY THE WITH THESE
FUNDS. AND WILL YOU HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO BE INVOLVING EXTERNAL.
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP THIS.
ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE A B. C. AND
AN ADVISORY BOARD WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THAT MEETS
QUARTERLY AND WE ALSO HAVE MANY
OTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH VICTIMS
STAKEHOLDERS AND SO WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WE- LET THEM KNOW
ABOUT THESE GRANT OPPORTUNITIES
. SO DEFINITELY WANT TO SEE MORE
DETAILS I'M AT A I UNDERSTAND.
THE DESIRE TO WORK WITH OTHER C.
B. O.'S OUT THERE AND ALLOWING.
PROCESS FOR THEM TO PARTICIPATE
I JUST WORRY THAT WITHOUT
DETAILS IS NOT CLEAR TO ME HOW
HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE.
SUPPLEMENTING THEM BETTER
SERVING THE VICTIMS OUT THERE
ARE THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO MOVE
IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION WE HAVE
A MODEL THAT IS WORKING. ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE ARGUMENTS
MISTER LACKING YEP. MY QUESTION
HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT-
THE VICTIM IS TO XIN FUND IS
HEADED TOWARDS INSOLVENCY IT'S A
IT'S CERTAIN FOR SUPPORT SO WHY
DOES THIS PROPOSAL USE THE
VICTIMS RESTITUTION FUNDS
INSTEAD OF THE GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES. CAN ANSWER TAKE A
STEP BACK KEVIN CLARK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM THE
INNOVATIVE PILOT PROGRAM VICTIM
SERVICES IS BUDGET AS GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS. RESTITUTION
BROWN'S. YEAH AND I DIDN'T CARE
BECAUSE OF OUR WELL I'M ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE MEDIA OUT
REACH. THEY MIGHT HAVE AN ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION. THAT'S A
TEMPORARY AND PERMANENT ALLIANCE
. I'M HARD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
THAT- AND PROVIDES NETWORK
NATION ABOUT THAT. OKAY
APPRECIATE THAT. WHAT YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON WHY
YOU'RE CHOOSING TO USE
RESTITUTION FUND VERSUS GENERAL
FUND SO AT THIS TIME. FOR THE
MEDIA OUT REACH THAT FIRST ITEM
ON THE AGENDA. I'M I DON'T HAVE
ANY INFORMATION FOR ME AT THIS
MOMENT BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES
ON THAT. THE JUST I'M- THIS
LITTLE TROUBLING THAT WERE
PROPOSAL WITHOUT. WITHOUT ANY
BEATS US I FEEL LIKE THE
QUESTION ASKED BY MISTER LACKEYS
PRETTY FAIR AND STRAIGHTFORWARD.
IF YOU. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANOTHER HEARING ON THIS SO. EVEN
MORE UNSETTLING. DO ANY OF OUR
PEERS HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ON THE SIDE OF MY COMMENTS HERE
BEFORE I MOVE ON TO THE NEXT. I
AM I DO WANT TO GIVE L. A. O. A
MOMENT TO THAT THEY CAN MAKE
SOME GENERAL COMMENTS ON THE
CELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TRUE
SO TO WORK LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE BOB SO OUR OFFICE HAS
RECENTLY RELEASED ITS INITIAL
COMMENTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION AND SO MY COMMENTS HERE
TODAY ARE DRAWN FROM THAT
PUBLICATION. ALL IN A
PUBLICATION WE BUT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REALLY- REVISION
ALLOCATES A FIFTY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND SURPLUS THE
LARGEST CATEGORIES OF SPENDING
FROM THE SURPLUS ARE FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS. BUT THE GOVERNOR'S ME
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES THIRTY
NINE BILLION OF PROPOSALS IN
ORDER TO MEET THE- STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LAMENTS REQUIRE
ALSO KNOWN AS THE CELL
REQUIREMENTS. THE TWO LARGEST
CATEGORIES OF THE PROPOSALS IN
THIS. AREA ARE IS. ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN TAX REFUNDS AND
THIRTEEN BILLION FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY. DESPITE THIS THE MAY
REVISION DOES LEAVE SOME SELL
REQUIREMENTS ON ADDRESSED
SPECIFICALLY THE GOVERNOR LEAVES
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION AND
UNADDRESSED SELL REQUIREMENTS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
IS CONCERNING BECAUSE IT SETS UP
A FISCAL CLIFF FOR THE STATE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
SPECIFICALLY WE ESTIMATE THAT
THE STATE WOULD FACE AN
ADDITIONAL CELL REQUIREMENT. OF
OVER TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND THE MAY REVISION DOES NOT
INCLUDE A PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS
REQUIREMENT AS A RESULT THE
STATE WOULD VERY LIKELY FACE A
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET PROBLEM NEXT
YEAR. IN ADDITION WE NOTE THAT
THERE. IS A HEIGHTENED RISK OF A
RECESSION IN THE FUTURE A
CERTAIN ECONOMIC INDICATORS
HISTORICALLY HAVE OFFERED
WARNING SIGNS THAT ARE RECESSION
IS ON THE HORIZON. AND MANY OF
THESE INDICATORS CURRENTLY
INDICATE THAT A RECESSION AS
POSSIBLE WITHIN THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. ACCORDINGLY OUR OFFICE IS
RECOMMENDING INCREASING
RESERVES- AS RESERVES WILL BE
ESSENTIAL FOR THE STATE TO
MAINTAIN ITS CURRENT PROGRAMS
WHILE FACING THE CHALLENGES.
SHINN'S LIMIT REQUIREMENTS. I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OR WE CAN MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ITEM. THANK QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU JUST A REALLY QUICKLY
FOR WE WANT TO THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- IF YOUR DEPARTMENT
HAS MORE THAN ONE ISSUE I ASK
THAT YOU SEE POTS BETWEEN EACH
ISSUE SO WE CAN I HEAR FROM
ALEJO THEY HAVE ANY COMMENTS AND
HAVE MEMBERS ASK QUESTIONS IN
BETWEEN EACH. ISSUE SO AS WE
WANT TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
THE FIRST ISSUE WE HAVE THERE IS
A FENCE AND ALL TASK FORCE. YOU
MAYBE CAN'T. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ASHLEY
HARPER BUDGET OFFICER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
- THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE MAY REVISED
BUDGET INCLUDES TWO BCPS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHICH AIMS
TO SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
MANDATED RESPONSIBILITIES. IN
CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY NEEDS- I
WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THESE PROPOSALS FOR THE
COMMITTEE. AND WE ALSO HAVE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AVAILABLE
TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC PROGRAMMATIC
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. THE
PROPOSAL IS THE FINAL TASK FORCE
AT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
BUDGET PROPOSED A SEVEN POINT
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION ON
GOING. FOR DOJ TO ESTABLISH THE
FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
WITHIN THE BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION TO TARGET
STATEWIDE FEDERAL TRAFFICKING
CRIMINAL NETWORKS. THE PROGRAM
WILL CONSIST OF THREE REGIONAL
INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS LOCATED IN
THE NORTHERN SOUTHERN AND
CENTRAL REGIONS WITH OPERATION
STATEWIDE. WITH DOJ'S UNIQUE
EXPERTISE STATE WIDE STATE WHAT
PERSPECTIVE AND VERTICAL
PROSECUTION MODEL AVAILABLE TO
DRAW UPON DOJ HAVE THE ABILITY
TO IMMEDIATELY IMPACT THIS
PARTICULARLY SOPHISTICATED SPACE
. THE REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT TWENTY FIVE ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL SPECIALIZED TRAINING
AND THE NECESSARY CONFIDENTIAL
SOURCES OF INFORMATION I'M
JOINED TODAY BY JOHN MARSH OUR
CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WERE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
ON THIS PROPOSAL. I NEED ONLY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- IN OUR ANALYSIS IT IS
UNCLEAR WHY- FEDERAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND ENFORCEMENT
CANNOT BE PRIORITIZED BY
EXISTING STATE AND REGIONAL DOJ
TASK FORCE IS WORKING WITH LOCAL
AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. IT IS ALSO UNCLEAR
WHETHER THIS ACTIVITY IS THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAY OF ADDRESSING
THE FENNEL AND OPIOID CRISIS.
COLLABORATION ACROSS AGENCIES
SUCH AS COORDINATING WITH
EXISTING AND PROPOSED DATA
COLLECTION AND I REJECTED EASE
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH COULD INFORM A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH.
STATEWIDE TO EFFECTIVELY TARGET
THE FINAL CRISIS AND SO BECAUSE
OF THAT WE THINK THE PROPOSED
FUNDING DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
NECESSARY BEFORE THAT
COLLABORATION TAKES PLACE. THANK
YOU. BUT CAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE COMMENTS ON. ALLEY OATH-
COMMENTARY ON THIS ITEM AND WHY
YOU THINK THIS IS NECESSARY AND
NOT DUPLICATIVE. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND HAND IT OVER TO JOHN
MARCIA CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO'S AVAILABLE
TO SPEAK TO THE DIFFERENCES.
BETWEEN THE PROPOSED FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AND OTHER
EXISTING EFFORTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. SO I'LL TOUCH ON THE
FIRST PART ABOUT USING EXISTING
RESOURCES. SO DO YOU GUYS HAVE A
TASK FORCE PROGRAM THAT HAS
BEEN- SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED AT
ONE TIME WE HAD FIFTY NINE- TASK
FORCES THROUGHOUT THE STATE WERE
DOWN TO ABOUT SEVEN NOW- AND
THEY ARE VERY- GEOGRAPHICALLY
COMMUNITY BASED AND FOCUSED- SO
THE DIFFERENCE IS- AND I CAN
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE I. WHEN I
CAME TO DOJ I WORKED FOR A STATE
TASK FORCE AND IT WAS IN A LOCAL
COMMUNITY ANNUAL ACCOUNTING AND
THEY HAD OFFICERS FROM FROM ALL
THE LOCAL DEPARTMENTS. DURING
THAT TIME- WE CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WERE
DICTATED THROUGH- WHAT THE NEEDS
OF THE AREA WORK. OUT WHEN WE
GET- INVESTIGATIONS AND CAME
ACROSS A BIG MULTI STATE
INVESTIGATIONS WE'RE ABLE TO
CALL THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WHO HAD SPECIALIZED TEAMS. THAT
COULD THEN TAKE THAT CASE TO THE
NEXT LEVEL- AND INTERCONNECTED
THE STATE SO. WHEN WE HAD CASES
THAT WERE BIGGER THAN OUR COUNTY
LEVEL. CAPACITY WE WOULD CALL
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND I
HAD EXPERTS THAT WOULD COME OUT
AND THEN TAKE THAT CASE AND WORK
AT IT FROM A STATE AND- FEDERAL
LEVEL. SO THAT'S- THE POINT OF
WE DON'T SEE THIS AS DUPLICATIVE
WE SEE THIS IS TARGETING AN
ISSUE THAT IS. UP IN A VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME
I'VE BEEN MONITORING THE FENNEL
AND OPIOID CRISIS OF ABOUT TEN
YEARS NOW. A FOR A LONG TIME IT
WAS AN ISSUE THAT- KIND OF EAST
OF THE MISSISSIPPI OPERATIVE
HEARING CALIFORNIA NOW AND I
JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON. JUST SOME
SEIZURES FROM LA IMPACT WAS A
TASK FORCE THAT WE HAVE IN LOS
ANGELES. IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THEY SEE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN POUNDS OF FENNEL AND
FREE. OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND- PILLS OFFEND-
LAST YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE THEY CITIES SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN POUNDS OF FENNEL AND SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
HILLS- SO YOU CAN SEE CALIFORNIA
IS ON THE RISE- THEN ALL THAT
OVERDOSE DEATHS ARE THE LEADING
KILLER. OF A- BOTH BETWEEN
FIFTEEN OR EIGHTEEN AND FORTY
FIVE. IT'S A CRISIS AND IT'S
HERE. AND CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
HAVE AN ORGANIZED- FOCUSED
EFFORT ON THIS. OUR GOAL IS TO
WORK WITH PUBLIC HEALTH. I'M A
JUSTICE UNDERSTANDS THAT- WE'RE
NOT GOING TO ARREST OUR WAY OUT
OF THIS PROBLEM WE'RE JUST- ONE
COMPONENT. THAT CAN HELP. TO
WORK ON THIS PROBLEM SO PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL BE. A PARTNERS LOCAL
WILL BE A PARTNER- MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES WILL BE A PARTNER- AND
THIS WILL BE A MORE OF A
HOLISTIC APPROACH- BUT- DOJ'S
COMPONENT IN THIS IS ENFORCEMENT
COMPONENT. SO HOPE I ANSWERED
THAT QUESTION I CAN ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. MISTER JONES
SAWYER- THE GLAD YOU MENTIONED
THE- THE HEALTH BENEFITS OF BUT
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE YOU YOU'VE
- REALLY FIGURED OUT HOW THAT
WILL HAPPEN THIS SOUNDS MORE
LIKE A PUNISHMENT AND
ENFORCEMENT ARM NOT NECESSARILY
LOOKING AT THE HEALTH
RAMIFICATIONS OF. IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU'RE DISCONNECTED FROM THAT
FROM WHAT YOU EXPLAINED OF THAT
LIKE I CAN TELL YOU WHAT
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. I KNOW
HOW THAT WILL WORK AND HOW WE
GET PEOPLE TO- TO THE TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY NEED BUT I
DON'T GET THAT SENSE HERE. WITH
THIS PROGRAM THAT THE TASK FORCE
THIS ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE
PUBLIC MORE ENFORCEMENT. THEN
THEN REMEDIATION OF CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
GET PEOPLE TO- GET OFF OF A FAT
NO OR NOT TO EVEN START WITH
THAT NOW OR YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S
NOT YOUR PROBLEM. AND YOU'RE
ONLY GOING TO ONE END OF IT. THE
WHO'S GOING TO DO THE OTHER AND. YEAH GREAT QUESTION AND I
THINK THE FUTURE IS A COMPONENT
OF THAT AND- SO WE ARE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION SO WILL BE HANDLING
THINGS AT A STATE LEVEL WORKING
WITH LOCAL COUNTIES. BUT THIS
TASK FORCE ISN'T FOCUSED ON ON
USERS THIS IS VIOLENCE-
DISTRIBUTORS OF A PANEL AND THEN
TARGETING OF THE WORST OF THE
WORST. AND NOT ADDRESSING THE
USERS AFFECTED ALL BUT THE
DISTRIBUTORS AND MANUFACTURERS-
OFFEND ALL WE KNOW THAT- PANELS
GETTING PUSHED INTO CALIFORNIA
FROM MEXICO- TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REPORT FROM D. A.
SPECIFICALLY SAID ALMOST ALL OF
THE FINAL COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA'S FOR MEXICO- WE'RE
SOURCE STATE AND A LOT OF A LOT
OF IT WAS LEAVING OUR STATE AND
NOW IT'S STAYING IN OUR STATE.
AND THERE HAS TO BE SOME
ENFORCEMENT TO CURTAIL THE I
DON'T OFFEND ALL THAT'S COMING
IN AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT'S A
PASSED DOWN THROUGH A STATEWIDE
EFFORT- BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPONENTS TO THIS ISSUE. AND I
KNOW MEANS AS ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE SAYING THAT- THE
ENFORCEMENT AND THE DISMANTLING
OF ORGANIZED CRIME THE SPRING
FINALE TO CALIFORNIAN IN
DISTRIBUTING IT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY PROBLEM
THE SOLUTION. IT MAY BE TOMORROW
YOU NEED TO LOOK AT IS THE- R.
C. MODEL. BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T
CORPORATION BOTH BUT YOU'RE
SAYING YOU CAN'T BUT YOU'RE
DOING IT RIGHT NOW. SO I THINK
YOU CAN. YEAH AND I'VE FIFTY
FIVE M. ACROSS THE SAYING WE
CAN'T DO THAT THAT THAT WAS NOT
MY INTENTION. IT'S RIGHT NOW THE
PROPOSAL IS THIS IF WE WERE TO
BE- GIVEN THE TEAMS ARE PART OF
PART OF THIS APPROACH IS WORKING
WITH. ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND EVERY
EVERYBODY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO KIND OF COME UP WITH ANOTHER
SOLUTION AND BRING TO- THE
SOLUTION AS IS OUR PARTY AND
STEMMING THE FLOW INTO
CALIFORNIA. GOOD CAN YOU GET
BACK TO THIS COMMITTEES SOME
DETAIL ON THIS ON HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO THIS HOLISTIC. APPROACH
OF COURSE. I THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER AND SOUGHT- WE DO
WANT TO HEAR MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING TO. BE
WORKING WITH ACADEMIA SOCIAL
SERVICES THE MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS INSTEAD OF JUST
THE INVESTIGATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE OF THINGS- IT
IS. IT IS THE PRIORITY TO
ADDRESS AND DEAL WITH THE FENCE
AND ALL- CRISIS WE HAVE HERE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING IT IN A WAY THAT WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE WHEN WE TALK TO
CONSTITUENTS. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE SECOND ITEM. BEFORE
THAT I ME FEET THERE'S
CONSTRUCTION GOING ON AND SO IF
YOU ARE SPEAKING TO AS REMOTELY
WE ARE TRYING TO RAISE THE
VOLUME HERE BUT IF YOU CAN SPEAK
UP AND RAISE YOUR VOICE THAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL FOR US IN THE
ROOM- AND SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE SECOND ITEM HERE THE
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- ACTUALLY HARPER
AND DOJ AGAIN- FOR REPARATIONS
TASK FORCE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE BUDGET PROPOSES A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION
OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
TO SUPPORT THE NECESSARY
EXTERNAL CONTRACTS TRAVEL AND
PER DIEM COSTS FOR TASK FORCE
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY-
SPECIFICALLY ONE POINT THREE
MILLION OF THE REQUESTED
RESOURCE SAYS ARE SPECIFIC TO
THE EXPERTS AND CONTRACTORS.
THAT THE TASK FORCE HAS
IDENTIFIED TO BE NECESSARY TO
FACILITATE THE MANDATED REPORTS
INCLUDING ECONOMICS EXPERTS
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS AND
REVIEW AND ANALYSIS OF THE
REPORT ITSELF. OF THE REMAINING
TWO HUNDRED K. IS REQUESTED TO
SUPPORT THE TRAVEL AND PER DIEM
BUT TASK FORCE MEMBERS AND DOJ
STOP. IN MEETINGS HAVE BEGUN
PURSUANT TO THE BAD BAGLEY KEENE
ACT. DEMON BROWN WITH THE PUBLIC
RIGHTS DIVISION AND I ARE
AVAILABLE TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEES QUESTIONS AS NEEDED
ON THIS PROPOSAL. I NEED ONLY
WITH THE L. L. WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
MEMBERS MISTER DANCER HI IT IS
YOU KNOW OF. I STOOD ON THE TASK
FORCE. AND- THIS IS ALL NEW. AND
THE REASON WE NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BECAUSE WE HAD
UNFORESEEN- PROBLEMS. OR ISSUES
OR THINGS WE NEED TO DO MORE
THAN WE THOUGHT WE WOULD NEED-
I'M NOT CERTAIN THAT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION IS ENOUGH. ALSO
THAT WE CAN COMPLETE THE TASK
FORCE MISSION WHICH IS FROM A
VERY SHORT TIME LINE. IN AND SO-
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT D. O. J.
WHICH I THINK I MEAN I'D ONCE
BEFORE DEAL J. BUT I THINK WE'VE
BEEN. ENCROACHED ON THEIR BUDGET
QUITE A BIT WE'VE ASKED THEM TO
DO A WHOLE LOT MORE THAN WHAT WE
HAD ORIGINALLY ASKED HIM TO DO.
AND SO- I JUST NEED TO KNOW IF
THIS IS ENOUGH WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO COMPLETE THE
WORK OF THE TASK FORCE. BECAUSE-
IT'S REALLY HARD. FOR ME OR
ANYONE ELSE- SPECIALIST BRADFORD
AND I TO COME BACK- TO TRY TO
GET MORE FUNDING. WHEN THE
REPORT IS DUE NEXT YEAR. AND SO-
I THINK THE- DOJ NEEDS ALL THE
MONEY THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GET THIS DONE NOW. AND THAT
WE JUST DON'T. GIVE THEM A
LITTLE BIT RIGHT NOW AND HOPE
THAT THE- COMPLETED WE GIVE THEM
MORE THAN ENOUGH SO THAT HE CAN
COMPLETE THE WORK OF THE TASK
FORCE- REPARATIONS IS RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE UNDER A MICROSCOPE
CALIFORNIA IS AND IF WE DON'T
GET THIS RIGHT. YOU COULD HAVE
RAMIFICATIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SO IT'S REALLY IMPERATIVE THAT
WE SPEND SOME MONEY IN GAS THEY
WOULD ALL HAVE ANY MONEY- RIGHT
NOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS GETS
DONE RIGHT. AND SO I. I IMPLORED
THE DEPARTMENT EMPLOYER THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FINANCE
EVERYONE TO REALLY STEP UP THE
GAME. AND GIVE MORE. MORE THAN
WHAT THEY MAY THINK THEY NEED-
THAT WE REALLY GO THROUGH AND
MAKE SURE THEY GET ENOUGH OF THE
OTHER THING I WOULD LIKE TO PUT
IN YOU PUT INTO A THOUSAND FOR
EXAMPLE FOR MEETINGS. A PART OF
THAT IS BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING
MEETINGS NOW WHENPEOPLE WORK.
WE NEED TO MEET AFRICAN
AMERICANS ON SATURDAY SUNDAY IN
THE EVENING ATTEND CHURCH
MEETINGS. THAT'S HOW YOU GET THE
MOST INPUT. BUT THE SAID TO SHOW
UP ON A TUESDAY. MORNING FOR
WEDNESDAY MORNING. OF THE TALK
ABOUT REPARATIONS IS DIFFICULT-
FOR ANY WORKING FAMILY IS SO-
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE START
EXPANDING WHAT WE THINK IS
APPROPRIATE. AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE REPARATIONS TASK FORCE GET
EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED. I
DON'T KNOW IF THE DOJ WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT BECAUSE I- EVERY DAY
WE WOULD KEEP ASKING FOR MORE
AND MORE THINGS FOR THEM TO DO-
THEY TRY. NOT DEEPLY PULLING
PEOPLE FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
AND OTHER PLACES THE TO FIT
FINALIZED AND GET THINGS DONE.
BUT THAT'S UNFAIR THAT'S IMPAIR
TO DOJ RIGHT NOW ALL FOR US TO
PUT THAT IN POSITION ON. IF I
MAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BUT SPEAK
UP A KID WHO WOULD EVER
WHISPERING. I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
BEING IF I'M ABLE TO BE HEARD-
THIS IS DAMON BROWN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE POINT THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
JUST MENTIONED- HE'S CORRECT. IN
THAT THERE ARE ADDITIONAL COSTS
THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED. IN THIS-
A PROPOSAL ON THE MAY NEED
REVISION. RELATED TO DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE PERSONNEL COSTS. WE
HAVE BEEN- EXTENDING RESOURCES
INTERNALLY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE TASK FORCE A WHICH IS PROVEN
TO BE QUITE DIFFICULT AND IN
SOME CASES- IT IS HAS BEEN
IMPOSSIBLE- WITH EXISTING PERSON
THOUGH- THE TASK OF PREPARING
THESE REPORTS. ENGAGING WITH
EXPERTS AND TASK FORCE MEMBERS
AND ALSO- IN- THE INTER AGENCY
INTERACTIONS AND REACHING OUT TO
THE COURTS- DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICES ALL OVER THE STATE- IT
HAS BEEN A HERCULEAN TASK TO GET
IT DONE WITH EXISTING RESOURCES
THAT REALLY- IT IS IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE ON A LONG TERM
BASIS- TO CONTINUE TO PULL. OUT
FROM THE OTHER WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING WITHIN NOT ONLY WITIN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT
SECTION BUT IN OTHER AREAS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
MENTIONED- AS THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PIECE OF THIS PROJECT
CONTINUES. ABOUT MEETING PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE WILL REQUIRE.
AFTER HOURS- EVENTS- SATURDAY
MEETINGS- WHICH AGAIN IS A
STRAIN ON INTERNAL RESOURCES
BASED ON OVERTIME COSTS THAT ARE
NOT BUDGET OR ALLOCATED FOR AND
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT YES THIS
CURRENT PROPOSAL DOES. INCLUDE
THE COSTS THAT WE ANTICIPATE
NEEDING IN ORDER TO MEET THE
CURRENT NEEDS OF THE TASK FORCE
IN TERMS OF ITS CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS- THE- THE TRAVEL
THAT WILL NOW BE REQUIRED- SINCE
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER EXEMPTING-
IN PERSON MEETINGS HAS EXPIRED-
THAT- IS MET IN THIS PROPOSAL-
THERE'S ABOUT ANOTHER- ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND IN IN
STAFFING AND OTHER COSTS. THAT
WOULD TRULY ALLOW THE TASK FORCE
TO DO THE WORK. THAT HAS BEEN
TESTED YOU IN DISPATCH. THE THAT
IN THE ONE POINT FIVE. IT POINT
FOUR YOU REALLY WHAT ANOTHER
BILLION AND A MILLION I MEAN.
OKAY. THE OKAY WITH US IN IT TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION IN TOTAL. IT
WAS A BIT TOO TWO BILLION. FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE THOUSAND. ONE
MOMENT OKAY- BILL BUT IT'S
BETTER AT MATH THAN ME TO BE
ABLE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT YOU WANT
ONE MILLION. OKAY. K. DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ONE TRIED
ANYTHING. SURE HIGH- MARC BERMAN
IS THE PERMANENT FINANCE- WE
JUST WANT TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT- DOJ I'D- WHAT'S PROVIDED
ABOUT MILLION. IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OUR BUDGET ACT-
IMPLEMENT THE- THE
RESPONSIBILITIES. OF THE P.
REYES TASK FOR SO WE CERTAINLY
TOOK THAT INTO CONSIDERATION. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THEY WERE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS FOR THE
CONTRACTS- THAT WOULD
NECESSARILY BUILT IN- ARE
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ENACTMENT OF THIS UP THE
STATIONS THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
AND- A BILL THAT INTO THAT
MAYBE. A REVISION- IT BUT IN
TERMS OF- THE- D. THAT
PERSONNEL- THE ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO SUIT AND I
MENTIONED- WE- WE WILL WE-
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'VE ALREADY
PROVIDED THE OKAY SOME RESOURCES
THAT I'M NOT FOR A BI- FIRST AYE
DOT STAFF TO. STAFF THIS TASK.
FORCE I. THIS SOUNDS LIKE AND
STILL NOT ENOUGH I I'M ALMOST
POSITIVE. THE TASK FORCE OF
ALMOST HAVE DEMANDED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT- THE- DAY
GRACIOUSLY JUST WENT ALONG WITH
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO SUCCEED
AND THE MISSION- BUT WE'RE NOW
AT A PLACE WHERE WE'RE GOING THE
EVEN MORE RESOURCES AND SO I
THANK WHATEVER THE GOVERNOR HAS
DONE SO FAR IT IS. REALLY BEEN
IMPORTANT BUT WE'RE GONNA NEED
SOME MORE TO BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
THIS TASK. OKAY THANK YOU AYE I
HOPE THAT BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE
FIFTEENTH WE COULD GET TO A
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT THE TASK
FORCE IS SUCCESSFUL AS MR JONES
SAWYER SAID IT. THE REST OF THE
NATION IS LOOKING AT US AS WE
SET THE MODEL. OUT THERE. INTO
THE WORK IS NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT- FOR PEOPLE
ACROSS THE NATION THAT WE'RE
DOING HERE TODAY. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR THIRD ITEM TO.
THE BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. BEFORE I MOVE ON
I'M GOING TO REMIND. OUR
PANELISTS WHO ARE. HERE
VIRTUALLY IF THEY COULD SPEAK
UP- AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WE HAVE
CONSTRUCTION GOING ON HERE IN
THE BUILDING THAT'S COMPETING
WITH WHAT YOU'RE TELLING US. AND
SO WE DEFINITELY WANT TO GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR YOU SAVE AS MUCH AS YOU
CAN RAISE YOUR VOICE THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO US. SO WE HAVE.
THREE ITEMS IN THIS SECTION SO
WE WILL AGAIN POTS BETWEEN EACH
ITEM ALL START WITH MISSING AN
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES GRANT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM SENTIMENT DOWN SO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I'LL PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE REQUESTS FOR GRANTS TO
SUPPORT. INDIGENOUS TRIBES
ADDRESSING THEIR MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS
THE COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM
WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
BOARD OF STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS AND THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TWELVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO BE SPENT OVER
THREE YEARS TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
SUPPORT FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
INDIAN TRIBES. IN EFFORTS TO
IDENTIFY COLLECT CASE LEVEL ATA
PUBLICIZING INVESTIGATE CASES
INVOLVING MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. GIVE GRANTS
ARE INTENDED TO FOCUS ON
ACTIVITIES THAT INCLUDE BUT ARE
NOT LIMITED TO THOSE THAT
DEVELOP CULTURALLY BASED
PREVENTION STRATEGIES
STRENGTHENING RESPONSES TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND IMPROVISING
COOPERATION BETWEEN VARIOUS LAW
ENFORCEMENT JURISDICTIONS.
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THE
UNIQUE AND UNFORTUNATE STRUGGLES
CALIFORNIA'S INDIGENOUS
POPULATIONS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
PROVIDED DIRECTLY TO CALIFORNIA
TRIBES WILL SERVE AS A
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT IN
REDUCING THE DISPROPORTIONATE
HARM OFTEN INJURED BY THESE
COMMUNITIES. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. CAITLIN
O'NEILL AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THERE ARE
SERIOUS CONCERNS REGARDING
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE SO WE DON'T RAISE A
CONCERN WITH THE GENERAL CONCEPT
OF PUTTING RESOURCES TOWARD THAT
PROBLEM- HOWEVER THE PARTICULAR
STRUCTURE OF THIS PROPOSAL DOES
RAISE SOME KEY QUESTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. AT THE FIRST IS THE
FOUR MILLION- PROPOSED FOUR
MILLION OVER PER YEAR OVER THREE
YEARS. RED AMOUNT TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM AND WE ASK THAT BECAUSE
THE ADMINISTRATION WASN'T ABLE
TO PROVIDE A CLEAR RATIONALE FOR
THAT AMOUNT- SECOND IS B. S. C.
C. THE BEST ENTITY TO ADMINISTER
THESE GRANTS. AND WE NOTE THAT
DOJ HAS AN OFFICE OF NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS. AND WILD GRANT
MAKING IS NOT OF COURSE DOJ'S
BREAD AND BUTTER IT DOJ DOES
HAVE SOME GRANT MAKING IT IS IT
HAS SOME INVOLVEMENT WITH GRANT
MAKING PARTICULARLY IN THAT. IN
WITH RESPECT TO TRIBAL ISSUES-
AND THAT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED FIVE MILLION
FOR DOJ TO SUPPORT PUBLIC SAFETY
ON TRIBAL LANDS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING BY STUDYING DE UM
CHALLENGES RELATED TO REPORTING
AND IDENTIFICATION OF MISSING
AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
SO COULD BE SOMETHING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AS TO
WHETHER GIVEN ITS EXISTING- AND
EXPERTISE AND THIS RECENT-
INVESTMENT IN BUILDING DOJ'S
EXPERTISE ON THIS ISSUE. WHETHER
DOJ WOULD MAKE MORE SENSE AS
THAT- ENTITY TO HOST THIS ADAM
GRANT PROGRAM- AND THIRD TO THE
EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES
THIS FUNDING WE RECOMMEND THAT
IT REQUIRE REPORTING ON HOW THE
MONEY IS USED AND WHAT OUTCOMES
ARE ULTIMATELY ACHIEVED. AT
THANK YOU THIS AREA AND INTENDED
AS- MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN IS A PRIORITY
FOR BOTH THE NATIVE AMERICAN
CAUCUS AND THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
WE'VE BEEN HIGHLIGHTING THIS FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS TOGETHER AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
DURING THESE TIMES OF ORDER OF
PRESIDENT SURPLUS FOR INVESTING.
PROPERLY AND NOT. AND NOT UNDER
INVESTING IN THESE PROGRAMS THAT
NOW THAT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
AND SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO HOW YOU
CAME UP WITH THIS DOLLAR AMOUNT
AND THEN I HAVE A SECOND PART OF
MY QUESTION. WHICH IS HOW ARE
YOU INVOLVING INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES REPRESENTATIVES AND
THIS PROCESS BOTH. AND AT THAT.
DECIDING WHICH DEPARTMENT THE
SCHOOLS AND TO- THE GRANT
PLANNING PROCESS BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT MOST OF ALL TRIBES
ARE AWARE OF THIS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY. THIS ISN'T EVEN TEN
SECONDS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS- IN TERMS OF THE
FUNDING- THIS WAS DECIDED- AND
ENCRYPTED WITHIN THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE BUDGET FOR
THIS YEAR AND- DEFINITELY TO
SPREAD IT OUT OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS WE FOUND THAT. TO
BE- THE BEST COURSE OF ACTION-
AND IN TERMS OF THE
INCORPORATION OF THE- TRIBES I
WOULD- HAVE TO DEFER TO THE- FAA
WOULD- INCORPORATE THOSE MEMBERS
AS THEY DEVELOP THAT PROGRAM.
WHAT I ACTUALLY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THAT WHATEVER THIS
MONEY AND SO THAT THE WORK WILL
BE HAND IN HAND WITH OUR TRAVEL
LEADERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS. OUT THERE SO
THAT WE'RE NOT PERPETUATING A
SITUATION WHEN AND WHERE. WORDS
WERE WERE NOT LETTING THEM BE
THE CHANGES THAT THEY NEED TO BE
I THINK WE HAVE A HISTORY OF
TELLING PEOPLE WHAT THEY NEED
AND HOW THEY NEEDED AND- NOT
NECESSARILY LSTENING TO THEM SO
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- ARE
LISTENING TO THE LEADERS AS THEY
ARE. BETTER ABLE TO GUIDE US AND
THEIR NEEDS AND THEN THERE'S
SOLUTIONS OUT THERE- AND ALSO.
WHILE A MULTI YEAR APPROACH
MAKES SENSE A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION OF WHETHER OR NOT
FOUR MILLION A YEAR IS GOING TO
BE ENOUGH FOR THE VISION THAT WE
HAVE FOR THIS. TASK FOR THIS
WORK. MADAM CHAIR THIS IS KATIE
HOWARD WITH THE SEC CAN YOU HEAR
ME ALRIGHT. YES OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ON YOUR QUESTION IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ONE AND THE
PSEC HAS ADMINISTERED- SOME
TRIBAL CONNECTED GRANTS IN THE
RECENT YEARS. AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE EXECUTIVE STEERING.
COMMITTEE PROCESS THAT THE BSE
THING USES FOR GRANTS SUCH AS
THIS ONE. IS A REALLY GOOD FIT
FOR THE EXACT REASON THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHEN WE- PUT THAT
TRIBAL YOUTH. DIVERSION GRANT
OUT A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE
MEMBERS OF THAT EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE. WERE LARGELY
AND MY COLLEAGUE RICARDO MAY
HAVE MORE INFORMATION READILY
AVAILABLE. LARGELY IF NOT
EXCLUSIVELY- FROM THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY THIS IS ABSOLUTELY-
GRANT THAT REQUIRES SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS AT THE TABLE-
FROM THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY SO
THAT WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE. HOW
DOES THIS WORK WOULD BE
APPROACHED. CAN ANY MORE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
MISTER DANCER REAL QUICK TWO ONE
THANK THEM WHOEVER PUT THIS IN A
BECAUSE I WAS AT THE- THE
HEARING ON THE SUBJECT AND I
TOLD THE- TRIBAL LEADERS THEY TO
COME TO THIS COMMITTEE AND ASK
FOR MONEY ALSO WHOEVER PT IT IN
THE BUDGET- I WANT TO THANK THEM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHOEVER
DID IT. AND UNTIL THE TRIED WITH
ALL MY IDEAS MULTIPLE
RESPONSIBILITY. THANK YOU. WE'LL
WE'LL LET OUR- I WILL LET HER
ONETRAVEL NUMBER IN THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE SOME OF THAT
CREDIT. HE'S BEEN WORKING OUT
THERE- OKAY THEIR NUMBER
QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE SECOND ADAM OFFICER WELLNESS
. THANK YOU AND- I'LL PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE REQUEST
FOR PEACE OFFICER WELLNESS
GRANTS THE MAY REVISION PROPOSED
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE OFFICER WELLNESS
GRANTS TO CITIES COUNTIES- TO
INCREASE ACCESS AND SERVICES FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELLNESS PROGRAMS. HIS
OFFICERS EXPERIENCE HIGH RATES
OF STRESS RELATED ILLNESSES
DEPRESSION TRAUMA SUICIDAL
IDEATION ESSENTIALLY LEAD TO AN
EARLIER DEATH ON AVERAGE IN
COMPARISON TO THE GENERAL
POPULATION THIS FUNDING WILL BE
DISBURSED- YEAH DISPERSED TO
COUNTIES BASED ON AN ALLOCATION
SCHEDULE THAT FUNDS COUNTIES AND
SMALL MEDIUM AND LARGE. GROUPS
AND THEN LOS ANGELES WOULD ALSO
RECEIVE ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THESE
FUNDS BASED ON ITS SITES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED OUT
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING TO
DEVELOP MORE INDIVIDUAL AND
ORGANIZATIONAL WELLNESS
STRATEGIES CONNECT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSON PARTNERS TO
WELLNESS RESOURCES AND CREATE A
NETWORK OF WELLNESS
PROFESSIONALS AND THAT'S AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT FOR A LONG
TERM DURABLE OFFICER WELLNESS
SOLUTION. THIS PROPOSAL HOWEVER
ADDRESSES THE UNIQUE AN
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE URGENT
RESOURCES. TO ADDRESS PEACE
OFFICER WELLNESS. WHICH HAVE
GROWN NEED MORE DIRE IN RECENT
YEARS HELP YOUR POLICE FORCE
WILL BE BETTER EQUIPPED TO
POSITIVELY ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITIES THEY LIVE AND WORK
AND PROMOTE OVERALL PUBLIC
SAFETY. THESE RESOURCES WILL
PROVIDE QUICK RELIEF TO THE
MENTAL PHYSICAL STRUGGLES THAT
CALIFORNIA FRONTLINE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SPACE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO BUILDING RESILIENT OFFICERS
AN IMPROVING COMMUNITY TRUST AND
RELATIONS. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. GOOD
COULD JUST MAKE THE DELEO
CAITLIN O'NEILL AT THE L. A. O.
WE FOUND THIS PROPOSAL TO BE
PREMATURE- AND- WE HAVE CONCERNS
THAT IT WOULD ULTIMATELY NOT BE
AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO.
IMPROVE OFFICER WELLNESS AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET IT INCLUDED A
PROPOSAL FOR FIVE MILLION FOR
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. TO
IDENTIFY EFFECTIVE WELLNESS
STRATEGIES AND HOST WHILE
NETWORK- WORKSHOPS FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENTS. AND SO-
ESSENTIALLY WE FIND IT PREMATURE
TO BE- SIMULTANEOUSLY PROPOSING
TO SPEND- FIFTEEN MILLION IN.
FORMULA GRANTS TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT BEFORE- POST HAS HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY WHAT
STRATEGIES- ARE LIKELY TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN DOING THAT. I'M AND
SO. TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE HOWEVER- WISHES TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
OFFICER WELLNESS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR IT COULD SIMPLY APPROVE THE
POST JANUARY OFFICER WELLNESS
PROPOSAL AS PROPOSED OR AT AN
AUGMENTED LEVEL INSTEAD OF
ESTABLISHING THIS NEW GRANT
PROGRAM. COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
BUT YOU PROBABLY KNOW OR YOU MAY
NOT KNOW- I'VE BEEN TRYING TO
GET A MENTAL HEALTH FOR CDC ARE
IN PRISON GUARDS- BUT A VERY
CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE. A SON WHO
IS A- PROBATION OFFICER IN CDCR
OF COMMITTED SUICIDE AND IS
PROBABLY MORE. OFFICERS THAT
PRISON GUARDS THAT HAVE
COMMITTED SUICIDE THAT HAVE BEEN
KILLED BY PRISONERS. AND SO
THERE'S SOMETHING GOING ON WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. I DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT THIS PROGRAM BUT I
DEFINITELY BELIEVE WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH IT. IF
ANYTHING WE PROBABLY NEED TO
TALK TO CDCR. THEY HAVE AN
EXISTING PROGRAM ALREADY- THEY
ALSO SHARE THE UNION WHICH IS
IRONIC FIFTY P. AWAY ALSO CHAIRS
YOU'RE CONCERNED THAT IT WOULD
BE MISUSED BY THE MEMBERS. AND
THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S SOME SAFEGUARDS. AT ODDS
FROM STRUCTURE TO ENSURE THAT.
THAT PEOPLE JUST DON'T USE IT
FOR THEIR OWN GAINS AND SO DO
YOUR YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT I THINK
WE MAY HAVE A HEAD START IF YOU
WERE TO LOOK AT A MODEL THAT
CDCR HAS RIGHT NOW WITH THEIR
UNION. BUT MORE IMPORTANT- OF. I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS THE
QUESTION FOR- WHO'S EVER GOING
TO IMPLEMENT THIS PSEC. IS THIS-
FOR POLICE. LOCAL POLICE
SHERIFF'S HIGHWAY PATROL OF
ANYBODY THAT WE'RE THE BAD
PROBATION OFFICERS ON HOW.
WIDESPREAD DEEP DO WE GET WITH
THE TRAINING. OF THIS ORDER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
THIS IS KATIE HOWARD WITH THE
SEC AND I WILL ASK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM DEAL AFTER TO A BACKING UP
OR CORRECT ME IF I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S RIGHT BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT THE FORMULA FOR THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS THAT IT IS
DIRECTED TO FRONT NOT FRONT LINE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SO THAT
WOULD BE DEFINED AS- CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICERS AND-
SHERIFFS WHO PROVIDE THE
FRONTLINE LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
OTHER ENTITIES YOU MENTION CHP
AND PROBATION I THINK ARE NOT
CONTEMPLATED. FOR THIS. THAT
CURRICULA YES THAT'S CORRECT TO
THINK UNITED. GOOD AND THEN I'M
OFF ON ON HOW TO- INSURE THAT
THESE THESE MONIES AREN'T WASTED
AND THAT WE CAN COME BACK TO
THIS COMMITTEE TO SAY WHICH IS A
GOOD PROGRAM THE WAY WE DID THE
GRANT PROGRAM DOES THAT WORK- I
GUESS TALK ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY-
IS THERE ANYTHING IN. THE
PROPOSAL THAT LOOKED AT THAT.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
KATIE HOWARD AGAIN IN THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE- IT TALKS
ABOUT A REPORTING REQUIREMENT IN
PROVISION CHIU AND- IT IT
STIPULATES THAT DEPARTMENTS OR
AGENCIES THAT WISH TO RECEIVE
THIS FUNDING I HAVE TO AGREE TO
PROVIDE DATA ON HOW THE
EXPENDITURES ARE USED TO SUPPORT
PEACE OFFICER PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS- AND
THE BCC WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
COLLECTING THAT DATA AND
PROVIDING AN EASY WAY IN WHICH-
I AGENCIES CAN REPORT TO US HOW
THEY'VE USED THE FUNDING. GOOD
THANK YOU AND I JUST HANDED THE
GAVEL BACK TO THE CHAIR. THE L.
A. U. S. B. NO I JUST WOULDN'T
KNOW THAT THAT'LL THE LANGUAGE
DOES REQUIRE REPORTING ON HOW
THE MONEY IS SPENT BUT IT
DOESN'T THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD GET BACK
BACK INFORMATION ON OUTCOMES
LIKE THE ACTUAL FEET WELLNESS OF
OFFICERS THERE ARE YOU KNOW
PERCEIVED MENTAL HEALTH STATE.
SUICIDE ETCETERA- SO TO THE
EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
I THINK AS YOU WERE ALLUDING TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW MORE ABOUT
WHAT STRATEGIES ARE EFFECTIVE IT
IT COULD CONSIDER BUILDING IN A
MORE ROBUST REPORTING
REQUIREMENT OR EVALUATION OR
PUTTING MORE STRICT PARAMETERS
ON WHAT THE MONEY COULD BE SPENT
FOR BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT SEEMS
QUITE. BROAD THANK YOU. I'M CAN
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY WERE NOT
GIVING THIS MONEY TO POST TO
ADMINISTER THE GRANT PROGRAM SO
SINCE THAT'S- THE THAT TOO WAS
KIND TASKED WITH OFFICER
WELLNESS. THIS ISN'T EVEN IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO CLOSE.
ATOMISTIC FUNDING WORK FOR A
PROGRAM TO DEVELOP TRAINING AND
RESOURCES WHICH WILL BE THE LONG
TERM DURABLE SOLUTION. THIS IS-
COMING THROUGH THE PORT OF SPAIN
COMMUNITY CRRECTIONS WILL GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
IT'S WITHIN THE WHEEL HOUSE OF
THE COURT STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS AND THEY'RE GRANT
PROGRAMS- AND SO AND THEY WORK
FREQUENTLY WITH WITH THE VARIOUS
CITIES AND FIDUCIARY SPEEDS.
SINCE THIRD WITHIN SPECIFIC
WITHIN THERE WILL HOUSE WORK
WITH THE COUNTIES AND WITH THE
CITIES. BUT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
WITHIN THEIR WILL HOUSE TO DO
THE- OFFICER WELLNESS. ARE YOU
EMPLOYED ARE YOU SAYING THAT
IT'S WITHIN THEIR WILL HAVE TO
DO BOTH. THIS IS AN S. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA THIS IS KATIE
HOWARD WITH THE BSE THING WE
HAVE DONE SEVERAL GRANTS THAT
ARE SIMILAR IN- FOCUS- WITH CITY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE NOT
SPECIFICALLY SOMETHING ON
OFFICER WELLNESS BUT WE HAD
GRANT PROGRAMS RELATED TO. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITY
RELATIONS- AND A FEW YEARS AGO
SOME THINGS RELATED TO. OF
FUNDING THAT HAD ALONG WITH IT
SOME REPORTING TO THE SEC ON USE
OF FORCE INCIDENTS SO- AS MISS
MANDHANA SAID D. EITHER GRANTS
SIMILAR TO OTHERS THAT WE DONE
BUT YES IN A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT. TOPIC AREA AND
OBVIOUSLY AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER SAID ARE A REALLY
CONCERNING AREA OF FOCUS ABOUT-
OFFICERS AND THEIR- THE- THE
WELLNESS SUPPORTS THAT ARE
NEEDED. SO I THINK GOING ON THAT
WITH MISTER DANCER I ALSO ON IT
I ALSO HAVE CONCERNS I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE PROVIDING THE
SUPPORT NEEDED I DOES HAVE
CONCERNS OF WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE
MOVING IN THE BEST DIRECTION FOR
THESE GRANT DOLLARS AND WHY WERE
NOT YOU SEEN. POST THAT HAS
EXPERIENCE ON A MENTAL HEALTH OR
OR HOW TO BETTER BUILD IN THE
PARTNERSHIP- IN DESCRIBED.
PROGRAM- AND SO. ESPECIALLY AS I
AGREE WITH THE L. A. THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE CLEAR OUTCOME
METRICS TO ENSURE OUR DOLLARS
ARE BEING USED PROPERLY. AND SO
IT IT SEEMS LIKE A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY. I TO SEE. TO HAVE
TWO DIFFERENT PIECES GOING ONE
POST HAS BEEN WORKING ON MEANT
OFFICER WALLACE ALREADY.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU I CHAIR
GARCIA THIS IS ALICE THANK YOU
IT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE COMMISSION ISN'T
WITH US TODAY BUT I JUST WANTED
TO UNDERSCORE THAT WE SEE THESE
COMPANIES PROGRAMS IS RELATIVELY
COMPLIMENTARY BUT THEY HAVE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FOCUS SO I
CAN SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO POST
FOCUSED. THEIR PROPOSED THEIR
FIVE MILLION PROPOSAL IS REALLY
ABOUT BUILDING STATEWIDE
CAPACITY FOR OFFICER WELLNESS
PROGRAMS AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
WAYS IN WHICH THEY PROPOSE TO DO
THAT INCLUDING PARTNERING WITH
SOME LOCAL ENTITIES TO HOST A
VARIETY OF WORKSHOPS AS WELL AS
PARTNERING WITH ACADEMIA TO
CIRCULATE SOME OF THOSE BEST
PRACTICES TO REVIEW THESE
PROPOSALS. ARE NOT ONE AS BEING
IN LOVE WITH THE OTHER BUT IT'S
TWO COMPLEMENTARY EFFORTS WITH
POST PROGRAM FOCUSED ON
STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO BUILD
CAPACITY AND THESE FUNDS BEING
SPECIFICALLY FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
FOR WELLNESS INITIATIVES. AT NOT
NOT. CONVINCED LET ME SAY THIS
WE NEED MONEY FOR OFFICER
WELLNESS- AND SO I DON'T WANT
THIS TO BE MISCONSTRUED I I'M
JUST NOT CONVINCED YET THAT THIS
IS THE BEST DIRECTION OF HOW TO
ENSURE THESE. THESE DOLLARS ARE
EFFECTIVE. AND SO IF YOU WE DO
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE DOWN THIS
ROUTE I THINK EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY HAVE VERY CLEAR.
OUTCOME METRICS TO ENSURE WE ARE
GETTING OUR MONEY'S WORTH AND
THAT THERE'S MORE CLARITY ABOUT
WHAT THIS MONEY CAN BE USED FOR.
AS WELL AS SO THAT WE CAN SAY
THAT THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER.
I DON'T WANT TO END UP IN A
SITUATION LIKE WE HAVE ON
HOMELESSNESS- WE'VE SPENT. MANY
BILLION DOLLARS AND WE CAN'T
TELL WE SEE THE PROBLEM IS ONLY
GETTING WORSE. I AND STILL. WANT
TO BE MINDFUL AND LESSON LEARNS
AND PLAN AHEAD AND IN THE SPACE
AS WELL. ANYONE OFTEN ADD
ANYTHING ELSE TO THIS OFFICER
WELLNESS. THANK YOU THEN WE ARE
STILL WITH THE- B. SEC AND WE
HAVE NEXT THE THIRD ITEM WHICH
IS MOBILE PROBATION. YES THANK
YOU- SO THIS IS THE PROGRAM I
REQUEST FOR MOBILE PROBATION
SERVICE GRANTS TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM
TO COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT'S
INTENDED TO REDUCING. BARRIERS
AND INCREASE ACCESS TO PROBATION
SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY BY
ESTABLISHING MOBILE PROBATION
SERVICE CENTERS AT THIS PROPOSED
SOLUTION FOR JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS STRUGGLING TO MEET
COURT ORDERED REQUIREMENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE RUN HOLLISTER
HAVE TRANSPORTATION
DIFFICULTIES. IS A POSITIVE
APPROACH THAT SUPPORTS HI
COUNTIES WITH ASSISTING COURT
APPEARANCES ARE PRE TRIAL CHECK
INS DOING NEEDS ASSESSMENTS-
IDENTIFYING HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT AND PROVIDING OTHER
SERVICES- POTENTIALLY PROVIDING. SOME REHABILITATIVE SERVICES.
EXACTLY THIS GRANT FROM IS INTO
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO PURCHASE
NECESSARY EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
COMPUTERS PRINTERS- AT
OUTFITTING THEIR VEHICLES WITH
TELEVISIONS- AND PROVIDING
MOBILE HOT SPOTS OFFICE SUPPLIES
AND SOMEONE. SO THESE RESOURCES
WILL ALLOW COUNTY APPLICANTS TO
THE GRANT PROGRAM TO BETTER
BRIDGE INDIVIDUALS SERVICES AND
THE COURTS ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
FOR EXPERIENCING STRUGGLES THAT
MAKE IT DIFFICULTY. MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO REMAIN CONNECTED
WITH COURT OBLIGATIONS ARE
COUNTY SERVICES I'M ABOUT I'M
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS
. CAITLIN O'NEILL AT THE L. A.
L. WE HAVE TWO MAIN CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL THE FIRST IS A
LACK OF DETAILS AND SPECIFICALLY
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT ABLE
TO PROVIDE KEY INFORMATION ABOUT
THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM OR HOW.
THE FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOCATED
AND PRIORITIZED. IN ADDITION THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE. IN A INFORMATION
DEMONSTRATING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE MODEL THE MOBILE
PROBATION UNIT MODEL. THE
RATIONALE FOR THE SPECIFIC
DOLLAR AMOUNT PROPOSED OR COUNTY
INTEREST IN THE PROGRAM. AND
THEN THE SECOND ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IS THAT-
YOU WANT TO LOOK AT THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
PROGRAM CREATED BY SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS FOR PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS IN- IN ORDER TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON
FELONY SUPERVISION WHO ARE SENT
TO STATE PRISON. SO SPECIFICALLY
THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
CONSIDER. THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THIS PROGRAM IS NEEDED GIVEN
THAT COUNTIES ALREADY HAVE A
FUNDING SOURCE SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT THAT COULD BE USED TO
IMPLEMENT- THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS- SO GIVEN THE TIMING
AND THE LACK OF DETAILS PROVIDED
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER THIS- PROPOSAL AS PART
OF NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET PROCESS AT
WHICH POINT THE ADMINISTRATION.
SHOULD HAVE MORE TIME TO PROVIDE
A MORE DETAILED AND WELL THOUGHT
OUT PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. HOW
LONG DOES THIS PLASTER COUNTY
PROGRAM. BEEN BEEN FUNCTIONING.
I AM I BELIEVE IT WAS FROM
TWENTY TWENTY BUT I'D HAVE TO
GET THE EXACT FOR YOU I'M SORRY
. SO IT'S- AT I'VE I'VE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT ACTUALLY
DID AND START TO TAKE EFFECT.
WORK UNTIL APRIL OF THIS YEAR SO
IT'S ONLY BEEN. IN PRACTICE FOR.
MAYBE TWO MONTHS A LITTLE LESS
THAN TWO MONTHS.
SO I WOULD LIKE AN ANSWER.
BECAUSE I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU SEE INTO A PROGRAM WHERE WE
HAVE REAL DATA THAT IT IS IT IS
BEING. SUCCESSFUL I AND IF NOT
THEN MAYBE THE ALLEY-
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE WAIT FOR
A YEAR SO WE HAD DATA TO BASE IT
ON WOULD BE MORE APPROPRIATE. AT
OF A MORE APPROPRIATE. FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. SEVERAL
THEY'RE FROM FROM A FINANCE- I
WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU IN
TERMS OF HOW LONG THAT PROGRAM
HAS BEEN AVAILABLE BUT
ESSENTIALLY THIS DOES. BY
BRINGING OUT PROBATION SERVICES
TO THE COMMUNITY IT DOES
INCREASE ACCESS AND- OVERALL
REDUCES THOSE BARRIERS AND THEY
CAN AND THEY ARE SHOWING THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO BRING THOSE
SERVICES TO THE FOLKS AND
PLASTER COUNTY- AND- WE WOULD TO
HAVE. IT SENT TO VERIZON AND
GIVE COUNTIES THE ABILITY TO
EXPAND SERVICES LIKE THAT. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE HAVE
REAL DATA THAT SOMETHING THAT
WAS WELL INTENTIONED ESPECIALLY
PRODUCING THE RESULTS THAT WE
WANT- VERSUS WE THINK THAT IT'S
A GOOD IDEA WITHOUT THE DATA AND
SO IT DOESN'T SOUND RIGHT NOW
LIKE WE HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
TO EXPAND THIS. PROGRAM I TO
OTHER COUNTIES OUT THERE IF IT'S
ONLY BEEN IN PRACTICE FOR LESS
THAN TWO MONTHS. AND SO. AT
WHICH WOULD. OFTENTIMES WE HAVE
GOOD INTENTIONS AND PRACTICES
AND ALWAYS TURN OUT TO BE THE
SAME. LET'S SAY WE GET AN
ANSWER- IN THE NEAR FUTURE THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED. THANK YOU. OKAY OKAY THEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION WHERE WE HAVE.
THREE DIFFERENT ITEMS AND AGAIN
FOR THE DEPARTMENT- IF YOU COULD
STOP BETWEEN ITEM SO THAT WE
COULD HEAR FROM THE ALLEY- IN
FROM THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE
FIRST ONE IS OF THE POPULATION
PROJECTION OR VIEW A REVIEW.
INCLUDING EXISTING OPEN BED
CAPACITY AND WITH CDCR IS DOING
OPERATIONALLY TO ADDRESS. THE
LATEST POPULATION NUMBERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M OUT ON THEM- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- MADELINE THE CLEAN
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION TO BE DIRECTOR
OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES. TO
PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF
THAT POPULATION CHANGES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BAY REVISION OF
THE SPRING TWENTY TWENTY TWO
POPULATION PROJECTIONS
ANTICIPATE THAT THE AVERAGE
DAILY INSTITUTION POPULATION TO
BE APPROXIMATELY NINETY NINE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. OF THE PROJECTED
EIGHTY P. FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE IS ANTICIPATED TO INCREASE
SLIGHTLY TO ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THREE THOUSAND. AND THESE
ADJUSTMENTS RESULTS- ARE A
DECREASE OF APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
TEN THOUSAND IN THE BUDGET YEAR
OVER- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTIONS- THE PROJECTIONS
INCLUDE DATA THROUGH DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
AND INCORPORATE THE ESTIMATED
IMPACT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY THREE.
A CURRENT ADULT INMATE
POPULATION AS A MALE ELEVENTH
WAS. APPROXIMATELY NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND. AFTER THAT PAROLED
POPULAR WERE- THAT MAY REVISION
PROJECTS ABOUT A POPULATION OF
ABOUT FORTY THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED. AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AN INCREASE OF ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PAROLEES OVER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTIONS. A CITY NEXT WEEK
WOULD BE HERE IS. JURICA SANO
WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
TOP MANAGEMENT. INFORMATION THE
WORD GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN
SHIRTLESS ON ALL AROUND THIRTY
DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES SPORTS
FOR THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS ARE THE MAJOR
REVISION PROPOSES UP TO THREE
ADDITIONAL. PRESENCE THAT COULD
CLOSE. BY 200-024-2000 TWENTY
FIVE FISCAL YEAR THIS SYSTEMS
LONGER- LONG TERM PROJECTIONS
WHICH INDICATE LOWER POPULATIONS
ARE FOR THE FUTURE YEARS HOLDS
TRUE. THE OFFICER RESEARCH
CALCULATIONS ARE GENERALLY VERY
ACCURATE- IN THE SHORT TERM
WHICH IS USUALLY ONE TO THREE
FISCAL YEARS HOWEVER LONGER TERM
PROJECTIONS- ARE SUBJECT TO SOME
UNCERTAINTY YES NO STATUTORY
INDOOR POLICY CHANGES. ARE MADE
WHICH COULD AFFECT THE LEVEL OF
VIEW COURSE OF THE POPULATION
ADDITIONALLY THE CHAIR WE EMERGE
FROM A COMPLETELY FROM KOBE IN
NINETEEN BOB CAN'T DIDN'T EVEN
ARE SHORT TERM POPULATION
ESTIMATES ARE SUBJECT TO A
LITTLE BIT MORE UNCERTAINTY THAN
PREVIOUS YEARS. AT THIS TIME CDC
OR HAS NOT IDENTIFIED WHICH
PRISONS- WILL WILL BE CLOSED. OF
THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL- UROLOGIC
CRITERIA AS DEFINED IN PENAL
CODE FIVE ZERO ZERO THREE POINT
SEVEN AS A BASIS FOR MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION I'M TAKE MANY
FACTORS INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN
SELECTING INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS
HOUSING NEEDS THAT TYPE. COST
OPERATE RECENT INVESTMENTS
EXCEPT HER. ONCE IDENTIFIED THE
SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PRISON CLOSURE I WILL BE
CAPTURED IN THE BCG YOU. SIMILAR
TO THE ONE SUBMITTED FOR. LUGER
OF THE JEWISH VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS INTERESTED
CALIFORNIA- WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
CURRENT PROJECTIONS INDICATE A
LOWER EIGHTY P. OR AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION IN OR OUT HERE WHICH-
ON IT YEAH I'M HERE TO. THE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU SHOULD
HAVE. BUDGET I KNOW NOW THAT THE
L. A. L. I'LL JUST MAKE TWO
BRIEF COMMENTS- THE FIRST IS
THAT WE REVIEWED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POPULATION
PROJECTIONS AND ASSOCIATED
BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS FOR THAT- FOR
THE CURRENT AND BUDGET YEARS AS
WELL AS THE LONG TERM-
PROJECTIONS OF THAT POPULATIONS
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX AND WE THINK THAT
THEY- APPEAR REASONABLE- AND
THEN THE SECOND. COMMENT WE JUST
NOTE THAT- AS THE COMMITTEE IS
AWARE THAT AND- DEPARTMENT OR
THE STATE DIDN'T HAVE COMMITTED
TO CLOSING- THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL CENTER- THOUGH THAT
IS ON HOLD PENDING LITIGATION.
AND THE MAY REVISE NOTES THAT.
THE STATE COULD BE ABLE TO CLOSE
AN ADDITIONAL THREE UNNAMED
PRESENTS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND THEN
HOWEVER WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS. THEY
SUGGEST THAT AFTER THOSE FOUR
PRISONS ARE CLOSE THE STATE.
COULD IN TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
HI- IN EXCESS OF TEN THOUSAND
EMPTY BEDS. SO WE WOULD- WE
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT. HOW
IT PLANS TO ADDRESS PRISON
CAPACITY AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX AND ONWARD. I AM LET
ME SHATTER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND TO RESPOND TO
REITERATE WHAT MISTER LOZANO
SAID GIVEN THE CURRENT
PROJECTIONS AND CABBIE ADDING
THAT IF WE ASSUME THERE ARE NO
MAJOR POLICY CHANGES AND THAT
THE PROJECTIONS REMAIN
RELATIVELY UNCHANGED THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT IT
MAY BE POSSIBLE TO CLOSE THE
ADDITIONAL THREE BY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE BEYOND THE TO
CURRENTLY IDENTIFIED. AND THAT
MEANS THAT CDCR WOULD HAVE TO
ACTUALLY FOR PRISON CLOSURES
WITHIN THE NEXT THREE YEARS. TO
REITERATE THE PROJECTIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO SOME UNCERTAINTY AND
THE DECLINING PROJECTIONS
ASSUME. I GET NO CHANGES- WHICH
WOULD AFFECT THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO BE MINDFUL OF OUR
NEED TO KEEP CALIFORNIA'S PRISON
POPULATION BELOW OUR COURT ORDER
CALCULATION THRESHOLD. AND
MAINTAIN FACILITIES APPROPRIATE
FOR THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THEIR KERR ST POPULATIONS NEEDS
AS WELL AS FOR STAFF VISITORS
AND VOLUNTEERS AT THE PRISONS.
THE ADMINISTRATION REMAINS%
COMMITTED TO RIGHT SIZING THE
PRISON SYSTEM TO REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF THE STATE. AND THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO MAKE
STRIDES TO DECREASE ITS CAPACITY
IT CHEAP SAVINGS AND REDUCE ITS
POSITIONS AS. IT IS SAFE AND
FEASIBLE TO DO SO. THANK YOU.
OKAY- THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. AS
OUR OUR POPULATION CONTINUES TO
DECREASE AND EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE THE TO THE CREASE PAST. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. I HOW ARE
WE WORKING TO REDUCE COST- ALONG
THE WAY BEYOND HIS CLOSING DOWN
THE- TO ENSURE THE PRESENCE THAT
WE HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED YET.
CERTAINLY IT AGAIN THIS IS
MAGGIE WITH A CLEAN RECORD CAN
YOU SPEAK UP I CAN'T WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU. ALL THE DAYS THAT
LITTLE BIT BETTER HALF OF MUCH
BETTER. SO AS WE WORK THROUGH
THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT HAPPEN EACH
YEAR AT THE- R. D. A. I.
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
FOLKS WILL MANAGE AND LOOK AT
THE BAD PLAN AND SEE WHERE
CAPACITY IS OR IS NOT AND WE
MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS AS PART
OF THE- GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
YOUR VISION PROCESS THROUGH WHAT
WE CALL THE HOUSING UNIT
CONVERSIONS. OR CLOSE FOR A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME DEPENDING
ON THE NEEDS OF THE INSTITUTION
SO WE IT'S AN OPERATIONAL
DECISION WE- DEPENDING ON AGAIN
THE NEEDS OF THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION- THE INFLOW AND
OUTFLOW OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE
AND THEN- SPECIFIC HEALTH CARE-
AND OTHER NEEDS THAT THEY'RE
ADDRESSING. SO THOSE ARE THOSE
SAVINGS ARE ARE WILL BE ENDED UP
HE CAPTURED IT AGAIN AS MISTER
LOZANO STATED WHEN WE DO CLOSE A
FULL INSTITUTION WE SUBMIT A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL TO TAKE
DOWN BUT THOSE COSTS ARE ONGOING
AND SO YOU'LL SEE THAT
CORRESPONDING REDUCTION IN.
STAFFING AND OTHER SAVINGS LIKE
OP BUT ONLY THE OPERATING
EXPENSES AND EQUIPMENT. MISTERLUCKY YEAH I JUST HAD A QUICK
QUESTION. CAN THE ADMINISTRATION
THE DEPARTMENT GUARANTEE THAT
THE INCREASING CAPITAL OUTLAY
FUNDING WILL NOT FUND PRISONS
LIKELY TO CLOSE IN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. AT THIS TIME THAT THE
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE- FOR CONSIDERATION
REPRESENT THE MOST CRITICAL
PROJECTS- THAT NEED TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF. THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION WE HOUSING STAFF THAT
WORK THERE AND SO I CAN WE CAN'T
GUARANTEE THAT THAT IS GOING TO
BE THE CASE BUT AGAIN AS MISTER
LOZANO STATED WHEN WE CAN TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION WHICH
PRESENTS TO CLOSE RECENT
FACILITY INVESTMENTS WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THAT ASSESSMENT.
OKAY. MISTER JOHN FIRE I JUST
HAVE ONE QUESTION WITH A
QUESTION WE KEEP GOING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN A LOT OF TIMES WE
DON'T GET THE ANSWER PROBABLY
MOST OF THE TIME. THE QUESTION
IS WHEN WILL CDCR LET US KNOW
WHICH FACILITIES WE CAN CLOSE. I
KNOW THIS IS A- SEEM TO BE
DIFFICULT BUT THERE HAS TO BE
SOME KIND ANALYSIS DONE BECAUSE
I THINK THE LAWSUIT THAT IS KIND
OF STYMIED US FROM CLOSING DOWN
IS BECAUSE PART OF THAT I THINK
PART RATIONALE AS WE HAD DONE
OUR DUE DILIGENCE IN ENSURING
THAT THE PUBLIC IS SAFE AND THAT
WOULD THAT THE FACILITIES ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE BEST. AT
CLOSING. SO CAN WE GET AN IDEA
OF WHEN YOU WILL GET BACK TO US.
WITH THE LIST OF. POTENTIAL
PRISON CLOSURE. I READ FOR A HA
. I'M SORRY TO DISAPPOINT YOU-
HOWEVER- THEY I THINK OF
SOMETHING THAT WE PROBABLY THAT
THIS DEPARTMENT IS KIND OF
PAINTING ANYWAY AS WE ARE TRYING
TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AND OPEN AS
POSSIBLE AND WE'VE BEEN HAVING
THOSE COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE STAFF TO
KEEP THOSE LINES OF
COMMUNICATION OPEN WHEN
DISCUSSING THIS VERY SENSITIVE
TOPIC SO AGAIN AN ADDITIONAL
TUNNEL STATED WHEN WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THE THREE POTENTIALLY
THREE PRESENT THAT WE CAN CLOSE
AND WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THE
CRITERIA OUTLINED IN THE PENAL
CODE. AND SO WE WILL NEED TO DO
THAT ASSESSMENT AND LOOK AT ALL
THE FACTORS THAT HE'S HAD STATED
SUCH AS- YOU KNOW HOUSING NEEDS
THAT TYPE THE POPULAR BUT NEEDS
OF THE POPULATION RECENT-
FACILITY INVESTMENTS THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS SO THAT'S NOT A
PROCESS THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS
ADDITIONALLY AS WE ALL KNOW WE
ARE STILL IN LITIGATION OVER THE
CLOSURE OF CCC AND I CAN. TELL
YOU WHEN THAT LITIGATION WILL BE
COMPLETED AND WHAT THE OUTCOME
WILL BE SO WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN WE ARE
DEVELOPING OUR POTENTIAL- LIST
OF PRISONS THAT COULD BE CLOSE
SO I WILL CMMIT TO YOU I THINK
THE SECRETARY HAS ALSO COMMITTED
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO BEING OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT AND CONTINUING
COMMUNICATION ON THIS VERY
SENSITIVE TOPIC- BUT AS SOON AS
WE GET TO THE POINT WHERE WE CAN
ANNOUNCE. WHICH PRINTABLE CLOSE
AND WILL BE A PHASE THAT THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE ALL THREE BY X.
DATE IT WILL BE IT'S GOING TO
TAKE THE DEPARTMENT TIME TO
IMPLEMENT THERE'S A LOT OF LABOR
THINGS AT LOGISTICS THAT NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT SO I REALLY THIS
IS KIND OF A LONG ANSWER BUT I
WE ARE COMMITTED TO. AGAIN
KEEPING THAT OPEN LINE. OF
COMMUNICATION AND THEN TO. GET
POINT SHOULD. PROJECTIONS CLOSE
THREE. PRISONS BY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. SO WE'LL HAVE AN
ANSWER BY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. NOTE SO THAT SO WE WON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER BY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
YOU HAVE A LOT OF- SOME PRISONS
IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE BUT
YOU WILL. LET ME KNOW BEFORE
THEM. WE WILL LET YOU KNOW
BEFORE THEN BECAUSE IT WILL BE
PART OF THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL PROCESS WILL NEED TO
SUBMIT. A REQUEST TO REDUCE
RESOURCES AND THERE WILL BE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT MADE- BUT AGAIN I
CAN'T COMMIT TO EXACTLY WHAT
TIME WHAT THAT IS BUT IF WE-
ANTICIPATE CLOSING BY THE END OF
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. WE
WOULD NEED TO LET YOU KNOW AT
LEAST A YEAR IN ADVANCE SO IF
THAT GIVES YOU SOME. AT SOME
LEVEL OF COMFORT ALL BETTER THAN
BEFORE. THANK YOU. OF IT FEELS A
LITTLE BIT LIKE GROUNDHOG STATE
. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS TOPIC
AND SO WE HAVE GOT INTO NEW
PIECES OF INFORMATION THAT THERE
WILL BE THREE ADDITIONAL BY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND THAT
AT LEAST A YEAR AHEAD OF TIME
WILL NOW WITH THOSE THREE ARE
AND SO I DO WANT TO GIVE YOU
CREDIT FOR THE TWO. ADDITIONAL
PIECES OF INFORMATION YOU'VE
SHARED WITH. BUT WE ARE REALLY
FRUSTRATED WE WANT TO MAKE SURE-
WE WANT TO HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
THAT OUT LEAD DOLLARS YOU'RE
SPENDING NOW ARE NOT GOING TO BE
FOR NOT. AND I'M NOT GOING TO BE
PART OF THOSE PERSONS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE. CLOSE AND SO WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
GIVEN THAT. PASSED AND GIVEN THE
LACK OF INFORMATION. WHEN THE
TWO THINGS I MENTIONED THERE AT
THE BEGINNING THAT'S ALL WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO GET. THE WHOLE YEARACTUALLY THE WHOLE YEAR AND A
HALF I'VE BEEN HERE NOT AS THE
CHAIR. SOUTH THERE- AND SO IT IS
IT IS TROUBLING AS OUR DUTY HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE IS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING
PROTECTED AND- IMPROPERLY. USE
THAT OUT THERE. AND SELL ASKS.
THIS PROCESS QUICKLY MOVES
BEFORE THE YEAR'S OVER I HOPE
YOU GIVE US MORE THAN JUST THOSE
TWO NEGATIVE INFORMATION THAT
YOU HAVE. GIVEN US THUS FAR. I
LIKE MY GOD HOW'S THEY TO COME
TO AN END- AND I WOULD LIKE THIS
ALSO START THINKING BEYOND
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE IF THESE
PROJECTIONS ARE. REAL THERE
THERE'S PLAN THAT SHOULD BE
HAPPENING IN THE NEAR FUTURE AND
AGAIN DOLLARS THAT WE COULD
POSSIBLY BE INVEST IN THAT WILL
BE FOR NOT COME TWENTY SIX. OUT
THERE WITH SOUTH OF TROUBLING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS I KEEP
ADDING BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
INTERCHANGEABLY I APOLOGIZE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ARE OUT THERE. I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM AND
SO WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND ITEM WHICH
IS OUR HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT AUGMENTATION. WHICH
AGAIN GOES BACK TO THE THING
HERE WE HAVE. I CAN ASSUME AND
SHARE MEMBERS- CHRISLEY'S
TATTOOS ARE TERM FOR THE SONY
PLANNING CONSTRUCTION AND
MANAGEMENT DIVISION. I SEE STARS
REQUESTING SIXTY SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
CONTINUING CONSTRUCTION OF
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM OR A FIFTY PROJECTS AT
ELEVEN INSTITUTIONS. CDCR HAS
COMPLETED ALL PROJECTS AND
FIFTEEN INSTITUTIONS EXPECTS TO
COMPLETE ANOTHER SEVEN TOTAL
INSTITUTIONS BY. THIRTY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
INSTITUTIONAL SEVERAL SUB
PROJECTS AND OVERALL A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ONE SEWER PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED. THIS REPRESENTS A
VAST IMPROVEMENT OF SPACE TO
DELIVER QUALITY MEDICAL CARE TO
BE INCARCERATED POPULATION AT
NEARLY EVERY INSTITUTION.
HOWEVER THERE IS STILL
SIGNIFICANT TIMELINE RISK FOR
COMPLETION OF THE REMAINING WORK
ALL OF WHICH IS RENOVATING
EXISTING SPACE THESE RISKS ARE
PRIMARILY TO ADDRESS REQUIRED
FIRE LIFE SAFETY CODE UPDATES IN
THE RENOVATED BUILDINGS. EACH
SITUATION REQUIRES DESIGN
FARMERS LOW PREVALENT THE DESIGN
AND MULTI CONSTRUCTION. EACH
STEP CARRIES RISK OF DELAY I
WHICH CAN COMPOUND ON EACH OTHER
AND EXTEND TIMELINES AND
INCREASED COSTS. CDCR IS
DRESSING LESSONS LEARNED IN THE
PROSECUTION OF THE HIT FOR
PROJECTS. NUMBER FOUR IS. THE
FIRST WE HAVE ESTABLISHED AND
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE ENHANCE
COMMUNICATION PROTOCOLS WITH
GENERAL CONTRACTORS AND PROJECT
STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP IDENTIFY
EXPEDITIOUSLY RESOLVE MERGING
ISSUES NEXT. WE CONTINUE TO
ACTIVELY COORDINATE WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL'S COMMUNICATE ISSUES
AND SOLVE PROBLEMS AS THEY ARISE
. WE ALSO- RECOGNIZING THAT THE
INMATE WORK LABOR PROGRAM IS
PERFORMING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF THE REMAINING WORK. I DON'T
WELL HAS ESTABLISHED WEEKLY
PROJECTS SCHEDULED MEETINGS TO
BRING ISSUES EARLIER TO THE CAMP
YET. I'M LESSONS LEARNED IN HICK
UP ALSO GUIDED IMPROVEMENTS BUT
PLANNING AND DESIGN THE FUTURE
PROJECTS. INSTRUCTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THE PROJECT SCOPE
COST AND SCHEDULE NOW INCLUDES
AN EVALUATION OF EXISTING
UTILITY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM. SEIZERT ALSO NOW
INCLUDES CONTRACT LANGUAGE WITH
ARCHITECTURAL ENGINEERING FIRMS
TO CLEARLY IDENTIFY THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR FIELD
VERIFICATION OF SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS
IDENTIFICATION OF UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES AND DESTRUCTIVE
TESTING TO THE EXTENT FEASIBLE
WITH AN OPERATING FACILITIES.
INCLUSION CDCR RECOGNIZES THE
SIGNIFICANT SHORTFALLS IN THE
PLANNING A TRIP PROJECTS
DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN STEPS TO
AMELIORATE THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS
OF THE POOR PLANNING. EXCEPT
REMAINS CRITICAL TO PROVIDE
SPACE FOR THE DELIVERY OF
QUALITY MEDICAL CARE TO THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE COMPLETION OF THE
HECK FOR PROJECTS AND PRITCHETT
SUBCOMMITTEES. THANK YOU.
ORLANDO AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE HECK FIP
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SUBJECT TO
SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASES FOR
EXAMPLE LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED SIXTY SEVEN
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOR COST INCREASES
AT THE TIME CDCR INDICATED THAT
HE EXPECTS. WOULD NOT NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE FUTURE
YEARS. IN TOTAL HIP FYBER HAS
INCREASED BY ABOUT 50% FROM
ABOUT ONE ONE BILLION TO ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION SOME OF THE
INCREASES ARE DUE TO FACTORS
THAT ARE NOT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT'S CONTROL SUCH AS
INFLATION IN THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. HOWEVER THE MAGNITUDE
AND FREQUENCY OF COST INCREASES
EXCEED WHAT IS TYPICALLY SEEN IN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS. I'M AND THEN
WE ALSO NOTE THAT OTHER CITIES
ARE PROJECTS HAVE EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASES AS
WELL TO THE EXTENT THAT
DEPARTMENTS PROJECT AND PLANNING
PRACTICES COULD BE CONTRIBUTING
TO THESE COSTS SIX. ESCALATIONS. THIS IS EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC
AND HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC
CONSIDERING THAT. CDCR PLANTS TO
PURSUE ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
AND FUTURE PROJECTS IN THE NEXT
TEN YEARS AS SUCH THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
PROVIDING GREATER OVERSIGHT OF
CDC OURS PROJECT PLANNING
MANAGEMENT TO ENSURE FUTURE COST
ESCALATIONS ARE MINIMIZED. THIS
COULD INCLUDE REQUESTING AN
AUDIT OF CTCS PROJECT PLANNING
AND MANAGEMENT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND IDENTIFY OPTIONS
TO CORRECT THE FACTORS LEADING
TO THESE COST INCREASES. THANK
YOU. FOR BUBBLES WHITE IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SUPPORTS
THE INCREASE OF SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND FOR THIS PROPOSAL. AND
THE DEPARTMENT WORK CLOSELY WITH
CDC ARE TO COME TO THIS FIGURE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT. THE COST
INCREASES OF THE PROGRAM IN THE
PAST AS WELL AS THE PROJECTS
WITHIN THE PROGRAM THAT REMAIN
ON STARTED- THE COST INCREASES
ARE UNFORTUNATE. BUT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE FACILITIES
IS NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH THE
PLOT A COURT ORDER AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL AS YOU ARE I'M SURE THAT
THIS ALLOCATION WILL PROVIDE
ENOUGH FUNDING. TO COMPLETE THE
PROGRAM. BUT FELT CAN- DOES HAVE
A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT LAST YEAR I WAS TOLD THAT
THE SIXTY SEVEN MILLION WITH
MAYBE ALL THEY WERE IN NEED AND
WE'RE ALMOST DONE AND WE'RE BACK
HERE TO DAY- ASKING FOR ANOTHER.
SIXTY SEVEN EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND I GUESS JUST LONG
TERM CONCERNS ABOUT. HOW WERE
COMING UP WITH THESE PROJECTIONS
AND HOWEVER MANAGING PROJECTS
SPECIALLY SENSE WE HAVE AFTER
THIS PART IS THAT WE HAVE MORE.
MORE UP MORE PROJECTS COMING ON
BOARD TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT. ONE
POINT EIGHT. BILLION DOLLARS AND
JUST TO DO THE MATH FOR YOU IF I
FOLLOW THE PATTERN OF FALLING OF
A 50% INCREASE THAT ONE POINT IN
IS GOING TO TURN TO TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
ALMOST AN EXTRA BILLION DOLLARS.
STATE THAT YOU ARE. THAT WE
COULD POSSIBLY BE UNDER
ESTIMATING AND SO WHAT KIND OF
SECURITY SO WHAT KIND OF
ASSURANCES THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
HAVE A BETTER SYSTEM NOW FOR
PROJECTIONS AND A BETTER SYSTEM
NOW FOR MANAGEMENT OF THESE
PROJECTS SO THAT WE'RE NOT
SHORT. ANOTHER BILLION DOLLARS
THAT THE NEXT SET OF PROJECTS WE
HAVE COMING ONLINE- THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION- AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE. THERE HAVE
BEEN LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
HICCUP- PROJECTS- PICKED UP WITH
AN EXTREMELY AMBITIOUS. ENDEAVOR
IN IMPROVING. THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES- ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS STATEWIDE
SIMULTANEOUSLY. IT STRAINED OUR
RESOURCES AND IN THE INCEPTION
OF THE PROGRAM THERE WERE. A
SHORT CUTS. TAKEN IN THE
PLANNING THAT TURNED OUT TO. NOT
BE SHORTCUTS- A- YOU KNOW SO AS
AS AS I MENTIONED EARLIER- WE
HAVE- TAKEN STEPS TO- IMPROVE
THE OUTGOING ADMINISTRATION OF
THE REMAINING. WORK AND WE HAVE
ALSO TAKEN STEPS TO IMPROVE THE
PLANNING OF PROJECTS GOING
FORWARD. BUT THIS IS WHAT YOU
TOLD US LAST YEAR AND THEN
YOU'RE BACK AGAIN THIS YEAR SO
CAN YOU BE MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT
WHAT THOSE LESSONS LEARNED ARE
AND HOW DO WE KNOW THAT WERE
DONE. LEARNING LESSONS WHEN THIS
HAS BEEN GOOD THIS I'VE ONLY
BEEN HERE FOR TWO YEARS BUT A
HECK THAT HAS BEEN ATTENDING A
PROJECT. CORRECT IT HAS BEEN
IT'S BEEN IN YOUR PROJECT. AND-
THE YOU KNOW WE UNDERESTIMATED
THE RISKS IN DOING AT THAT LEVEL
OF RENOVATION WORK THAT- WHAT'S
INCLUDED IN THAT PICTURE
PROGRAM- I CAN'T SIT HERE AND
PROMISE YOU THAT THERE WON'T BE
ANOTHER ASK I CAN SAY THAT WE
HAVE DONE OUR BEST TO- IDENTIFY
WHAT. WE THINK IS NECESSARY- AT
THIS POINT IN TIME TO A FINISHED
PROGRAM AT THAT SAID- THERE ARE
SEVERAL- PHASES OF WORK LEFT-
PRESENTS- OUR TIMELINE RISKS AND
TIMELINE WRISTS TRANSLATES TO
MONEY- SO WE'RE WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THIS WILL BE THE LAST TIME
WERE IN FRONT OF YOU ASKING FOR
MONEY- AND WE WILL DO OUR OUR
LEVEL BEST TO PROSECUTE PROGRAM
AS EFFICIENTLY. AS POSSIBLE- AND
THAT THAT'S THAT'S THE PROMISE
AT THAT BUT I CAN MAKE YOUR
REGARDING FUNDING FOR HECTOR. AS
FAR AS PROJECTS MOVING FORWARD-
IN IN FUTURE- AS I ALSO
MENTIONED EARLIER- WE HAVE-
ENHANCED ARE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
EARLY PLANNING FOR PROJECTS SO
THAT'S A MAJOR ISSUES THAT WERE
OVERLOOKED AND A HICCUP SUCH AS-
EVALUATION OF EXISTING UTILITY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS- AND-
FIELD VERIFICATION OF SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS.
IDENTIFICATION OF THE PRECISE
LOCATIONS OF UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES AND- DESTRUCTIVE
TESTING. AND RENOVATION
PROJECTS- IT IS OCCURRING AS
PROJECTS ARE BEING PLANNED SINCE
THIS ON. AND I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO BE CRITICAL OF BECAUSE I
DON'T LIKE MY QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN ANSWERED ON ON THIS I'M NOT
GONNA ASK YOU THE QUESTION
AGAIN- BUT IF WE CAN GET SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. IT'S
TROUBLING WHEN I AM TOLD THIS IS
THE LAST TIME WHEN I COME BACK
AND I'M JUST A LOWER TRYING OUR
BEST- IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T
FEEL. LIKE I'M DOING MY JOB THAN
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE BEING.
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE HERE. THE
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THATONE OUT ON THIS
ITEM. OKAY WELL- WE WON'T BE
HERE- AT AND SO- IT WILL BE
FRUSTRATING TO SEE AT. I HOPE I
HOPE I HOPE THAT WE ARE THE
LEARNING AND WE ARE DOING BETTER
BECAUSE THESE ARE REAL DOLLARS.
I OFTENTIMES INTO THE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE USED FOR
SO MANY OTHER NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OUT THERE- SOMEONE
FROM A WORKING CLASS COMMUNITY
THAT HAS A LOT OF NEEDS. WHETHER
IT'S ON SOCIAL SERVICES THE
REMEDIATION OF TOXICS COULD THIS
MONEY GOOGLE. A LONG WAY OUT
THERE SO IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING
TO SEE THESE OCCURRENCES UP
THERE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ITEM FOR THIS
DEPARTMENT WHICH IS DATA
COLLECTION. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
HERE MEMBERS OF- MADELINE THE
CLEANED UP THE RECTOR CTR. THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU FOR DATA
COLLECTION AND EVALUATION-
PROVIDE SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
ENHANCE THE DEPARTMENT'S DATA
COLLECTION AND EVALUATION
CAPABILITIES. BY ALLOWING TO USE
YOUR TO EXPLORE OPTIONS THAT
LEVERAGE EXISTING DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS EFFORTS.
THAT MAY ASSIST THE DEPARTMENT
IN DETERMINING EFFICACY OF
VARIOUS REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
AND POST INCARCERATION
STATISTICS. ORLANDO CENTERS WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WHILE IMPROVING CITIES OUR DATA
COLLECTION AND EVALUATION
CAPABILITIES COULD HAVE MERIT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
PROVIDED A CLEAR DESCRIPTION OF
HOW I WOULD USE THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES. FOR EXAMPLE IT IS NOT
CLEAR WHAT TYPES OF DATA WOULD
BE COLLECTED OF WHICH- OR WHICH
PROGRAMS WOULD BE EVALUATED TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDING IS USED IN A
MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE. PRIORITIES THEY
MAY WISH TO ASK CDCR TO PROVIDE
A DESCRIPTION OF THE SPECIFIC
DATA COLLECTION AND EVALUATION
ACTIVITIES. FOR WHICH THE
FUNDING WOULD BE USED. OKAY
THANK YOU- COLLEAGUES. OF YES
CAN YOU TELL US HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO BE EVALUATING PEARL PROGRAMS
AND THE AND THE PARTS AS WELL.
AND THAT IS ONE COMPONENT THAT
WOULD BE LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF
DATA AGAIN THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU IS TO ALLOW US TO LEVERAGE
AND BUILD UPON EXISTING DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING EFFORTS
THAT WE HAVE. THE DEPARTMENT
DOES HAVE A VARIOUS DASHBOARDS-
AN OFFENDER DATA POINTS AND SO
THE IDEA IS THAT WE WILL- LOOK
AT SOME OF THAT INFORMATION THAT
WE ALREADY COLLECT AND FIGURE
OUT- USING BEST PRACTICES. I GET
THE MOST BANG FOR A BUCK SO THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT THINGS- DATA
ELEMENTS THAT CAN. BOLSTER
PROFESSED FUTURE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS I THOUGHT WE ALSO
OFTEN BEEN TOLD THAT WE DON'T
PROVIDE A RETURN ON INVESTMENT-
INFORMATION WE DO REQUEST
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND SO
I. THIS FUNDING WILL BE USED TO
KIND OF EXPLORE OPTIONS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN USE- EITHER
CONTRACTING WITH AN OUTSIDE
ENTITY ANOTHER DATA SOURCE
COLLECTION. TO GATHER AND AGAIN
ANALYZE SOME OF THE DATA THAT WE
DON'T LREADY COLLECT AND FIGURE
OUT AREAS WHERE WE DON'T COLLECT
DATA INPUT PERHAPS INCORPORATE
THAT AS WELL. IT'S LIKE IDEALLY
FOR DECISION MAKERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS- TO MAKE BETTER
DECISION POINTS. CALIFORNIA ADAM
FOR. I'M GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR
FIFTY. DEPARTMENT THE OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND I HAVE. TO TWO PROPOSALS IN THIS- AND
SO AGAIN IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STOP IN BETWEEN TO HEAR FROM THE
ALLEY OWN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT COMPLAIN
OMICS AUGMENTATION. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM MARIE I
THINK THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. WE
HAD INITIALLY REQUESTED RESOURCE
SAYS TO FIND OF TWENTY FOUR
POSITIONS TO MONITOR CDC OURS
NEWSPATH COMPLAINT PROCESS AS
PART OF THE- GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
HOWEVER WE HAVE RECEIVED HELPFUL
AND BUT AND AFTER REVIEWING CDCR
SPLAT. WE HAVE MODIFIED THE
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN THE FOLLOWING THREE
CRITICAL AREAS. FIRST WE'RE
REQUESTING RESOURCES TO MONITOR
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS RECEIVED
BY ALL POTENTIAL SOURCES- BY CDC
ARE CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
THIS WOULD INCLUDE NOT JUST THE
SIX OF TWO ONES BUT ALSO THE SIX
INTO HEALTHCARE THE FOURTEENTH
TWENTY FOUR AND ANY THIRD PARTY
COMPLAINT. SECOND WE
RESTRUCTURED THE MONITORING OF
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INVESTIGATIONS TO INCLUDE
ATTORNEY. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE HAD ASKED FOR DEPUTY
INSPECTORS GENERAL FOR THIS TASK
HOWEVER IT SINCE CDCR SPLINT IS
TO USE VERTICAL ADVOCATE IN
THESE INVESTIGATIONS WHICH ARE
DEPARTMENT ATTORNEYS WE ARE
TRUSTING ATTORNEY RESOURCES TO
MONITOR IT THE INVESTIGATORS
FROM THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS. AND ALSO THE DEPARTMENT
ATTORNEYS. FINALLY ADDED TO
REQUEST TO MONITOR THE LOCAL
ENQUIRIES THOSE GRIEVANCES THAT
ARE RETURNED TO THE LOCAL
PRESENT FOR A SUPERVISORY
INQUIRY WE'RE REQUESTING
RESOURCES TO MONITOR
APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THOSE
INQUIRIES. AT THIS TIME WE
BELIEVE OUR REQUEST FOR THESE
ONGOING POSITION IS SUFFICIENT
TO ESTABLISH THE FOUNDATION TO
BEGIN CONTEMPORANEA OVERSIGHT OF
THE INCARCERATED PERSON
GRIEVANCE PROCESS. TO IDENTIFY
WEAKNESSES IN THE PROCESS AND
MAKE MEANINGFUL RECOMMENDATIONS
TO CDC ARE. OUR GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY INTO
WHETHER OR NOT THE DEPARTMENT IS
CONDUCTING THOROUGH COMPLETE AND
UNBIASED INVESTIGATIONS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ASSESS OUR
MONITORING PROCESS IF ALL THAT
PROCESS IS NECESSARY AND MAKE
REQUESTS TO GROW AS MORE
INTENSE. THANK YOU I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. WE DON'T RAISE CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL BUT I AM
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. A REAL
QUICK ARM. RIGHT I DO AGREE YOU
DO NEED ADDITIONAL BODIES AND
THEIR RESOURCES ARM. DOES THIS
GRANT THE- I. D. ANY- ADDITIONAL
INVESTIGATION POWERS OF BECAUSE
THAT COULD BE A PROBLEM TO WHERE
YOU DON'T HAVE OF THE AUTHORITY.
TO GO WHERE YOU NEED TO GO WHERE
NO MAN HAS GONE BEFORE BUT TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM. DO YOU NEED. DO YOU
NEED SOME OTHER AUTHORITY YOU
KNOW YOU THAT THE BODIES. IT AT
THIS TIME THIS. BOB THIS DOES
NOT GRANT AS INVESTIGATIVE
AUTHORITY HOWEVER THE STATUTE IS
VERY BROAD THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS WIDE
LATITUDE WHEN WE GO INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS WE ARE
PRIVY TO ANY BOOKS PAPERS
DOCUMENTS I'M PRETTY MUCH EVERY
INCH OF AN INSTITUTION IS. OPEN
TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OFFICE WE HAVE A HOUSE- SEVERAL
OF OUR REPORTS IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS SO WE ARE ABLE TO
GET IN THERE AND WE ARE ABLE TO
ASK FOR- THOSE THINGS AND WE CAN
GO INTO THE PLACES WHERE ANY MAN
OR WOMAN HASN'T GONE AND BE ABLE
TO GET IN THERE AND ACTUALLY.
LOOK AT WHAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT.
TO BE INTO IT YOU CAN'T
INVESTIGATE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE DIFFERENCE IS. GO IN AND
LOOK AT SOMETHING AND THEN YOU
WALK AWAY BUT YOU CAN'T
PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATE. THAT IS
NOT THE ROLE OF AN OVERSIGHT
AGENCY NO WE CANNOT INVESTIGATE
OR PROSECUTE WE CAN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE CAN WRITE
PUBLIC REPORTS WE CAN COME BACK
TO THIS BODY AND MAKE
PRESERVATION RANKING TO MAKE
WRITTEN RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MANAGEMENT THE CDC ARE. YES. THE
DO YOU SEE THE INHERENT PROBLEM
WITH THE. I FULLY UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERNS I'VE WORKED AT
THE- I. G. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN AND I ALSO WORKED AT
CDC ARE FOR SHORT BIT- SO I
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERNS AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT IN IN THE PAST
THERE HAVE BEEN. OCCASIONS IN
PRIOR ADMINISTRATIONS WHERE
THERE WASN'T ACTIVITIES THE
RELATIONSHIP AND THERE WAS SOME-
AREAS WHERE PERHAPS- THE
COMMUNICATION LINE WASN'T GOD-
BUT I BELIEVE AT THIS TIME I DO
HAVE A POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH CDCR- I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO MONITORING
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS THAT
THEY JUST LAUNCHED. AND IF THE
IF IT'S NECESSARY TO COME BACK
AND ASK FOR THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE THESE ADDITIONAL-
INVESTIGATIVE POWERS THEN THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I WOULD BE
WILLING TO DO. I AM JUST
CONCERNED THAT YOU MAY NEED IT
NOW WHO- EVEN THOUGH YOU GET ALL
THE BODIES. ARE YOU DOING THE
STACKING UP REPORT SO HOPEFULLY
. WE CAN MOVE A LOT MORE
AGGRESSIVELY ON- INFRACTIONS.
THE. TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONCERNS I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN MOVE MORE AGGRESSIVELY- I AM
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT THE THAT
CDCR WILL BE RECEPTIVE TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR REAL TIME
MONITORING- IN THIS INCARCERATED
PERSONS GRIEVANCE PROCESS. OKAY
THANK YOU ARE A VENDOR FOUND
THAT. YOU USED TO HAVE- THE
ABILITY TO INVESTIGATE AND THAT
WAS TAKEN AWAY I AND I DO HOPE
THAT IF AT SOME POINT YOU FEEL
THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
THIRTY TO COME BACK THAT YOU
DIDN'T REACH OUT TO A FULL WEEK
OF WORK. ON ON THE SIDE OF- I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON ON
THIS ITEM AND SO I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO THEIR
SECOND ITEM WHICH IS THE MEDICAL
INSPECTION STUFF. I'M GOING TO
GET EVERYTHING INSPECTOR
GENERAL. INITIALLY WE HAD
REQUESTED RESOURCES TO FIND
EIGHTEEN POSITIONS TO ACCELERATE
OUR MEDICAL INSPECTIONS OF CDCR
INSTITUTIONS. THEY ARE INITIAL
REQUEST FOR- IS OLDER THAN
FIFTEEN POSITIONS OF A PERMANENT
POSITIONS WITH LIMITED FUNDING
HOWEVER AGAIN AFTER HELPFUL
INPUT AND RESEARCH WE HAVE
MODIFIED OUR REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES SO THAT THE POSITIONS
WILL BE PERMANENT AND THE
FUNDING WILL BE ONGOING. BOB SO
THANK YOU AND I'M I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. ORLANDO
WITH THE L. A- WE DO NOT RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND
CAN RESPOND TO QUESTIONS AS
NEEDED. OKAY THANK YOU I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM.
EITHER BUT I DO WANT TO THANK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR. CARRYING OUR
FEEDBACK FROM OUR FIRST HEARING
IN WORKING WITH US ON THESE TWO
PROPOSALS AND MAKING ADJUSTMENTS
ACCORDINGLY. TO ENSURE WE HAVE
IMPROVED OVERSIGHT AND
EFFICIENCY AND MEDICAL
INSPECTIONS MOVING FORWARD. SO I
WILL MOVE ON TO THE SIXTH
DEPARTMENT ARGUE JUDICIAL BRANCH. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS THERE ARE
OUR FIRST ONE IS THE OVER
ARCHING COMMENTS ON THE COST
INCREASES FOR COURT
CONSTRUCTION. IN COURT PROJECTS
FOR JUDGESHIPS OVERVIEW. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
PAUL MCCORMICK DIRECTOR OF
FACILITIES FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. NAY REVISIONS THE CLOSE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO SEVERAL
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FACILITY
PROGRAM PROPOSALS AND REQUESTS
FUNDING TO PROVIDE FACILITIES
FOR TWENTY THREE JUDGESHIPS.
BROADLY IT TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
PROPOSALS INCLUDE COST
ASSESSMENTS TO LINE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE BUDGETS THE CURRENT MARKET
CONDITIONS BASED ON DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES PUBLISHED
CALIFORNIA. INSTRUCTION COSTS
INDEX THE THOUGHT. THE CCI IS A
MAJOR CROSS TRANSFER
CONSTRUCTION TRADE LABOR AND
MATERIALS IN CALIFORNIA. THE CCC
I INCREASED THIRTEEN POINT 4% OF
A CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HAS INCREASED AN ADDITIONAL
NINE POINT 23% BETWEEN JANUARY
AND APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
DUE TO THE SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE INDEX THE PREVIOUS COST
ESTIMATES ARE UNDERSTATED THE
REQUESTED TWENTY FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE I
JUST CONSTRUCTION PHASE BUDGETS
FOR SEVEN PROJECTS STATE
CHESSMEN FIRST SOLELY DUE TO
ECONOMIC PRESSURES WITHIN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. THE
PROJECT SCOPE HAVE NOT CHANGED
ALSO REQUESTED- TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS TO LIQUIDATE INTRUM
DEBT SERVICE ON TO CAPITAL
PROJECTS THAT WILL PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE AVOIDANCE OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS. REAPPROPRIATION
A CONTINUING BASIS FOR THREE
CAPITAL PROJECTS WHICH HAVE
SLOWED TO TWO EXTENDED REVIEW
PERIODS ARE ALSO REQUESTED. I
COM OF CAPITAL AND FACILITY
ADDRESS COURT FACILITY NEEDS FOR
TWENTY THREE JUDGESHIPS BASED ON
THE SPECIFIC FACILITY CONDITION
ITS SPACE AVAILABILITY PROJECTS
INCLUDE. BUILDING OUT PREVIOUSLY
SHELVED CONSTRUCTION SPACE
UPGRADING EXISTING COURTROOMS.
RECONFIGURING SAYS WORKSPACE OR
LEASING SPACE. AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
OR TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS-
TURNING OVER TO FILL OUT FORMS
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. A
HIGH- BUT CHURCH MEMBERS THIS IS
THE LOS FOUR WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IF THE FURTHER
EXPOUND UPON AND- CCCI PROPOSALS
RECALL AND IT IT'S A STATE WIDE
PROPOSAL THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
JUST FOR COURT WE HAVE TEN
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE RECEIVING
THE CCCI. OF YOU KNOW INCREASES
AND- IT'S QUITE A BIT OF- JUDGE
WITHIN THOSE TEN PART. AND JUST
AS STAFF TO BOTH THE BOARD TO
THE STATE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
OVERALL. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAM IS ONE OF
OUR BETTER MANAGE PROGRAMS AND
IT IN EVERY CASE- WHERE THESE
CCCI INCREASES ARE. AREBEING
REQUESTED THEY'RE ALL HELLO WHAT
WE'RE CALLING A BENCHMARKING IS
THE IS THE 10% IT WOULD YOU KNOW
THIS YEAR AND- TWENTY FIVE CENTS
LAST YEAR SO IN EVERY CASE.
THEY'RE ASKING FOR. LESS THAN
WHAT WE'RE KIND OF SEEING ON
AVERAGE SO WE JUST WANTED TO.
THE LEAD AFTER IT AT. THE ON THE
SECOND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE ON ANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. I NEED ONLY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS BUT
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. OKAY I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM
COLLEAGUES. OKAY THANK YOU THAN
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND ITEM HERE
CARE COURT. MMHM. HEY I'M MARK
MEADOWS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE NEIGHBOR VISION INCLUDES
THIRTY NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND THIRTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION ONGOING FOR THE DID
JUDICIAL BRANCH TO IMPLEMENT THE
CARE ACT- INCLUDING RESOURCES TO
CONDUCT CARE COURT HEARINGS AND
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR SELF HELP
CENTERS CARE COURT IS THE NEW
COURT PROCESS TO DELIVER
COMMUNITY BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TO
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
UNTREATED SCHIZOPHRENIA SPECTRUM
OR OTHER PSYCHOTIC DISORDERS.
THE COSTS IDENTIFIED IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS PRIMARILY BASED ON
THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
OUTLINED IN- SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH ESTABLISHED THE CARE
COURT PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW THE
CARE ACT IMPLEMENTATION SPANS
VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES MAINLY
THE HEALTH. HUMAN SERVICES AND
THIS PROPOSAL IS ARE REALLY JUST
SPECIFIC TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE RESOURCES FOR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND WE CAN
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF ON ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THE
TECHNICAL TEAM UP BY THE
TECHNICAL DETAIL OUT PROGRAM OUR
TECHNICAL PROGRAM DETAILS OF THE
CARE PROGRAM- I'M- HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. I NEARLY
WITH THE L. A. L. SO FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF BRIEF CON TAXED ON
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
INCLUDES A TOTAL OF THREE
PROPOSAL THAT TOTAL- ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS ONE
OF THEM- THERE IS ALSO A FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AS WELL AS TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING FOR THAT
CARE COURT SUPPORTER PROGRAM-
WHICH COMPLEMENTS THIS PROPOSAL-
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT IS
CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH THE
POLICY PROCESS AND MAY CONTINUE
TO CHANGE. AND SO THIS MEANS
THAT THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
NEEDED AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
SPECIFIC PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES THAT ARE INCLUDED. IN
THE FINAL LEGISLATION- WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT IT IS STILL WORKING WITH
COUNTIES TO IDENTIFY COSTS AND
IT COULD BE POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT. SO WITHOUT FULLY
IDENTIFYING THE STATE AND LOCAL
COST IT'SREALLY DIFFICULT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO WAIVE THIS
PROPOSAL AGAINST ALL OF ITS
OTHER GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES.
AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT WE DO
THINK IT IS PREMATURE TO
CONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S MAIN
PROVISION BUDGET PROPOSALS IN
THIS AREA AT THIS TIME. WE DO
RAISE THAT THE QUESTION ABOUT-
YOU KNOW KEY DECISIONS AND
SPECIFIC PROPHECIES- WE DID WANT
TO OFFER SOME EXAMPLES- IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY CAN IMPACT THE LEVEL
OF RESOURCES AND WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE NEEDED. AND THEY REALLY
FALL INTO KIND OF FIVE KEY
CATEGORIES ON THESE EXAMPLES.
THE FIRST IS INTERACTIONS WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS. SO HOW DO
EXISTING STATE AND LOCAL PROGRAM
PROPHECIES AND CAPACITY INTERACT
WITH CARE COURT. SO FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN THE MISDEMEANOR ICE TEAS
COME OVER DOES THAT MEAN THAT
THEY NEED TO BE. RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY DO THE CARE COURT
PARTICIPANTS- IN TERMS OF THEIR
NEEDS- MIMIC THOSE THAT ARE
SERVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING'S SUPPORTERS- YOU KNOW HOW
HOW LINES ARE THOSE. THE SECOND
BUCKET IS WHICH INDIVIDUALS ARE
BEST SERVED BY A CARE COURT
THROUGH A JUDICIAL PROCESS-
THERE HAVE BEEN INVESTMENTS-
RECENTLY APPROVED OR PROPOSED IN
THE BUDGET FOR EXAMPLE NEW
SERVICES TARGETED AT
INDIVIDUALS. WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THROUGH CAL AIMS.
AND SO AS PART OF THAT IT'S ALSO
HEALTHCARE COURT KIND OF
EFFECTIVELY. NAVIGATE AND
COORDINATE THOSE SERVICES. THE
THIRD BUCKET IS WHERE WE HAVE
QUESTIONS- IS SORT OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES SO DOES THE STATE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
APPROPRIATE AND SUFFICIENT
HOUSING TREATMENT AND OTHER
SERVICES. SO FOR EXAMPLE IT'S
UNCLEAR IF THE STATE FUNDING FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HOUSING WILL
ACTUALLY MEET. RECORD AND IF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE TO
IDENTIFY THEM AND WHAT STEPS
NEED TO OCCUR FOR EXAMPLE
CONTRACTING OR TRAINING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE FULLY
AVAILABLE. THE FOURTH BUCKET IS
THE INFORMATION THAT'S REQUIRED
IN JUDICIAL PROCEEDINGS SO WHAT
TYPE OF INFORMATION AND PROOF
WILL BE NEEDED FOR A JUDICIAL
PROCEEDINGS TO ESTABLISH
ELIGIBILITY- MODIFYING OR
REJECTING TREATMENT PLANS OR
ALSO DETERMINING WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS ARE COMPLIANT OR
NONCOMPLIANT. AND IN THE FINAL
BUCKET OF KIND OF QUESTIONS AS
DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY WHAT
ARE THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE CARE
COURT PARTICIPANTS AS WELL AS
THE STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING SUPPORTERS.
AND LEGAL COUNSEL THAT-
REPRESENTING INDIVIDUALS COUNTY
GUARDIANS CONSERVATORS ETCETERA
IN THE DECISION MAKING AND
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROCESS.
MOST OF THOSE- ARE JUST TO SOME
KEY AREAS THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOUR ATTENTION AS
YOU CONSIDER THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR STYLE. THANK
YOU I'M QUITE OF OUR OWN
FINANCES HERE BECAUSE I'M NOT
SURE THE COURTS REALLY CAN
ANSWER A LOT OF THESE QUESTIONS
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT DO YOU EXPECT THAT SEEN
WIDE RANGES OF NUMBERS AND I'M
NOT SURE ANYBODY REALLY HAS
THEIR HANDS ON. SURE OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND- THE WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS BASED ON IT IS
SEVEN THOUSAND. TO TWELVE
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS- WHO WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR PARTICIPATION IN
THE CARE PROGRAM. IN ANY OF
THESE AUDITS FOCUS. ANY OF THESE
FOLKS ARE COMING INTO THE COURTS
WHERE. WHERE WHERE THE COURT'S
GOING TO BE EXPECTED TO SEND
THEM- IT LOOKS BOB SO ALL. PART
OF THE RIVER PART OF THE REQUEST
BILLS AND RESOURCES FOR SELF
HELP CENTERS RIGHT AND SO- AS AS
PART OF THE PROGRAM AND YOU WANT
ON CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS CAN BE
REFERRED TO THE PROGRAM SO- THE
EIGHT YEAR. THE YOU WE WOULD BE
PROVIDING SOME RESOURCES IN THAT
IN EACH COUNTY TO ALLOW FOR-
SELF HELP HELP CENTERS TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE ARE CONSIDERING CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS OR FAMILY MEMBERS
ARE FOR PARTICIPATION IN THE
CARE PROGRAM SO THAT THAT I HAD
A RESOURCES CERTAINLY BUILT INTO
THE REQUEST OKAY EXPLAIN SELF
HELP CENTERS GIVEN. THE
POPULATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOW DOES THAT WORK- AND- MAYBE-
I CAN HAVE AYE SOMEONE FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL SPEAK TO THAT
SELF HELP CENTERS ARE YOU VERY-FAMILIAR WITH SELF HELP CENTERS
BUT SELF HELP CENTERS. ARE
PREDICATED ON ON PEOPLE
REPRESENTING THEMSELVES AND
BEING ABLE TO AND AS I
UNDERSTAND. THIS SYSTEM THIS IS
GOING TO BE VERY HEAVILY RELIANT
ON. PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO GET.
COUNCIL AND HELP SHEPHERD THEM
THROUGH THIS THE THESE ARE FOLKS
WHO ARE HEADED TOWARDS
POTENTIALLY. BEING CONSERVED AND
OTHER CHALLENGES I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND A SELF HELP CENTER IN
THIS CONTEXT. HELLO MY NAME IS
FRANCINE BROWN I'M THE PRINCIPAL
MANAGER AT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND I THINK I CAN SPEAK TO A
LITTLE OF THAT I WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THOUGH BECAUSE- THINGS
ARE STILL BEING WORKED OUT WITH
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT SOME OF
THESE PROCESSES HAVE NOT BEEN
COMPLETELY IDENTIFIED. THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT ARE THE SELF HELP
CENTERS WILL BE UTILIZED SINCE
THERE IS AN ABILITY FOR MORE
PEOPLE TO PETITION AB WORK FOR A
PERSON TO BE A PART OF THIS I
CAN'T QUITE MODEL THEN THERE IS-
IN ORDER TO TRADITIONS THAT
WE'RE USED TO IT'S VERY UNUSUAL
I WOULD THINK THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME GOOD AMOUNT OF FAMILY
MEMBERS OR- OTHERS. WHO WOULD
SEEK THE RESOURCES PRIMECAP
CENTERS AND NEED SOME GUIDANCE
SO WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE
FORTY- THE PERSON WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN THE CARE COURT IT
WOULD BE FOR FAMILY MEMBERS OR
OTHERS. WHO ARE INTERESTED
INITIATING THE PROCESS. OKAY SO
YOU'RE TO BE PRO. SELF HELP
CENTER WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
PROVIDING SOME LEGAL ADVICE THAN
. AT AND THE PARTICIPATING THE
PERSON TO WHOM THIS IS GOING TO
BE HAPPENING THERE MAY NOT BE
REPRESENTED OR HOW DO WE- ENSURE
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL IS.
ADEQUATELY BEING. CARED FOR. IT
WILL BE REPRESENTED THIS WILL BE
A SEPARATE PROCESSES TO BE
SORTED BEFORE THEY ENTER INTO
THAT INTO THAT MODEL SO BUT THEY
WILL AND I WILL DEFER TO MARKHAM
AND SO IS JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAN
GOING TO DEVELOP OR BE ABLE TO
IN THE SELF HELP CENTERS DEVELOP
THE EXPERTISE TO UNDERSTAND WITH
WHOM. THEY ARE. DISCUSSING SO A
FAMILY MEMBER OTHER WHO IS.IS
NOW. BRINGING INDIVIDUAL OR
CLAIMING THAT SOME INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS HELP HOW ARE YOU GOING TO.
KNOW WHETHER THAT INDIVIDUAL. IS
EVEN APPROPRIATE FOR THESE
SERVICES THAT MAYBE THIS IS JUST
A FAMILY MEMBER LOOKING TO. SHED
RESPONSIBILITY I'VE I'M NOT SURE
THAT'S NOT HOW SELF HELP CENTERS
WORK. WHAT WHAT LEVEL OF
COUNSELING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WHAT LEVEL OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ARE GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE TO THE SELF HELP
CENTERS THAT. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT WOULD
LIKELY BE AB JUST PROVIDING
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION I
THINK AND AGAIN THIS HASN'T WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE A LOT OF
MODELS TEND TO WORK OFF THAT
LOOK AT SOME OTHER OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT SIMILAR MODELS AND
THINGS GOING ON IN OTHER STATES
BUT THERE'S NOTHING PRECISELY
LIKE THIS BUT WE BELIEVE THAT-
WHAT A SELF HELP CENTERS RENTAL
COULD BE IS PROVIDING RESOURCES
TEMPORARY REFERRALS POSSIBLY I'M
JUST MAKING THIS. UP WOULD BE
HONEST. RESEARCH WHERE. TWO
OTHER SOURCE AND DEPENDING ON
WHAT THE PERSON'S NEEDS WOULD BE
SO WHAT WHAT ABOUT TRAINING FOR
THE PEOPLE ACT THE SELF HELP
CENTERS TO UNDERSTAND- SORT OF
WHERE THEY COULD POTENTIALLY
THE SELF HELP CENTERS THAT
TYPICALLY ARE DEALING WITH
FAMILY LAW AND SORT OF MINOR
LEGAL ISSUES AND OTHERS ARE NOW
GOING TO BE TAKING ON. THIS
BREATH. AND SPECULATE ON THAT-
COMPLETELY BEFORE THE DETAILS
ARE WORKED OUT BUT THAT IS ONE
AREA THAT WE THINK SELF HELP
CENTERS IS ONE AREA THAT WE
THINK WE CAN PROVIDE INFORMATION
. AGAIN THE DETAILS ARE NOT.
ENTIRELY WORK OUT YEAH THIS IS
MEAN HEY YEAH. AND THESE ARE
FOLKS COMING IN WHO MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE THE BEST INTERESTS OF
THE- SUBJECT. OF THE- PROCEDURES
IN MINES AND HOW HOW IS THAT
GOING TO WORK IS THIS REALLY THE
EXPERTISE THAT JUDICIAL COUNCIL
IS GOING TO HAVE AND BE ABLE TO
FOSTER AND SELF HELP CENTERS.
THEY CERTAINLY THINK IT'S A
RESOURCE AND I THINK IN IN THE
SPIRIT OF YOU KNOW- AND
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM AND
ALLOWING THERE TO BE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC IS ABLE TO WORK FOR I'M
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM I THINK THAT'S- YOU
KNOW THE REALLY THE INTENTION
OF. OF THESE RESOURCES BECAUSE
YOU KNOW CERTAIN THE ABSENT
THESE RESOURCES MAY BE-
DIFFICULT FOR AN INDIVIDUAL TO
NAVIGATE THE PROCESS IN ORDER TO
WORK FOR AN INDIVIDUAL INTO THE
PROGRAM- I'M AT. RIGHT AND MAYBE
REFER IT TO- TO ADJUSTER
QUESTION ABOUT- YOU KNOW- IT
SUPPORTS FOR THE ACTUAL
PARTICIPANT- PART OF THE CARE
PROGRAM- DOES REQUIRE YOUR THE
COURTS TO APPOINT- THE TWO POINT
LEGAL COUNSEL TO THE PARTICIPANT
AS WELL AS A SUPPORTER. ARMED
FOR THE PARTICIPANTS TO ASSIST
THEM IN DECISIONS AND MAKING- BE
APPROPRIATE DECISIONS AND
PARTICIPATING THROUGH THE
PROGRAM SO THAT. THAT DOES
SUPPORTS ARE ALSO BUILT INTO THE
BUDGET AS WELL AS THE- THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CARE PROGRAM BUT AT BUT- AT I
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT THEY
ACTUALLY THOSE THOSE SUPPORTS
ARE ARE ACTUALLY BUILT IN. HI I
HAVE EVEN MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT.
SELF HELP CENTERS IN THAT
CONTEXT BECAUSE IF THEY-
PARTICIPANTS IS REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL AND GETTING OTHER HELP
THEY DON'T NEED THE SELF HELP
CENTER. SO THE SELF HELP CENTER
IS JUST THERE FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OR FAMILY MEMBERS TO COME
COMPLAIN ABOUT AND- ASK THE
COURTS TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL. HOW IS THAT.
HOW'S THAT PROCESS GOING TO BE
THAT IT HOW HOW IS ANYBODY GOING
TO. KNOW WHAT'S IN AT THAT POINT
WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF.
THE INDIVIDUAL I. I'M JUST
ASTONISHED AND RESETTING UP A
PLACE A WHOLE SYSTEM WHERE
SOMEBODY CAN JUST GO COMPLAIN
ABOUT SOMEONE WHO'S INCONVENIENT
AND PUT ALL THIS STUFF IN IN
MOTION AND IS THIS JUDICIAL
COUNCIL REALLY WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO SET UP HERE. AND MAYBE
JUST SO- AGAIN THAT THE SELF
HELP FIVE COMPONENT OF THE
REQUEST IS TO WELL AS YOU HAD
EXPLAINED TO ASSIST THE PUBLIC
IN- PROVIDING RESOURCES TO THE
PUBLIC. ON TO. REGISTER AN
INDIVIDUAL OR A FAMILY MEMBER ON
TO BE A PART OF THE PROGRAM AND
THERE IS- UP PROCESS IN THE CARE
PROGRAM WHERE THE COURTS WOULD
HAVE TO. DETERMINE WHETHER
SOMEONE IS EVEN IT IT WHETHER
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE TO EVEN
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM SO IT
WOULDN'T ASSIST YOU WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE- FOISTED INTO THE
PROGRAM UNLESS- YOU ACTUALLY
MEET CERTAIN. CRITERIA AS
ESTABLISHED IN STATUTE I'M
SUPPORT FOR YOU TO ACTUALLY BE A
PART OF THE CARE PROGRAM. HEY I
WHICH WHICH IS WHY I DON'T I
THINK YOU REALLY CONFUSING. WHAT
SELF HELP CENTER IS. AND HOW
THAT WORKS OUT I HAVE MUCH MORE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES WITH HOW THIS
IS ROLLING OUT AND THERE WAS A
COMMENT MADE EARLIER THAT. THE
UNDERLYING POLICY BILL MIGHT
CHANGE IT WILL CHANGE THEIR IT'S
IN THE PROCESS OF BEING CHANGED
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE A LOT OF
SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS AROUND
PRESUMPTIONS THAT ARE CREATED
THAT ARE NOT HEALTHY. OR
APPROPRIATE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
CONSERVE TO THE QUESTION ABOUT
HOUSING AND RESOURCES THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHERE ANYBODY IS
GOING TO BE REFERRED TO AND I'M
JUST SURPRISED THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IS. TAKING THIS FAIRLY
LIGHTLY BECAUSE IN ALL OF THIS
PROCESS I DON'T KNOW WHERE ANY
COURT IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
REFER. AN INDIVIDUAL TO SERVICES
THOSE SERVICES ARE DON'T MISS
EITHER DON'T EXISTING COUNTIES
ARE SEVERELY. OVER TAXED AND
THERE'S A WHOLE NEW LEVEL OF
SUPPORT AN EXPECTATION THAT'S
BEING CREATED. COMING OUT OF
THIS PROPOSAL THAT I JUST DON'T
SEE HOW IT ACTUALLY GETS
IMPLEMENTED AND THE END FOR THE
COURTS TO BE WILLING TO TAKE
THIS ON MAYBE THEY'RE HAPPY IT.
THE NOTION OF RECEIVING THIS
ADDITIONAL MONEY. BUT IT CAN'T
BE SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE POTENTIAL
OUTCOMES ARE THE RESULTS WHERE
FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE. REFERRED
AND WHAT COUNTIES ARE OR NOT
ULTIMATELY GING TO BE ABLE TO
DO WITH THESE FOLKS AND- IF WHAT
THIS IS ENDING UP BEING IS JUST
A WAY OF CORRALLING. AND
DETAINING FOLKS WHO ARE
INCONVENIENT WHICH IS WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE BEN. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND AT ALL WHERE THIS
PROPOSAL IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO
BE. HELPFUL AND THE PEOPLE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND WHO ARE
BEING THE SUBJECT OF ALL THESE
HAVE RIGHTSAND INTO JUST ROLL
OVER THAT FOR THE CONVENIENCE OF
OTHERS WHO WANT TO COME IN AND
REPORT THAT MORE. WORK CREATE
OTHER AT ANOTHER SITUATION KIND
OF FORCE THEM OFF IS. I DON'T
THINK GOING TO BE VERY HELPFUL
HERE. AND THE FACT THAT WE I'M
NOT SURE THAT WE'VE ADEQUATELY
IDENTIFIED INDIVIDUALS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WHAT THE SERVICES.
EXPECTATIONS ARE GOING TO BE.
WHAT THE HOUSING OBLIGATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE WHAT ALL OF THIS
FRAMEWORK REALLY ENDS UP. THE
ONLY PLACE RIGHT NOW WHERE A LOT
OF THESE FOLKS END UP IS. JAIL
AND IF WE DON'T CREATE AN
APPROPRIATE. BACKSTOP
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR FOLKS TO
GO THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
END UP. AND THAT THAT'S
EXPENSIVE AND IT'S DEBILITATING
AND IT IS NOT AT ALL HELPFUL TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS OR FAMILIES IF
THERE ARE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
ARE. TRYING TO TRYING TO HELP
THAT SUCH THOSE FOLKS OUTSIDE I
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT ONLY A
PIECE OF IT. BUT I ACTUALLY
SURPRISED IN THIS THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S NOT PUSHING BACK QUITE
A BIT BECAUSE I DON'T SEE HOW
UNDER THE EXISTING PROPOSAL.
THERE'S ANY HOPE THAT THEY'RE
THAT THEY'RE PART OF THIS
PROCESS IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. WITHOUT SEEING
EVERYTHING ELSE SO I TEND TO
AGREE WITH. LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HERE THAT THAT
WE THROW NUMBERS AROUND. AND
POTENTIALLY THROWING PEOPLE
AROUND WITHOUT REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT.
COMPLEXITY OF THIS PROGRAM IS
WHERE IT IT'S GOING TO BE HEADED
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DEVELOP CONSISTENTLY SERVICES
IN EACH OF THE COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE. PEOPLE WHO
ARE SWEPT UP IN INTO THIS SYSTEM
SO I JUST DON'T IN THIS BUDGET I
DON'T. KNOW THAT I HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THINKS THIS IS GOING TO
GO. AND HOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HEADED SOMETHING THAT THAT THEY
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL BUT- THERE ARE
SOME MENTAL HEALTH COURTS IN IN
VARIOUS COUNTIES THERE ARE SOME
REALLY GOOD EXAMPLES. OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE INTERACTING WITH THESE
COURTS AND THAT THOSE ARE ALL
BACKED UP WITH SERVICES BUT
WE'RE LOOKING AT A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM AND COUNTY BY COUNTY.
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE THE REALLY
THE ABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO
MANAGE POPULATIONS LIKE THIS AND
HAVE SOME PLACE FOR THEM. TO GO.
SO I JUST DON'T WERE WORKING
WITH. THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
OTHERS ON TRYING TO PARSE OUT
THAT. THE POLICY AROUND THIS AND
WE'RE TAKING ABOUT PUTTING
MONEY INTO BUDGET NOW AND
IMPLEMENTING PARTS OF THIS NOW
COME JULY ONE. WHEN WE END THE
POLICY STUFF STILL HAS A LONG
LONG WAY TO GO SO I'M I'M- THAT
YOU'RE JUST REALLY NOT SURE WHAT
TO DO WITH THIS PROPOSAL. AND
I'M NOT SURE THAT I GUESS
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS BEING NICE
ABOUT THIS BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND. WHY THERE'S A LOT
NOT A LOT MORE PUSH BACK.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEY'RE GONNA
BE SET UP ULTIMATELY TO FAIL
HERE WITH WITHOUT THAT THE
BREADTH OF THOUGHT THAT NEEDS TO
BE PUT INTO A TO A PROGRAM OVER
ALL. RIGHT I DON'T KNOW WHAT AS
A SUB COMMITTEE WE CAN EVEN
REALLY DO WITH THIS AT THIS
POINT. I WANT TO THANK MR STONE
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. IN THIS
SPACE- AND JUST ADD A COMMON ON.
ON THIS- AT HOME WE KNOW WE NEED
TO BE DOING MORE WE NEED TO BE
DOING BETTER IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM ISN'T WORKING FOR A LOT
OF OUR LOVED ONES OUT THERE AND
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
CONSTITUENTS. WHO ARE DESPERATE
FOR HELPING FOR SOLUTIONS OUT
THERE LIKE MISTER SUN I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
OFFERING A PROGRAM THAT IS GOING
TO BE HELPFUL- AND NOT LEAVING
FOLKS WITH EMPTY PROMISES OUT
THERE AND SO I DO APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS THAT HE HAS ASKED THAT
I HOPE WE DO GET ANSWERS AND-
THIS PROCESS AND I DO WORRY
ABOUT HOW DID YOU DISTILL BRANCH
IS GOING TO IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM.
I TO THE ENACTMENT OF THE ACTUAL
POLICY. AND SO WANTED TO BE
THOUGHTFUL SO THAT. WE ARE NOT
GIVING COMMUNITY MEMBERS FALSE
EXPECTATIONS DURING THIS REALLY
WONDERFUL TIMES THAT THEY'RE
LIVING OUT THERE. AND SO WE MUST
PROCEED WITH CAUTION I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS AT
THAT COMMENT ON ON THIS ITEM AS
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THIS AND SO JUST. WANTED TO BE
REALLY MINDFUL OF. WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IN THE QUESTIONS THAT
A SIX ONE HALF THE OUT BREATH.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO OUR SEVENTH DEPARTMENT THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
OUR AND OUR FIRST. ISSUE HERE IS
ALEJO. SORRY NOT OF. THEY HAVE
SORRY I LOST MYSELF- THE ALLEY
IS GOING TO GIVE US SOME
COMMENTS ON THE STATE RESEARCH
PROJECT PLAN AND- YES RESPONSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I'M SO IN THE
MAY REVISION THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING A NUMBER OF I'M
SIGNIFICANT. OVERALL AND
INCREASES TO- YES THIS BUDGET
THAT ARE. AND CAPABILITIES OF-
YES I'M ON AN ONGOING BASIS
INCLUDING STAFFING INCREASES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE LIKE. I'M
IS SIMILAR TO WHAT WE FOUND WITH
THE JANUARY PROPOSALS ALONG THE
SAME MEANS OF- ENHANCING THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES WE FIND THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THESE ME REVISION PROPOSALS TO
ENHANCE STATE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPACITY. AND REFLECT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND APPROACH EFFICIENT
APPROACH TO DOING SO- BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT TIED TO SPECIFIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE GOALS OR
OBJECTIVES- AS WE DISCUSSED IN
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY PROPOSALS WE CONTINUE TO
FIND THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
STRATEGIC PLAN TO ENHANCE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY.
WOULD BE VALUABLE IN ASSESSING
FUTURE PROPOSALS. I'M IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE BETTER INFORMATION TO MAKE
DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE WE WOULD
RECOMMEND REQUIRING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR ENHANCING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY. AND
SUBMIT THAT PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE NO LATER THAN
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR- WE THINK SUCH A PLAN
SHOULD INCLUDE- GOALS FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY.
THAT WOULD GUIDE OF THE OVERALL
ENHANCING OF- SUCH CAPACITY. AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THE EXISTING
CAPACITY IS ON THAT HAS NOT BEEN
DONE. I'M IDENTIFICATION OF GAPS
OR WEAKNESSES IN THE CURRENT
CAPACITY. AND AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE LEVEL OF STAFFING NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE IDENTIFIED CAPACITY
GOALS. I WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND THAT AND THE- YES
BASED BUDGET BE REVIEWED AFTER
COMPLETION OF THE STRATEGIC
PLAN. I'M IN ORDER TO ACCESS ON
THE EXTENT TO WHICH ITS EXISTING
RESOURCES AND MEET THE GOALS
IDENTIFIED IN THE STRATEGIC PLAN
WHETHER SOME OF THE RESEARCHERS
SHOULD BE REALLOCATED TO HIRE
PARTY USES- AND TO THE EXTENT TO
WHICH A RECENT AUGMENTATIONS
ALREADY PROVIDED- RECENTLY HAVE
ADDRESSED SOME OF THE CAPACITY
GOALS- I WOULD NOTE THAT EARLIER
ON YOUR AGENDA TODAY ON THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR. HI THIS COMMITTEE
VOTED- CONCEPTUAL BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO- UP UP REQUIRE- WE
ASKED TO DEVELOP- THE STRATEGIC
PLAN- AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF ON THIS ISSUE-
YES SEVEN A RESPONSE. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARKET
OR EACH YEAR DIRECTOR OF CAL YES
SO FIRST UP I APPRECIATE THE L.
A. O. STATE KNOWLEDGE IS THAT
THE CHALLENGES FACING THE
ORGANIZATION AND THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO ADDRESS.
IT REALLY UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER
SEASON DEBTS AFTER THAT WE'VE
BEEN FACING SO MANY DIFFERENT
ONES INCLUDING DROUGHT AND
WILDFIRE OF POWER OUTAGES
EARTHQUAKES. AND OF COURSE THE
PANDEMIC. WE'RE OPEN TO WORKING
FOR THE L. A. O. IN YOUR STAFF
ON THE PARAMETERS OF THE NEXT. I
PROCESS THAT I HAVE TO CORRECT
IT. MY STAFF TO WORK WITH THE L.
A. O. AND YOUR STAFF ON LANGUAGE
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT'S
STRATEGIC PLAN. IN THE MEANTIME
CALORIE US IS ALREADY IN THE
PROCESS OF UPDATING STRATEGIC
PLAN. PACKAGE TO TREAT IT RIGHT
PROCESSES THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
TOOL FOR CALIBER YES WE PUBLISH
OUR STRATEGIC PLAN ONLINE AND
BELIEVE THAT THE STRATEGIC PLAN
SETS THE COURSE. FOR YES TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL ENHANCE
THE SERVICES WE PROVIDE. AT THE
EFFORTS WE UNDERTAKE TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA REMAINS A LEADER
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND
HOMELAND SECURITY IN FACT. WE GO
THROUGH- AND HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
ACHIEVED NATIONAL ACCREDITATION
THROUGH THE NATIONAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION WHICH
CALLED FOR SIXTY SIX DIFFERENT.
AFTER RECEIVING AND STANDARDS
FOR ACCREDITATION FALL WITH
MEDICAL BONTA METRIC DRIVEN
DOUBLES AND OBJECTIVES STAND.
EACH OF OUR PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU
THIS AFTERNOON HI TO OUR CURRENT
STRATEGIC PLAN. FOR EXAMPLE THE-WAREHOUSE THE PROPOSAL WILL
DISCUSS IN A FEW MINUTES WHILE
TO ACHIEVE OUR GOAL OF
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
DELIVERING OF RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA DISASTERS
SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY SHE
SUPPORT. FUNCTIONS SEVEN. THAT
IS ONE OF SIXTY EMERGENCY
SUPPORT FUNCTIONS. BY METRIC
ITSELF AND OF COURSE OUR- OUR
PARTY FINANCIAL STRUCTURE WITH
REGARD TO THE STANDARDIZED
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SYSEM. L.
LOOKS THE WAY THAT THE STATE
AND- WE HAVE SPECIFICALLY-
MANAGEMENT RESPONSE TO RECOVERS
FROM ALL HAPPENED EMERGENCY AND
DISASTERS. HOWEVER ALL NOTED
THAT THE ONLY- IT'S RECOMMENDED
THAT YOU BOB APPROVED. FUNDING
FOR SOME OF OUR PROJECTS- BUT
ONLY THREE YEARS. AND WHILE I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT LEO'S
ASSESSMENT I SUPPORTED THE
PRACTICAL IMPLICATION IS THAT
THIS RESTRICTION MAKES HARD TO
FILL POSITIONS. EVEN HARDER TO
FILL. THIS WORK IS NOT FOR
EVERYONE IT'S VERY CHALLENGING
IS DEMANDING. YEAH THERE ARE
WOMEN AND MEN OUT THERE WHO ARE
WILLING TO STEP UP AND COMBAT.
BUT WHEN WE TELL THEM THAT THESE
CANDIDATES THAT THEIR EMPLOYMENT
IS NOT PERMANENT. FOR MANY IT'S
A DEAL BREAKER AND ACTUALLY IT'S
A IT'S A HUGE DETAIL THAT WE
HAVE A HARD TIME OVERCOMING. SO
THAT'S BASICALLY ASSESSMENT
AUTOMATIC RESPONSE. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. OKAY OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AND JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. HE GOT THE- LANGUAGE
AT STAFF THAN TO OVER. AROUND
THIS IS TO CHECK PLAN- I KNOW
WHICH IS CENTERED OVER A FEW
DAYS AGO- IT'S BEEN TWO WEEKS
ALREADY SORRY FOR MORE THAN A
FEW WEEKS AGO- BUT IT'S WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO SURE ARE
THAT WE DO INCLUDE- SURE GOLD.
IN THIS BUDGET- FOR TUESDAY
STRATEGIC PLAN AS WELL AND SO DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT ON
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE SHARED WITH
YOU- JUST A QUICK. QUESTION YOU
HAD IS PICKED UP FUTURE WORKING
WITH US TWO WEEKS AGO WITH
REGARDS TO THE PLANET AND THAT.
WERE ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
REGARDS TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING
THE PLANNER DEVELOPING THE PLAN.
DOES WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO PUT
SOMETHING IN THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR. NOW THAT WE HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT'S CODIFIED.
I GOT YOU KNOW OUTSIDE OF THAT
YES WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT THANK YOU AND WHEN DO YOU
THINK YOU'LL BE ABLE TO EITHER
PROVIDE SOMETHING OR RESPOND TO
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE PROVIDED ON
MAY FOURTH. LOOK AT THE MY
STAFF. HERE WILL BE TAKING.
MEASUREMENTS MARKET CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- WE EXPECT TO BE ABLE
TO GET BACK TO YOUR STAFF IS
ALWAYS TOMORROW. AND WILL ALSO
BE WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. OKAY THANK YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT. WELL. I HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME I WILL WAIT FOR YOUR
RESPONSE AND I'M SURE I'LL HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS THAN- BUT WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ITEM WAREHOUSING
OPERATIONS. ALL RIGHT GREAT- SO
THERE'S A PORTAL ON YOUR GENDER
IS A REQUEST FOR. ONE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN POINT THREE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND WHAT TIME TO
PROVIDE WAREHOUSE SPACE.
PURCHASE NATO AND REPLACE
EXPIRED PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. INCREASE LIFE LINE
COMMODITY SUPPLIES FOR ALL I
HUNDRED BANDS AND SECURE
LOGISTICS SUPPORT EQUIPMENT.
SPECIFICALLY FOUR PP THE
PROPOSAL REFLECTS PP STOCKPILE
TARGETS. THAT ARE BASED UPON
AVERAGES UP ACTUAL DEMAND
RESPONSE DURING THE INITIAL
PANDEMIC. RESPONSE THE WINTER
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SURGE.
THE DELTA THERE HAVE SURGED AND
ECONOMIC CRIME VARIANTS SEARCH.
HELLO YES AS THE GERMAN THAT
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF
WAREHOUSE SPACE IS NEEDED IN
BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S A MILLION
SQUARE FEET IN TOTAL TO ADDRESS
THE CURRENT DISASTER LOGISTICS
PLANNING. ASSUMPTIONS AND
ADEQUATELY SUSTAIN EXISTING
CRITICAL PANDEMIC AND OTHER
EMERGENCY RELIEF SUPPLIES. FOR
RISK CONTINUED RESPONSE THE
PANDEMIC BUT ALSO FOR
EARTHQUAKES. WILDFIRES FLOODS
AROUND AGES. FOOD SHELTER AND
WATER COMMODITIES. FUNDING
INCLUDE SUSTAINING EXISTING
WAREHOUSES. WITH AT LEAST BY
STRATEGY UTILITIES SHIPPING.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TEMPERATE
LOGISTICS SPECIALIST PERSONNEL
AND MAINTENANCE COST PER FISCAL
YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JESSICA PETERS- WHAT THE
L. A. OUT- JUST TO RECAP- TO
MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR SINCE I'M
NOT ENTIRELY SURE I HEARD IT
AND- SO THE PROPOSAL IS A
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME-
THAT WOULD SUPPORT TO- EXISTING-
YES WAREHOUSES- ONE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S APPROXIMATELY
HALF A MILLION SQUARE FEET. AND
A ONE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS A MILLION SQUARE FEET
SO A ONE AND A HALF MILLION
SQUARE FEET OF SPACE- WHICH IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S HIGHER THAN
WHAT THE- DIRECTOR INDICATE.
THAT DEPARTMENT BELIEVES IT IS
NEEDED- AND THIS WOULD BE ONE
TIME FUNDING AND BECAUSE THE
STATE HAS ALREADY PURCHASED OUR
EQUIPMENT IT IS- IN EXISTENCE-
AND HAS TO BE STORED SOMEWHERE
AND THESE ARE WAREHOUSES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WAS ABLE TO.
PROCURE AND SET UP USING OTHER
EMERGENCY FUND SAYS THIS IS
CONTINUING THOSE EFFORTS. I'M TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO APPROVE THIS FINDING
OUT WE WOULD RECOMMEND MODIFYING
THE PROPOSAL. AND SPECIFICALLY
WE WOULD RECOMMEND MAKING THAT
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION OF THE
TOTAL FUNDING FOR REPLACING PP
CONTINGENT UPON A REPORT TO THE
DRAFT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AND A THIRTY DAY
NOTIFICATION- BEFORE THE FUNDS
COULD BE SPENT AND WE THINK THIS
REPORT SHOULD INCLUDE DETAILS ON
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF THE PP
STORED IN THE WAREHOUSES. THE
AMOUNTS OF EXPIRED PP. AND THE
RATIONALE FOR PURCHASING NEW PP
ON THIS IS BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY STORING
PP THAT IS ABOUT TO EXPIRE. AND
THEN NEED TO REPLACE THIS
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
HAS NOT BEEN ESTABLISHED- JUST
ARE WITHIN THE LAST FEW HOURS-
YES THAT WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO OUR OFFICE. THAT
CURRENTLY AT THESE WAREHOUSES
THEY HAVE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE MILLION PIECES OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
STORED. AND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION OF THAT IS
EXPIRING SOON- AND SO IT JUST
RAISES THE QUESTION OF HOW MUCH
PP NEEDS TO BE STORED- IF WE
HAVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
PIECES OF IT EXPIRING EQUIPMENT.
THAT IS GOING BAD IN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS WHEN WE'VE JUST COME
OUT OF- IN A RECENT SURGES
WITHIN THE PANDEMIC. HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. I'M NOT
SURE IF THAT BY CUTTING- BUT ALL
THE RESPECT IN THE LA- SUCCESS
MEANT BOB WHAT'S GOING ON
WAREHOUSES. BOB THIS IS A
COMPLEX. IF BOB BOB BEING ABLE
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH-
FOR ALL YOUR DEMANDS BUT NOT
COMMODITIES INCLUDING PP. UP ON
IMMEDIATE AVAILABILITY TO MEET
WHATEVER ADVANCED FALL US NOW
WAS VERY EFFECTIVE SPECIFICALLY
WHAT USED THE L. A. WAS TALKING
ABOUT IS THE EXPIRATION OF- WHAT
WE CALL THE HOSPITAL GREATER
SURGICAL GRADE PP. THAT IS
DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY. WORK IN-
OPERATOR ROOM OR BURGER YOUR
GROUPS- THAT'S ONGOING ISSUE
WHEN YOU'VE GOT THAT KIND OF B.
B. E. TO CONTINUALLY EVALUATE
REPLACED MY AGE OR REVIEWS.
ABOUT BP SO IT'S NOT UNCOMMON
ISSUE OR CHALLENGE CHU CHU- YOU
KNOW. CONSTANTLY UPDATE OR
UPGRADE- I CHANGE OUT EXPIRED BE
BEAT BUT LET ME MAKE A NOTE THAT
THIS PARTICULAR LEVY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHILE IT IS NO
LONGER NECESSARILY USED AND
AVAILABLE FOR HOSPITAL GREAT FOR
SURGICAL GREAT CAPABILITIES THAT
SEEMS HE CAN'T BE HUGE CRICKET
CONDITIONS LIKE WILDFIRES- BOB
ROGERS MATERIALS OR ABETS BETTER
NOT. WITHIN THE SURGICAL SORT OF
REQUIRED LEVEL SO. IF THIS IS AN
ONGOING. THE ISSUE BY THE PART
OF THE PART OF THE TEAM. HERE
JUST ONE OF IT WE'RE CONSTANTLY
FOOD. WILL COME ON- AND OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVE SHELF LIVES ON
THEM NOT TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
A STOCKPILE THAT MEETS THE NEEDS
NOW THIS ISSUE OF. THIRTY DAYS
AND GOING TO MAKE UP TO ASK
ABOUT THE- APPROVAL PRIOR TO
GETTING IT LOOKED BE SURGES
WE'RE GONNA WORK WERE KICKING UP
WITH WITH THE WITHOUT BE ONE
TWO. YES AS WE SPEAK UP ON ON
THE PANDEMIC OF WILDFIRE SEASON
IS RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER WHAT
WE GO THROUGH THESE COMMODITIES
VERY RAPIDLY IF YOU REMEMBER ALL
WE HAVE TO DISTRIBUTE SEVERAL
MILLION- MASTER SCHOOLS JUST AS
AT SCHOOL STARTED BACK UP AGAIN
BOB COME AUGUST WHERE WE
POTENTIALLY COULD SE. AS WITH
LOOKING AT THE PROJECTIONS MAY
BE ANOTHER SPIKE IN KOBE THAT'S
ABOUT THE SAME TIME THE KIDS.
BACK TO SCHOOL THERE'S GOING TO
BE A NEED FOR THIS AND WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO GET UP AND
PROCURER- BOBBY B. AND OTHER
COMMODITIES GET REAL TIME TO BE
ABLE TO STAY OUT IN FRONT OF THE
IRAN CRISIS. I THINK I L. CLOSE
MIGHT SAY I DON'T WANT TO FLOAT
UP AND WHERE WE WORK AT. IN
MARCH. BOB- TWENTY ONE WE START
THEM PANDA. BUT THE REALITY IS
WE ARE. FACING GOAL SUPPLY CHAIN
CHALLENGE RIGHT MAJORITY OF THE
BECAUSE HE COMES FOR PROTECTING
THEM THE- MASTIN THINGS FROM
ONCE. AND WE HAVE TO BE IT'S NOT
GONNA THAT. THERE ARE LAGGED
BEHIND AND TRY. WITH REGARDS TO
BLOGSPOT PROCUREMENT. BOB
CAPABILITIES AND IT'S NOT UNIQUE
TO. THIS IS THE A GLOBAL
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE FACING UP
WHERE- BOB HOPE BUT THERE'S A
HUGE BACKLOG IN A LOT OF THIS
STUFF NOTWITHSTANDING JUST PP WE
HAVE TO GET BACK LOTS OF THINGS
LIKE FIREBOATS REDUCING BACKLOGS
AND THINGS LIKE- BOB GOGGLES AND
OTHER KINDS OF PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND- IN CERTAIN
SHOPPING ITEMS SO. THIS IS THIS
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WE ARE.
LASER FOCUS WITH BECAUSE TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE COMMODITY-
BEAR THAT WE CANNOT BE CAUGHT
SHORT AND THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
LIFE SUSTAINING LIFE LINE. OF
RESOURCES WHAT WE NEED. I THANK
YOU I THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT WE
HAVE THE SAME. GOALS HERE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE LEARN
FROM. WHERE WE'RE AT A MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY AM AND WE READ IT
BETTER PREPARED. MOVING FORWARD
WHETHER IT'S ON CLIMATE OR ANY
OTHER. EMERGENCY THAT IS OUT
THERE I THINK SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE ALLEY- IS
STILL SEEN OUR FAIR THOUGH AS WE
STILL NEED TO ENSURE. TAXPAYERS
THAT WE ARE BEING RESPONSIBLE
WITH. THEIR DOLLARS OUT THERE
AND SO I DO THINK SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS ARE FOR AND ANSWERS
FOR THEM WOULD BE. APPROPRIATE
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO TELL THE
VOTERS THAT WE'RE LEARNING FROM
TWENTY TWENTY. AND PLANNING
BETTER BUT WE'RE ALSO BEING
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE- UP THERE
AS WELL AND SO I DO HOPE. HE
GETS SOME ANSWERS TO THE-
QUESTIONS. HERE ARE AND THAT. WE
AT THE END THE DAY WE HAVE. A
BUDGET THAT WE'RE VOTING ON THAT
. WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF- OUT
THERE AND SO I DO AS THIS
PROCESS CONTINUES- I LOOK
FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS ON ON THIS ITEM. ON
THE WAY HOUSING ITEM. AT THE
ONLY OTHER ITEM THE ONLY OTHER
PIECE I WANT TO ADD TO THIS I
KNOW THAT THIS IS A ONE TIME.
ALLOCATION. AND IT JUST
WONDERING IF WE SHOULD BE PLENTY
MORE LONG TERM. I WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE COST EFFECTIVE AND
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST KIND OF ANY
NON RANDOMLY. ALONG THE WAY AND
SO I DON'T KNOW IF. THE
DEPARTMENT WANTS TO COMMENT ON.
AND THAT WAY I REALLY DO YOU
KNOW ONE YEAR VERSUS SOMETHING
pTHANKS JERRY I WOULD LIKE TO
COME ON THAT SO. WE'RE ACTUALLY
DEVELOPING A LONGER TRM
STRATEGY FOR PER MINUTE- BOB.
WAREHOUSING A BEACH TO
FACILITIES NORTH AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- IN ORDER OBVIOUSLY
LIKE ALL OF US- STILL IN THE
THROES OF RESPONDING TO THE
DISASTERS AND- AND THE PANDEMIC
SPECIFICALLY- THAT HAD NOT BEEN
ABLE TO PULL TOGETHER BOB YOU
KNOW- A COMPREHENSIVE AND STOP
ALL. PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT ON ALL OF THAT IS IT
ROCKPORT YOU BOB THIS IS A HI
INTRINSICALLY CHEN. AND OUT WILL
WELCOME BACKGROUND THIS NEXT GO
AROUND WITHOUT THE MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION. AND AT
UNTIL THEY YOU FOR KNOWLEDGE IN
THE YOU ARE TRYING TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING MORE LONG TERM-
WHAT WITH THE TEN MAINLY SAY FOR
THE NEXT FOUR ON THAT WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN THAT APPROXIMATELY
WHAT ARE. WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
IF YOU'RE GOING TO NEED. 2%
SOMETHING TO US. IS IT UP.
MEXICANUM CHAIR- WEEKS MARKET
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR- OF THE
PROPOSAL FOR YOU WOULD PROVIDE
US FUNDING THROUGH JAN THIRTY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO IT'S ONE
YEAR FUNDING SO WE WOULD BE
COMING BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
REQUESTING APPROVAL OF A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LONG TERM PROPOSAL
PRIOR TO THAT TIME SO IN
DEVELOPMENT AT THAT. OF THE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
NOT TWENTY THREE TWENTY PARK
BUDGET. SB BY THE NECK BUDGET S.
BEFORE THE JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WE SHOULD HAVE. AND A PLAN
BRETT. MADAM CHAIR MITCH
MEDICAMENTS I JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT THAT THE ONLY OTHER BOOK
REALLY IT ADDRESS THAT WE HAVE
ONE MILLION SQUARE FEET IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- OUR GOAL IS
STILL FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET THERE OR AT LEAST
UNTIL DECEMBER AT WHICH POINT IN
TIME WE'RE GOING TO BE
TRANSITIONING OR REDUCING THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE OBLIGATION THERE
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SCORPION WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES UNINSURED AT THAT
HAPPENS BUT THE ARTICLE IS STILL
NOT ONE POINT FIVE. ONE MILLION
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT RATHER. TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT. WAREHOUSE OKAY
THANK YOU. MISTER JONES SAWYER.
BUT I COULDN'T RESIST- AT THE
FORMER MERGING PREPAREDNESS
COORDINATOR FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. AND I WAS IN CHARGE OF
LOGISTICS- I BOTTOM UP GAME GO
SANDBAGS BACK WHEN WE USED TO
HAVE FLOOD- IT'S PROBABLY EIGHTY
NINE. BILLS THEIR BAG TO
PROBABLY MOLD IT IN ARRIVE IT
RIGHT NOW. AND FEMA WOULD NOT A
REPEAT WOULD NOT LET US BY
THINGS LIKE CHAIRS AND TABLES
AND TENTS. AND THEY WOULD ONLY
REIMBURSE US FOR THINGS THAT WE
LEAST I STILL THINK WITH THE
STUPID IDEA BUT- THAT WAS THE
WAY THE WITH THAT THINGS. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE ONE WE DON'T GO
AHEAD AND BUY THINGS THAT PEOPLE
WILL NOT REIMBURSE US FOR. TO
THAT WE DON'T WE ACTUALLY DO
NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT THINGS ARE
ARE PERISHABLE BECAUSE THAT IS A
REAL CONCERN THAT WE PUT ALL THE
STUFF IN A WAREHOUSE IN A COME
TO THE END OF THEIR USEFUL LIFE-
WE GET THROUGH THIS AND YOU HAVE
THESE MASKING THEIR- FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS. EVERY TWO YEARS
WITH. ROTATING THEM OUT. OF LIKE
WE COULD HAVE BEEN DOING WITH
THOSE SANDBAGS. CIVILISED COULD
STILL BE BUYING FED BAGS RIGHT
NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF A DROUGHT.
SO I TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
WASTING MONEY. ON THINGS THAT-
YES RIGHT NOW WE'RE WE'RE IN A
FLOOD SITUATION WITH THE
PANDEMIC BUT IT MAY NOT ALWAYS
BE THAT WAY AND WE HAVE TO BE
THAT SOMEONE SAID. MINDFUL OF-
SOMEONE'S MONEY DAVID IS AS IT
IS YOUR MONEY WOULD YOU CONTINUE
TO PAY FOR SOMETHING YOU CAN'T
USE EVERY YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR. SO I'M JUST PUTTING THAT
OUT THERE. OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REPRESENTED THAT THE OPERATION
AND THEN YOU'RE RIGHT BOB I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE FOR
EVERYONE IS THAT. THE PROBLEM.
IS THE MASTER OF THE GORBALS
ECCENTRIC BEACH ARE UTILIZED FOR
NOT JUST THE PANDEMIC BUT FOR
ALL HAZARDS RIGHT WE DEPLOYED
BURKE WILDFIRE SMOKE- WHICH WE
KNOW WE HAVE SEEN COME INTO.
URBAN AREAS AND THAT YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR THE CITY SAN FRANCISCO
WAS ALMOST DEVELOPMENT WITH
SMOKE AND SO WE'VE WE'VE USED IT
AT SCHOOL FIVE SECONDS RIGHT
WE'VE- PUSHED THEM OUT THAT
BUSINESS EDITION OTHER TOP
ACTIVITIES TO ENSURE THAT THE
OUR ECONOMY COULD STILL BE
MOVING RIGHT. SO WE TRY TO
LEVERAGES BUDGET THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO MEET ALL
OF THAT THE RISKS AND THREATS
BUT YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE A PERISHABLE ITEM
WE'RE CONSTANTLY TALK ABOUT THE
THINGS LIKE JUST SIXTEEN. A DISS
THERE CONSTANTLY ROTATING AND
ACCESSING TO MAKE SURE THAT NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE UPDATED-
COMMODITIES BUT ALL THE
BATTERIES ARE CHARGED NOT BAD
THAT GENERATORS ARE FUELED AND
THAT THAT THAT YOU KNOW A QUICK
A QUICK MINUTES READY TO GO. AND
THAT'S A CRITICAL FUNCTION
JOHNSON PARTICULARLY IN A STATE
LIKE THIS BOB HERTZBERG WE SEE
ON ANOTHER EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS THAT WERE ROTATED A
LOT OF THINGS THE ANNUALLY- BUT-
AND WE DO ALSO WORK TO GET. AS
MUCH FEMA REIMBURSEMENT ALL IT'S
CERTAINLY ALL THE STAFF FOR THE
PANDEMIC CURRENTLY IT'S STILL AT
A HUNDRED PERCENT- WEEK FIRST
MET BY FEMA HANNAH BETH TOOK IT
WILL CHANGE OUR DOG TO AT NINETY
TEN SHORT FORMAT UNTIL THE
EMERGENCY IS OVER AND THEN IT'LL
BE A DIFFERENT STORY SO. PART OF
THIS PROPERTY WE'RE DOING NOW IS
REALLY EACH BUILDING THAT
SUSTAINABLE THIS- YOU KNOW WE
DON'T ACTUALLY THE FEDERAL.
DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF THAT WILL
COME TO RIGHT NOW BUT THAT THE
NEEDS AND THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
US TO. EXPORT THE SIXTY
CALIFORNIA'S. AFTERWORLD WILL
REMAIN. I JUST DIDN'T RESPOND TO
THE- OF. THE TERM NEED- MADAM
SHE THAT YOU WOULD ASK I THIS IS
A ONE OF THOSE KINDS OF AYE.
THAT WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE INTO THIS STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND I'M
A RATHER THAN DOING THINGS IN A
PEACEFUL MEAL FASHION. ON IF THE
DEPARTMENT WERE TO COME UP WITH
A PLAN FOR STORING PP IN THE
NEXT YEAR AND THEN A YEAR LATER
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN. THAT
MAYBE LAYS OUT A DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE- OR DIFFERENT COLOR
CAPACITY GOALS IDENTIFIES
DIFFERENT TYPES OF THREATS THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO. ON THAT THAT MIGHT
NOT ALIGN WITH WHAT THEY COME UP
WITH AND SO- WE I THINK WE WOULD
CAUTION AGAINST. DOING THINGS IN
A PIECEMEAL PLAN- AND OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE SORT OF AN INTERIM NEED
AS THE EQUIPMENT HAS BEEN
PROCURED AND THE STATE DOES HAVE
A NEED TO DISPERSE THIS
EQUIPMENT-BUT WE WOULD HOPE
THAT THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
PLAN AND- AND REALLY JUST THE
SITUATION KIND OF HIGHLIGHTS.
THE NEED FOR A PLAN ON ONGOING
BASIS AS- THAT THE PROCUREMENT
OF THE WAREHOUSES IN THE PP WAS
DONE IN A VERY REACTIONARY
FASHION WHEN. THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC STARTED AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING A MORE STRATEGIC APPROACH
ON THE FRONTEND. THANK THANK YOU
I LOOK FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS ITEM AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THIS PROCESS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
THIRD. ITEM WHICH IS CALIFORNIA
SPECIALIZED TRAINING INSTITUTE.
RIGHT THANKS I'M NOT SURE SO THE
FINAL REQUEST ON THE AGENDA IS-
SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND THAT'S FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS BOND GOING
IN TWENTY THREE POSITIONS BONTA
ECHO FIVE UPDATE THE NUMBER OF
KEY COURSES FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND A BIRD
AND SHE RESPONDED REYES THE.
CALIFORNIA SPECIALIZED TRAINING
INSTITUTE. RESEND COURT. WALL
BOB BLACK THE NEW NORMAL THAT
WE'RE ALL FACING AND WILL ENSURE
THE STATE AND LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PROFESSIONALS
PRIVATE. SECTOR NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS ACTIVE IN
DISASTERS WILL BE FULLY TRAINED
TO BE THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
CHALLENGES FACING THE STATE. THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL ALLOW
CSC ACT PROVIDE NEW EXISTING AND
UPDATED CERTIFICATE AND
CREDENTIALS OR SENSE AND
EXERCISE SUPPORT IN MORE
LOCATIONS ACROSS THE STATE IN
BOTH YOUR PERSONAL AND VIRTUAL
INSTRUCTIONAL INSTRUCTOR LED
FORMATS. HI THIS IS A PROBLEM
IMPLEMENT OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
GOALS UP SUPPORTING STATEWIDE
TRAINING EXERCISE EDUCATION AND
URGENCY MANAGEMENT PUBLIC SAFETY
ALL RIGHT SECURITY OUT OF
MATERIALS DISASTER RECOVERY AND
CRISIS COMMUNICATIONS FROM LOCAL
STATE AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
BURKE SHE MET IN PERSONNEL
PRIVATE SECTOR CUSTOMERS. AND
FOR REGIONAL MUTILATE STABILITY
AND SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAMS LIKE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT MUTUAL AID
PROGRAM- INSURERS THAT WERE
POORLY TRAINED AND CAPABLE OF
MUTUAL AID. COORDINATOR AT THE
RETAIL LEVEL- SO. THAT'S AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE- THE- AS PART
OF THIS PARTICULAR- REQUEST
AGAIN- THIS IS BASED UPON THE-
CONTINUAL APPLICATION YEAH- NEED
TO MEET THE EVER CHANGING.
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE FACE IS A
STATE OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE AREN'T
RESELLING IT AS A POSSIBLE
PROBLEM ALL OF THE ASYMMETRICAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. HELLO
AT JUST COMPUTERS THE WITH THE
L. A. L. A. CAN AND SO WE WOULD
DO IT WE FIND THAT THE PROPOSAL
REALLY LACKS SUFFICIENT
JUSTIFICATION AND I'M HAVING A
BROAD BASED INCREASE IN
TRAINING- WHAT TRAINING IS A
VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE- AGAIN THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE THINK WOULD
BE BEST INFORMED BY AFTER THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS ABLE TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN- AND
SO- WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
MOST OF THE REQUEST- HOWEVER WE
DO THINK THAT SET THE SEVEN
POSITIONS FOR VIRTUAL TRAINING.
ON COULD BE REASONABLE
ESPECIALLY ON A THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM BASIS THEY COULD BE
REVISITED AFTER TO THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPS A STRATEGIC
PLAN- BUT THOSE POSITIONS WOULD
ALLOW- WE ASKED TO HAVE SUNG
SOME AUGMENTATION OF ITS
TRAINING CAPACITY AND THE
VIRTUAL FORMAT WOULD OPEN THE
TRAINING UP TO ANYBODY IN THE
STATE INCLUDING MORE RURAL
REMOTE AREAS OF THE STATE THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO MAKE IT TO THE
TRAINING INSTITUTE- AND THEN
THESE BROADER INCREASES OF THE
TRAINING INSTITUTES CAPACITY AND
ROLE IN THE STATE COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT ARE CONSIDERED AS
PART OF ITS DEVELOPMENT OF THE
STRATEGIC PLAN. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. BUT THANK YOU CAN
THE DEPARTMENT LET US KNOW WHAT
THE CURRENT. FUNDING LEVEL A
NUMBER OF POSITIONS. YOU HAVE
FOR THIS TRAINING METHOD TO. I
AM I STOP LOOKING THAT UP RIGHT
NOW- FOR YOUR FOR YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT CHAIR. BUT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A MAP CAN I JUST SAY
THAT- WITH THE ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATION. IT DOES LEAVE
THE CORE FUNCTIONS AND
CAPABILITIES OF THE PROGRAM WHAT
SUPPORT CAN PARTICULARLY THREE
YES THE FIRST IS TRAINING UP
INTERNAL STAFF. WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES CASS WHEN
IT WILL BE ABLE TO STAY AT WORK
THE TRAINING NEEDS OF ALL OUR
STAFF ARE CURRENTLY. REPORTS
WILL PROVIDE DEDICATED TREATING
THE PERMITS ASTERISK BONTA STAFF
TO PROVIDE INCREASED TRAINING
AVAILABILITY BUT IT DIVISIONAL
STAFF. YEAH HELLO YES TO BE
SEATED IN A RECENT YEARS THE
SECOND IS TRAINING AND
STRENGTHENING THE CAPABILITIES
OF STATE LOCAL PARTNERS ACROSS
THE STATE. BUDGET EVEN TRIBES
RATHER STATE AGENCIES EVERY YEAR
PROBABLY S. B. C.'S MORE
TRAINING REQUEST REGIONAL
OVERSEE MANAGEMENT. TEAMS THE
PROVIDE WITHOUT RESTORE FELLOW
YES WILL BE UNABLE PROVIDE A
DISH TRAINING. DRESSES AS WELL
AS TRAIN. IT CANCERS THAT
RESIGNED. APOLO LEVEL WHICH
THERE ARE THE WOULD BE THE
REQUIRE. THANK CALL IN THE STATE
FOR US CONTINUALLY HAVING TO
RESPOND INTO THOSE JURISDICTIONS
TO THAT DEGREE THAT WE DO. NEED
RESOURCES WELL ESTABLISH A
TRAINING. COORDINATOR IT EACH OF
THE STATE'S SIX METER WIDE
REGIONS RECORDED NECESSARY
TRAINING AND ENSURE THE TRAINEES
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE STATE. AND
LASTLY BOB. IT'S SO OBVIOUS BUT
AGAIN THERE ARE THE BILL TO SHOW
. HE VOLUNTEERED NOT GO OR IN
THE- WERE CRITICAL TO THE
COMMUNITIES- WITHOUT THESE
RESOURCES CAN I GUESS ISN'T ABLE
TO SUSTAIN ADDRESS THE
INCREASING TRAINING REQUEST
RECEIVED FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
INCLUDING OUR BEST A CALL
UTILITIES. INVOLVED
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE MEMBERS
DEBATE RETRAINING TO PRIVATE.
SECTOR ORGANIZATIONS INSURERS. I
THINK IT'S BECAUSE ACROSS THE
STATE AND IT HERE'S TO BY THE
MURDERS MAN SYSTEM THE METRIX'S
WITH THAT MEETS THE OBJECTIVES
IN METRICS THAT ARE SUPPORT IN
OUR CREDIT DECISION. THAT MEETS
THE INTO THE COMMANDS- THAT
SYSTEM STRUCTURE THE CALIFORNIA
USES DURING EMERGENCY RESPONSE
EFFORTS ALL TRAINING PREPARED
AND LIBERTYTHESE ENTITIES ARE
PAID FOR BY THE REQUESTED
PRIVATE SECTOR ORGANIZATION. AS
THE CHAPTERS ARE BECOME LARGER
MORE FREQUENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND COMMUNITIES ARE RELYING MORE
NGOS AND VOLUNTEER GROUPS
SUPPORT RESPONSE RECOVERY
EFFORTS PROVIDE TRAINING.
PROGRAM. TRADING TO THESE GROUPS
. SO YES YOU KNOW. FOUGHT WORKS
WITH WITH THE STATE RESPONSE
SINCE. ALL RIGHT WHICH THAT
THINGS WERE ABSOLUTELY HERE AS
POLLS BY THE L. A. O. WITH TO
THE WAY. THAT WE BOB FOR RESPOND
TO I JUST ASK I WISH WE KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT THE DISASTER IS
GOING TO BRING IN FRONT OF US
BUT THE TRUTH OUT OF RACES
THAT'S NOT HOW REALITY WORKS AND
THE FACT IS THAT- WE HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLANS I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR- THE COMPASS THE L. A. L.
WHICH THAT HELD STRATEGIC PLAN
EXISTS. NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN TO FOLLOW IT TO A
T. IT BUILDS THE CAPABILITY
CAPACITY WITH ORGANIZATIONS AND
IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS
EVERYTHING ACTUALLY ACROSS IT
FOR MULTIPLE YEARS OUT WE JUST
WENT TO ANOTHER CREDIT THEY
SHOULD THIS PAST WEEK. SO AGAIN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEL. A.
OKAY AND THEN AND THEN YOUR- BUT
LET. ON BEHALF TO ADDRESS THE
THESE GAP PLANS WHEN MAKE IT
CLEAR ABOUT AS OF THE L. A. O.
WITH THIS. I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH
OF THAT DID BUT THERE IS A-
THERE'S A REASON WHY- OH YES.
ASSEMBLY AND EFFICIENTLY NOW. IT
THESE- YES CRISIS AND THE THAT
WE HAVE AS WE ACTIVELY AT SIX.
SUPPORTED LOCAL. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ACROSS THE STATE TO
BE ABLE TO PROTECT LIFE AND
PROPERTY AND THAT THAT IT CANNOT
YEAH A SUCCESSFUL EFFICIENT WAY
SO- I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
EDITORIAL LIKE THAT BECAUSE I'M
I'M NOT SURE THAT THE- FOR THE
RECORD I THAT THE COMICS THE L.
A. L. THAT- IT SOUNDED LIKE THEY
DIDN'T TAKE ANY STRATEGIC PLAN
THAT THAT WHERE **** NILLY JUST
BEING INCORRECT. AND- YES.
RESOURCE FOR NO REASON
WHATSOEVER AND NO NO. OR THERE
IS A- MISTER TO THIS IN AND WE
HAVE SO- BOB EFFECTIVELY AND OF
THEM ARE IN THE PAST YEARS AND
THE ANSWER OF THE- IT A BOB
LEVIN POINT FOR. MILLION AND
FORTY EIGHT ALL POSITIONS AT
UCSD AYE THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIALIZED TRAINING INSTITUTE.
IF APPLE HAVE BOOKED MAYBE I
COULD HELP AS A PROUD ALUMNI OF
C. S. T. I. BOB WHAT YOU JUST
SAID TO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM WITH GOBBLEDYGOOK
BUREAUCRATIC GOBLET GROUP. SO I
WILL HELP YOU TRANSLATE TO THE
L. A. O. AND OTHERS. HOW
IMPORTANT IF- IF YOU'VE NEVER
GONE THROUGH TRAINING YOU DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU BRING
BACK TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES SO
I WILL I WILL VOLUNTEER TO HELP
YOU WITH THAT- BECAUSE I'M IN
1100% SUPPORT. OF GETTING THE-
OF THIS BUDGET REQUEST AND
MAKING SURE THAT IT HAPPENS. I'M
SO. I APPRECIATE THAT THE TIME
IT TOOK TO ENTER TO LIFE YOUR
THOUGHTS HERE TO US- I THINK
IT'S OUR JOB TO ASK QUESTIONS AT
THE L. A. ILL STOP TO ASK
QUESTIONS TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
BEING FISCALLY PRUDENT WITH OUR
DOLLARS- AND IT'S AS OUR
PARTNERS I THINK. A BETTER WAY
TO APPROACH IS THIS IS NOT TO.
BAKAN SENDING TO US- AND IN THIS
MOMENT- AND- AS THE AS THE WOMEN
I GET MANSPLAINING TO QUITE. TOO
OFTEN- AND IN THIS PLACE A
LITTLE TOO OFTEN OUT THERE AND
SO I DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS ON
THE DAYS BUT I DO FEEL LIKE I
WAS JUST MANSPLAINING TO. AND MY
QUESTION WAS NOT ANSWERED AND I
HAD A SECOND QUESTION THAT I
WANTED TO ADD TO THIS- INSIGHT
WOULD ASK THAT WE ANSWERED MY
QUESTIONS WITHOUT ANY
EDITORIALIZING- OF WITH THE L.
A. L. SAT OR WHAT MY QUESTION IS
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
YOU COULD TELL ME WE DON'T HAVE
AN ANSWER WE'LL GET IT TO YOU.
LATER AND SO THE EARLIER
QUESTION WAS ABOUT THE CURRENT
FUNDING LEVELS AND THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS FOR THIS TRAINING
INSTITUTE MY SECOND QUESTION IS
THAT THE PRIMARY RESOURCE FOR
TRAINING FOR EMERGENCY PERSONNEL
OR THE LOCAL FIVE OTHER.
TRAINING OUT THERE THAT THE THAT
THEY'RE USING THEIR OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THEY ADEQUATE.
OR NOT. I'M SURE. YOU HAVE YOUR
FIRST QUESTION IS- ELEVEN POINT
FOUR MILLION FIVE DOLLARS AND
FORTY EIGHT AUTHORIZED POSITION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SPECIALIZED
TRAINING INSTITUTE- WE ACTUALLY
THE SECOND QUESTION IS- THAT-
THIS IS THE- PRIMARY- MARKET SHE
MANAGEMENT TRAINING CENTER FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BOB
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THERE IS-
OTHER TRAINING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN. ACQUIRE BIG
CAN'T GO- FOR EXAMPLE LIKE TEXAS
A AND M. AND SOME OF THE OUT OF
STATE- TRAINING CONSORTIUMS THAT
ARE PART OF THE- DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY SAQQAQ
OUTWARDS- CAN PROVIDE TRADING AS
WELL AS- BOB MAPLE POSTGRADUATE
SCHOOL. IN MONTEREY BOB
HERTZBERG D. C. MANAGEMENT
CONSTRUCT AND NOT ALL HAZARDS
STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AS OUTLINED
STATURE IT- CSPI IS THE PRIMARY
STOCK. OKAY THANK YOU FOR THOSE
STRAIGHTFORWARD ANSWERS- I WOULD
HOPE THAT ALEJO COULD SIT DOWN
AND YOU GUYS COME TO A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS IS THAT WE
HAVE- SO THAT WE HAVE CONFIDENCE
MOVING FORWARD IN THE DOLLARS
THAT WE ALLOCATING WE SEE
OURSELVES AS YOUR PARTNER. WE
WANT YOU TO BE SUCCESSFUL I'M
CALLING THIS THAT THAT YEAR
AFTER YEAR THE NUMBER OF
EMERGENCIES HAPPEN GROWING-
WHETHER IT'S ON WILDFIRES AND
THAT SEASON AS LONG LONGER JUST
THREE MONTHS BUT IT FEELS LIKE
IT'S YEAR ROUND. I AM EACH YEAR-
WE ARE SETTING NEW RECORDS AND
SO PLANNING FOR THOSE RECORDS
MAKES IT HARD I UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN OUR DATA POINTS KEEP
CHANGING THOSE PROJECTIONS ALSO
CHANGE. ALONG THE WAY AND SO WE
TRY TO BE FAIR IN IN THIS
COMMITTEE BUT- I THINK THAT
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT. AND ANSWERING
SERVICES ARE IMPORTANT SO THAT
GIVEN THE INFORMATION WE HAVE WE
CAN BE CONFIDENT AT THAT AT THIS
POINT. WITH THE REALITY THAT WE
MIGHT HAVE TO CONTINUE TO ADJUST
pAND BE FLEXIBLE AS SEVERAL
CONTINUES TO CHANGE OUT THERE
WHETHER IT'S ON WILDFIRES- HE
EMERGENCY BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. EARTHQUAKES THAT WERE
ALL EXPECTING AT SOME POINT ARE
OR THE MANY OTHER MANY-
EMERGENCIES THAT YOUR OFFER THAT
YOUR OFFICE- WORKS WITH ON- AND
RESPONSE TO ON A REGULAR BASIS
OUT THERE AND SO I DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WORK THAT YOU
DO. I DO ALL THE KNOWLEDGE IS
BECOME MORE MORE COMPLEX OVER
THE YEARS- I DO HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION. AND ANSWER EACH
OTHER'S QUESTIONS THAT WE AT THE
END OF THE DAY HAVE A FOR A
PRODUCT THAT WE HAVE ALL WE CAN
ALL BE CONFIDENT ED. I'M GONNA
ASK THE L. A. O. TO ADD ANY. ARE
THAT THEY WANT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I DID WANT TO JUST
CLARIFY- IN TERMS OF THE
STRATEGIC PLAN. AND THERE MIGHT
BE A BIT OF A MISCOMMUNICATION
THIS STRATEGIC PLAN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS. TALKING ABOUT IS
THERE SORT OF OVERALL DEPARTMENT
STRATEGIC PLAN IT'S A IT'S A
BRIEF COUPLE PAGE DOCUMENT ON
THEIR WEBSITE- AND CERTAINLY
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT DOCUMENT FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE- BY THE TYPE
OF STRATEGIC PLAN THAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING IS LASSEN
ORGANIZATIONAL STRATEGIC PLAN
AND SPECIFICALLY A STRATEGIC
PLAN. FOR ENHANCING THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY AND
SO THE TYPE OF STRATEGIC
PLANNING WORK THAT IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR MY- YES DOESN'T
IDENTIFY THOSE FOUR KEY ELEMENTS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT ON IN TERMS
OF OUR OFFICES- RESEARCHING THIS
TOPIC WE DID REACH OUT TO- YES
AND ASK THEM IF THEY HAD. SUCH A
PLAN THAT PROVIDED THIS
INFORMATION AND WE DID NOT
RECEIVE A RESPONSE. THANK YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
WILL KEEP WORKING ON THIS ITEM
AND THE STRATEGIC PLAN AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO. THE DEPARTMENTS
OF RESPONSE TO THE LANGUAGE THAT
STAFF PROVIDED- ALSO- AND SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND WRAP UP
TODAY'S. ISSUES I DO WANT TO
THANK ALL DEPARTMENTS FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND PREPARING- IN
SUCH SHORT NOTICE. AS WELL SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS-
AND THE- WE'RE GONNA START WITH
FOR THE COMING HERE IN THE ROOM
. FROM MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MIKE CARROLL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. AND
WE- ONCE- CONCUR WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WE HEARD EARLIER
ABOUT CARE COURT FROM. YOURSELF
MADAM CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE EMILIO WE TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ROLE OF THE JUDICIARY IN THIS
PROCESS. WE DO SEE JUSTIFICATION
FOR INVOLVING THEM IN DURING
CLINICAL. DECISIONS AND WE WOULD
URGE THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
PROPER TIME TO REJECT THE
FUNDING REQUEST MADE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN LASTLY
WE JUST WANT TO- WE'RE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THIS BUDGET
DOES NOT INCLUDE A FULL REPEAL
OF CIVIL ASSESSMENTS IN TRIAL IN
TRAFFIC COURTS. WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL- BRING UP AGAIN
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AGAIN
TO. FULLY GET RID OF CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS IN THE HARM THAT
THEY DUE TO LOW INCOME AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WITH THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON. THE PHONE. THE
NUMBER IS AVAILABLE IF YOU'RE
STREAMING THE HEARING ON YOUR
WEBSITE. IT'S ALSO YOU COLIN AT
THE NUMBER. 877-692-8957 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. ADAM
OPERATOR- AND JUST A REMINDER A
PUBLIC COMMENT IS LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE PER PERSON. ADAM OPERATOR
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE'LL START WITH LIGHT NINE
PEOPLE AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
RIO SHIRE FROM AN ATTORNEY AT
THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS TO THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AND I'M CALLING TO URGE YOU
ALL TO PRIORITIZE THE
ELIMINATION OF DOUBLE ATTACK
MEANT AS WE ALL KNOW THESE ARE A
PERNICIOUS THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR
LATE FEE IMPOSED BY MOST OF THE
TRAFFIC COURT. AND EVEN THOUGH
THE MAY REVISE DID NOT
INTRACTABLE ATTACHMENT WE REALLY
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP
THAT THE HIGH PRIORITY AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO FINALIZE THE
BUDGET- THEHARM OF CIVIL
ASSESSMENT ARE PLENTY ARE WE
THANK YOU DATA SHOWING THAT.
HIGH NUMBER OF PEOPLE MORE THAN
70% HAVE TO CUT INTO THEIR
GROCERY CARTS AND RENT COSTS AND
UTILITIES CAUGHT IN ORDER TO
AFFORD THESE LATE FEES- IT ALSO
WE HAVE DATA SHOWING THAT MOST
PEOPLE OVER 70% DON'T EVEN
REALIZE THEY CAN BE PENALIZED
WITH ONE OF THESE LATE FEES
WHAT'S THE JACK BUT THEY REALLY
ARE NOT AN EFFECTIVE DETERRENT
TO NON APPEARANCE IN COURT- SO
DO YOU. SEVERAL ATTACHMENT
ESPECIALLY HARM LOW INCOME BLACK
AND BROWN CALIFORNIANS A LOT OF
THE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET IS REALLY
ENDEAVORING TO LIFT UP- AND IF
WE CONTINUE TO PENALIZE PEOPLE
WITH THESE GROUPS FROM LATE FEES
WILL ONLY BE TAKING AWAY THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES FROM THEM
THAT THE BUDGET SEEKS TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH SO PLEASE AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD IN BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE GOVERNOR- PLEASE REMIND
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE
ARE OTHER WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO APPEAR IN COURT THERE
ARE BETTER WAYS ALREADY
AVAILABLE. AND THAT CONTINUING
TO IMPOSE THESE AWFUL FEES ONLY
UNDERMINES THE OTHER EFFORT THAT
WE ARE MAKING TO SUPPORT LOW
INCOME. CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS DANIEL
SANCHEZ I'M THE OPPOSITE SHE
PROBATION OFFICERS- IN SUPPORT
TODAY OF THE PROPOSAL AND THE ME
REVISED FOR TWENTY MILLION FOR
MOBILE PROBATION CENTERS TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS ON PROBATION WITH
MEETING OUR COURTORDERED
REQUIREMENTS BY REMOVING
TRANSPORTATION AND TECHNOLOGY
BARRIERS AND REALLY FOCUSING ON
MEETING INDIVIDUALS WHERE THEY
ARE TO HELP THEM BE SUCCESSFUL-
COMPLETE COURT CHECK INS AND
LINK THEM WITH SERVICES AND
PROGRAMMING. MANY OF THE
TRANSPORTATION BARRIERS AND
IMPACT OF HOMELESSNESS ALONG
WITH CO THE NINETEEN HAVE REALLY
UNDERSCORED THE NEED FOR
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES WE SEE
THIS AS AN IMPORTANT WAY TO
INCREASE CONNECTIONS AND ACCESS
TO ALTERNATELY HELP INDIVIDUALS
ON PROBATION BE SUCCESSFUL IN
THEIR PROBATION AND REENTRY. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK BRIEFLY
TO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
THE HUNDRED MILLION FOR COUNTY
JUVENILE FACILITY MODERNIZATION
THIS FUNDING IS VITAL THE
UPDATING AND MODERNIZING
FACILITIES IN ORDER TO SERVE AND
SUPPORT USED IN OUR LOCAL
FACILITIES PURSUANT TO THE
RESPONSIBILITIES GIVEN TO
PROVISION THE SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE WE WILL ALSO CALL
ATTENTION TO TWO OTHER BUDGET
REQUEST WE PUT BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE. ARE
THE FIRST BEING TWENTY NINE
MILLION AND PLANNING GRANTS TO
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO INVEST
TIME IN DEVELOPING LONGER TERM
VISION FOR LOCAL JUVENILE
JUSTICE CONTINUE ONES AND ONE
BILLION OR A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM TO ALLOW PROBATION
APARTMENTS TO APPLY FOR FUNDING
TO CARRY OUT THE VISIONARY PLANS
DEVELOPED AS A RESULT OF THE
PLANNING GRANTS. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING FURTHER WITH THIS AND
THAT WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. LEVINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR NUMBERS BUT I THINKING ON
BEHALF THE SACRAMENTO
METROPOLITAN FIRE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF ADVOCATES REQUEST FOR
SUPPORT FOR THE BUILD OUT OF AN
URGENTLY NEEDED FIRST RESPONDER
TRAINING FACILITY TO BE
CENTRALLY LOCATED IN RANCHO
CORDOVA THE FIRM COOLEY IS
CHAMPIONING THAT'S REQUESTING
THIS ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF
FORTY FOUR MILLION WILL HELP
TRAIN THE NEXT GENERATION OF
FIRST RESPONDERS ON CRITICAL
OPERATIONS CENTER THE OPERATION
POP IN THE EVENT OF NATURAL
DISASTER RESPONSE INCLUDING
WILDFIRES. DISABILITY WOULD BE
UNIQUE TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TO COURT THE MANY FIRE
DISTRICT STATEWIDE NO. DEFEATED
COMPLETED IN THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHT HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CORY CELLS ALONG BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS PROPOSAL
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES REGARDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL AID SUPPORT
TO HELP WITH THE COST OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE TO
EMERGENCIES INCLUDING WILDFIRES.
WERE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL REGARDING
OFFICE FOR WELLNESS HI WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT BOTH ITEMS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ZERO NINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I ASSURE GARCIA
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR DISNEY
WANTS DISCUSSION TODAY- MY NAME
IS SEAN YOUNG THAT I WORK WITH A
FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT THE
OFFICE OF THE SEPARATIST OF
TREASURER I'M CALLING IN TODAY
AS PART OF THE DEBT FREE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA COLLECTIONS
RESPECTIVELY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE. TO PRIORITIZE
COMPLETELY ELIMINATING THE
SUPPORT DOCUMENT MIKE ECHO
WESTERN CENTER AND I'M MORE TO
PLAYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS- COMMENTED AT THAT
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT LEVYING
SKY HIGH FEES COMPELS PEOPLE- TO
PAY TICKETS OR APPEAR IN COURT I
WOULD RATHER THE SIMPLE STUFF
SPENT I'M FURTHER BURDEN LOW
INCOME FOLKS AND BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES INESCAPABLE DEBT-
THE CIVIL STUFF THAT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE STATE
AND THE COURTS MAKING MONEY OFF
OF PEOPLE WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD.
YOU CAN SUPPORT IT- IN THE
ASSEMBLY BETTER WAYS TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO APPEAR IN
COURT FOR PAYING THEIR FEES-
THAN BURDENING THEM WITH DEBT
THAT THEY SIMPLY CANNOT PAY- OUR
COALITION IS CALLING ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO COMPLETELY
ELIMINATE THE CIVIL SUSPECT NOT
JUST CUT IT IN HALF. YOUR SIZE
ELIMINATING IT IN ONGOING-
BUDGET BUDGET DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE GOVERNOR IT IS THE ONLY
ADEQUATE SOLUTION TO INVEST IN
THE WILD AND SAFETY WALK AROUND
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU RYAN TO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS STEPHEN KING- I'M A
RETIRED LEGAL AID LAWYER FROM
BAY AREA LEGAL AID I ORKED
THERE FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS ON
EMPLOYMENT PUBLIC BENEFITS
ISSUES AND EYESORE CLIENT AFTER
CLIENT. WHOSE LIFE WAS DESTROYED
BY FLORENCE IN CIVIL ASSESSMENTS
IF IT'S CHAU COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
TO BE TRYING TO SQUEEZE THIS
MONEY OUT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOSING THEIR CARS AND THEN
LOSING THEIR JOBS. IN AS HAVE
SAID THE FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
. COMMITTEE IN THE COALITION OF
ITS- I'M NOT GOING TO COLLECT
THE MONEY IT'S UNCOLLECTIBLE AND
IT'S ONLY FEW. IT'S CAUSING
PEOPLE TO LOSE THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSES AND THEY'RE LARGE SHIP
FALLING APART SO PLEASE. S. C.
GOVERNOR TO REACH BACK INSTEAD
THE ELIMINATION OF. THE
DIVERSITY IS THE REDUCTION WAS
APPRECIATED BUT IT'S NOT A NO
JUST HAVE TO GO SO ARE
APPRECIATED YOU- DOING YESTERDAY
IT. WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR IN OTHER- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRANDON GREEN
DIRECTORATES MAKING ONLY JUST
THE PROGRAM AT THE FIGURE GLOBAL
CALIFORNIA. I LIKE MY OTHER DEBT
PROJECTED COLLEAGUES IN CALLING-
ASKING BAD. THE COMMITTEE IN
OTHERS PRIORITIZE. OF THE WILL
AFFECT ME. WHICH REPRESENT THE
RACIALIZED. WHAT THE STRIKING
COMPLEXLY BURKE LEE AND THE
MANIFESTATION OF FRESH BY POLICE
AND HAVE IT SET UP IN OUR
TRAFFIC COURT. WE KNOW THE BOAT
BROUGH- THE RACIAL PROFILING AT
DATA FROM IT WELL THAT THE OTHER
ANECDOTAL. DATA A GOOD BLACK
FOLKS AND BROKE THE PULLED OVER
A DISCORDANT RATES WHICH MEANS
THE BAY OUR FIND A
DISPROPORTIONATE RATE WE KNOW
THAT YOU'RE NOT HELP PEOPLE GET
TO COURT. IN ELIMINATION OF THE
IF THAT ARE BETWEEN LINE WITH A
LOT OF THE CONVERSATION- ON
BEHALF MONEY TO HAPPEN AT THE
REPARATION PASSPORT AND OTHER
BRAZEN THE LEGISLATION WITH THE
FACT THAT OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS SOME THOUGHT I ALONG WITH
COUNTY COURT ACCORDING. ASKING
FOR THE FULL ELIMINATION OF
FILLED WITH ETHNIC WELL A DAY TO
DAY- THAT COMES ALONG WITH THAT
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
COLLECTIBLE IN THE AREA TIME I
DO BEFORE THANK. YOU FORTY
PACKARD BLACK AND BROWN- UNDER
KOBE I THE THOUGHT OF FINANCE
WILL BE WOULD A LONG WAY. IN
TERMS OF- I PEOPLE TO LOOK FOR A
LOT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FOR COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT LOOK BECAUSE
PUBLIC COMMENT- ARE ALMOST AT
AND READ THE FINAL VOTE FOR THE
ISSUES WE WENT ON EARLIER.
ASSETS ON THE RECORD SO ARE
THESE ARE ALL OUR VOTE ONLY
ISSUE ITEMS ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THE VOTE WAS FIVE ZERO. ISSUE
NUMBER TWO THE VOTE WAS. THREE
TO. THE ICE TURNOS. ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY. THE BUT WITH THE ICE TO
NOT VOTING. ISSUE NUMBER. FOUR
THE VOTE WAS FIVE ZERO FIVE FIVE
. ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE VOTE WAS
FIVE ZERO FIVE VICE. ISSUE
NUMBER SIX THE VOTE WAS FIVE
ZERO FIVE ICE. ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN THE VOTE WAS FIVE FIVE
FIVE ZERO. FINAL VOTE ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT THE VOTE WAS FIVE
ZERO FIVE ICE. ISSUE NUMBER NINE
THE VOTE WAS THREE I TO NOT
VOTING. ISSUE NUMBER TEN THE
VOTE WAS THE ICE TO KNOW. ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN THE VOTE WITH. FOR
I ONE MALE. ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
THE VOTE WAS. THREE S. ONE KNOW
WHEN UPLOADING. SHE NUMBER
THIRTEEN THE VOTE WAS THREE GUYS
TO KNOW. ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
THE VOTE WAS FIVE VICE. THERANOS
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN THE VOTE
WAS FIVE EYES SERRANO'S. SHE
NUMBER SIXTEEN THE VOTE WAS FIVE
VICE SERRANO'S. ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THE VOTE WAS FIVE VICE
THROW KNOWS AN ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN THE VOTE WITH BYE BYE
CENTER LOS ALL ISSUES ARE OUT
AND WITH THAT WE WILL RETURN TO
THIS MEETING THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY.